Heat. [music]
[music]
Hey, Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hi B here with RQ. Joining me is Silvin,
frontman for our Polish delegation. I
will say Riftbound super fanar
hype beast. How are we feeling today,
>> bro? I'm right now I'm flattered, you
know. Very good. The overall feeling
here is insane. A lot of people like I
would say this weekend we'll have what
3,000 4,000 people in this venue. It's
insane. It's insane.
>> It is absolutely crowded. Everyone is
bringing their agame not just to this
event. You've been bringing your agame
for a while starting in Bologn
>> from day one. From day one from
>> from day one.
>> Now just to kind of what what drives
that passion to join all of these events
with all the passion that you have.
>> I can speak just for me that I I've been
a shotcaster for League of Legends. For
me, League of Legends was my whole life
to be fair. Uh my current situation in
life is because I was so close with
League of Legends. So when I see Rebound
coming, I just decided like I love card
games. I love League of Legends. It's
the two best things for me to be
connected. So, I just love the people,
love the energy, love the game,
everything here.
>> And it's not only coming from you
because every time we see you, you are
surrounded by Polish brethren and
sisters bringing all of the energy. Is
that something inherent to just the
Polish community in itself?
>> Okay, I'm give me this microphone. Give
me Give me I'm not going to lie. I'm not
going to lie. In Poland, Reebound is
like the biggest thing. Everyone's so
hyped. We have a local tournaments with
100 people. Uh we love to be
competitive. We love to play casually.
And the fact that I'm surrounded with
these people. It's just because they
love to come here and have fun. It's
just because of that. But the point is
since day one, we heard that Rebound is
coming. Rebound was hyped up in Poland.
We just love that. I mean it it shows so
clearly from the energy you bring, the
energy that everyone brings to each and
every single event. Now I mean whenever
you bring up opponent you have to talk
Allan and you were there in Bolognia
when he lifted his very first trophy.
How did that feel as a spectator to see
to see that happen right in front of
you?
>> No matter this sport let's let's say
rebound is sport right. No matter this
sport we love rooting for our
representatives
>> and seeing this goat playing in the
tournaments. It just give us this this
this dopamine rush every time. And not
only him we have many talented players.
We have BKE, we have Shiku, we have
Sebic that come second in uh in Bologna
as well. So Alan is just very prominent
tip of tip of the an iceberg.
>> So now that he has not only quite his
first trophy, but his second trophy
[music] and is now hunting for his
third,
does he will he get it in Utre, his
third trophy?
>> Hear me out. Hear me out. Not only utre
from this spot I can say that Allan will
be the first world champion of rebound.
Right. Right. [cheering]
>> I can tell you that. I can tell you
that.
>> I think it's very clear he clearly has
the support not only from you but
everyone around us. Now I'm going to
have to ask how many of your friends did
you bring along for today?
>> 200 people I think in total here is like
I don't know maybe 100. There a lot of
people still waiting for the on demands
at this point coming to the venue but I
think easily like what
200 people from Poland at least at
least.
>> And are they just as passionate as you
are?
champion
>> keep [screaming]
[cheering]
>> but of course other players as well as
well you know you know
>> we're we're cheering for everyone in top
eight however there can be absolutely no
doubt about the passion that the Polish
delegation is bringing I'm going to
bring it up one more time guys
>> how feeling
[cheering] wait
magic.
>> Just one last thing. One last thing. One
last thing.
>> One last thing.
>> In Poland right now, we have this uh
thing ontopia. If you are not going to
have a great weekend, not a good
tournament, you are going n. But if you
are feel, if you are feeling lock in, if
you feeling prepared, you are going to
park pass. And this weekend we are
definitely going to Park Park. Let's go.
>> Thank you very much. Thank you
>> everyone. Thank you so much for showing
up. Absolutely wonderful experience.
Best of luck today.
>> Ah, it is hard not to be hyped with the
Polish contingent always in the
building. Um, always always exciting.
James here with Bandit. We do have a few
minutes before we get to the next round.
So, you are going to be stuck with us
for just a little bit longer before we
get you some more riffound. But that was
a fun interview that
>> they are electric. I I I I will say the
audio doesn't do justice. When they were
in the hall, it was deafening. The
entire people were like, "Is
>> are we okay?"
>> Speaking of microphones, uh shout out to
you not giving up the microphone. Uh
[laughter]
>> that's always dangerous when someone's
like, "Give me that microphone." I'm
like, "No,
>> I was like 14 when it happened to Shocks
and Xeek. [laughter]
Uh never
>> stealing the mic." Ah, classic moments
to learn from.
>> That is esports history.
>> It is. It is. Uh, and I mean esports
history and and history through League
of Legends. You you heard uh how
passionately they were talking about uh
how much League of Legends means to
them. I mean it's very similar
background for myself where like coming
from casting League and being a Trading
Card Games fan my entire life and being
like ah there's a game that's both. This
is perfect. And now here we are three
RQs in with with Riftband. It's it's
amazing. The community is amazing
though. It it feels so special because
it feels like it should be a niche.
People that are really into League of
Legends and also do card games and then
you enter a hall and it's filled with
thousands upon thousands of people who
all share that well not so niche any
longer.
>> Yeah. And my favorite thing is and I'm
sure those of you at home that go to
your Nexus nights and skirmishes uh see
players that show up and they're like,
"Hey, I'm here because I play League,
but I've never played a card game
before. Like, can you help me? Can you
teach me?" And of course you're like,
"Yes, yes, of course I'm going to help
you." Yes, I will uh you know get you up
to speed with how trading card games
work and you can see how many people
have filled our venue here this weekend
and that is kind of the part that I
really really like because people can be
a little hesitant like oh I kind of want
to get started and the welcoming nature
of everywhere I've been is like here is
a deck take a seat this is how it goes
so are you familiar with the alphabet
ABC D like it's [laughter]
such a warm experience
from from head to tail.
>> Yeah. And I've seen a lot of people um
kind of paying it forward in their
Riftbound journey. A lot of people will
be like, "Hey, I cracked a box. I've
already got my commons and comments that
I need from it. I don't need them." So,
uh local game community who who needs
stuff who who wants this? Here's a box
of like bulk cards that I've already got
in my collection. See that all the time.
Uh love the community spirit. Uh
interacting with everybody here and in
your local game store is just so fun. I
think some people don't expect it. Some
people don't expect to walk into an
environment is super friendly, whereas
you're like, "No, this isn't solo queue.
This I don't have to fight anything."
>> The internet told me you were all rude.
[laughter]
>> Everybody Everybody is lovely. And
everybody here at the RQ is lovely as
well. We did have a last few couple of
matches finishing up at the end of round
four. So, of course, as we go through
overtime, we got to do pairings. Got to
get everybody at the thousands of
PlayStations here. like the setups where
you've got your number table, you got to
find the exact place to be. Um, looking
around the venue, I'm seeing a lot of
Mari. We've talked about that and we'll
continue on other things. Uh, we haven't
seen too much in the way of Aurelia in
our cast, but we know that there are
players in in the hall playing
>> allegedly, which I always think is a
very good like Swiss portion of the
tournament deck. It tends to in the same
way that E does be quite consistent. uh
didn't really change too much in this
set. So, if you owned it in Spirit
Forge, you're like, "Oh, okay. I can
play most of the same stuff."
>> That does kind of hint at that there's
another portion in the tournament where
Aurelia might do a little worse.
>> Yeah, it does. Um, Urelia doesn't
necessarily have like a lower ceiling,
but especially through Arc Leil and
Bolognia, what we saw was the Aurelia
and the Kaisers would beat up on other
decks on the Swiss portion where you'd
maybe just win from consistency. But
something like uh an Azia or a Diana or
in Spirit forge Meta of Ezreal would be
like, "Hey, I can actually out maneuver,
out position you, out think you, out
resource you." And Aurelia is like,
well, I can move around the battlefields
and I can draw cards.
>> Well,
whilst also dominating you and pay one
mana to, oh, that's a five energy might
swing. It
>> the ceiling is so clear on Aurelia. And
to see it perform at the highest level
is a humbling experience to to be going
through. It's just has the momentum
shifted now?
>> Yes. Uh there are a couple of Aurelas
that show up in our best of the best
list or at least as you go further down
the list as well, but you can see a
relatively diverse range of legend
picks. Of course, there are a couple of
names on top of this. We've spoken a lot
about Allan. We will speak more about
Allan and Prismat as well. We got to
Sami Sherman who of course with the
Rengar I don't believe is in the
building this weekend is likely gearing
up for H um I was going to say Houston,
but that is time traveling for Houston.
It's Hartford. the other H city as yeah
Sam on that Rengar and as we go through
one player that I I think is noteworthy
that isn't quite on this list uh we've
spoken a little bit to Ghostaster Driver
who does have two top eights to his name
as well he is tenacious in his runs and
every time I I do see him pass by again
I was like
>> he will always be stuck in my head as
the Victor player from back in Bolognia
that got robbed I'm telling you he
should that match Okay, [laughter]
>> it's fine. I'm doing okay. We're we're
He in my head was always known as the
Victor player.
>> But over the the RQs time and time
again, he has shown his diversity. He
has shown that he has mastered a a
platitude of decks. And honestly, I'm
kind of I'm kind of hedging to see him
once again make a deep run.
>> Yeah, I'm sure we'll uh keep a track of
Ghost of Driver over the weekend. Um, we
are only going into round five coming
up. So, we if we haven't seen your
favorite deck or your favorite player,
it's okay. We'll get there. We'll get
there as long as they stay in the
tournament. That's the thing. Um, you
know that it's always fun being in this
competitive environment where you can
expect big results out of a player, but
sometimes it's just not their day. Um,
we've seen that from multiple players.
Like, we've had tournaments where we're
like, "Well, Allan's going to crush
through." and whether it's the draw
through the the the Swiss portion or the
matchups that line up and you're like,
"Oh, Alan didn't make it as far as you
would expect, but then comes back to
like the next event and wins."
>> Here's the thing. uh despite and and
that's not trying to to to push it all
off on that, but these large multi-ur
day tournaments kind of similar to other
uh knockout styleish and Swissish uh
tournaments,
>> it demands so much of you and a a single
extra loss of just ricking out on your
deck or running into that one poor
matchup or
>> you're just a little distracted and not
fully in it. a single slip up can can
mean the end of a run. And especially in
the early portions of the tournament,
you have to be very mindful of the fact
that you definitely cannot win the
tournament in the first few rounds, but
you can squander it all.
>> Yeah, you can miss out on that top eight
spot quite quite easily with just one,
as you said, uh game where it just
doesn't draw. And that's one of the
reasons why traditionally in card games
when we look at player performance over
a long scale of time when we're looking
at multiple tournaments and we're
talking now into the years um we measure
in top eights. It's not just about wins.
We measure in like okay this player
historically has had four top eights and
that already is an accomplishment in its
own right. So as we have more events for
Riftbound I think we'll start to see
that balance out of like hey this play
may not have won but look at how
consistent they've been. It is really
that big picture that is kind of hard to
get a real feel of right now because the
big picture is
>> eight nine months. Exactly. Even though
I feel like we we've been already
through so many phases of both gameplay
and and events being covered,
>> we're not even a year old.
>> And still in the early portion of the
game where some people would say ah the
field is a little softer cuz people are
just not as experienced. And when we you
do have the resources to really commit
to really start studying that is when
the results get daunting. That is what
we are in right now.
>> But I love to see that people are not
being scared away by that. We still see
people stay true to their own legends
and find success on it and then be
celebrated and rewarded for it. Yeah.
You know what? I'm so glad that you're
talking about like the number of
different decks that we have, the the
scale of competition and the uniqueness
because there are a lot of unique decks
here at RQ Utre. We spoke to some of the
players about their picks.
Welcome back to Quick Decks at the RQ in
Utre for Riftbound. Welcome. I'm joined
by Jabin. At this format, players are
going to have 30 [music] seconds to
explain their decks to me. Jabin, what
deck are you running?
>> I am playing Pike, the Blood Harbor
Ripper. I'm just really obsessed with
this play style. I've tried a bunch of
decks in Unleashed, [music] but the
discard mechanic that Pike really abuses
is just too satisfying a loop to play.
>> That sounds great. I'm going to start
the timer in three, two, one, go.
>> Okay, core cards of Pike. Obviously,
this is the big one. Bewitching Spirit.
There's something particularly evil, I
think, about making your opponent choose
what they want to discard that is so
much more fun than like Mindsplitter.
So, that's a really satisfying one.
Obviously like the champion unit. I
think a lot of decks like the champion
unit is kind of an addendum, but this
one is really really significant.
Accelerate [music] out, get points like
that, steal points, really really
valuable. And I think the last big one
for me is Baron Nasher. I think Pike is
probably the second best deck behind
Diana and playing it. But ramping to
this, getting it out and using it as a
windcon really.
>> Stop. All right. Wow, that was really,
really loud. Okay, you hit the 30se
secondond mark. So, let me summarize
this a little bit for you. You like to
discard cards from your opponent. You
like to bounce those cards. You steal
points. You steal their cards in hand.
Then you bounce them and you do it all
again. Is that about right?
>> That nails it. Yeah. Bewitching spirit
number one.
>> All right, we got it. Thank you so much
for your 30 seconds of time, Jin. And
we're going back to the action.
I I tell you this is my entire world's
collide because those of you at home
that may not recognize Jabin with a name
change by the way is a European Wild
Rift champion and I cast one of their
wins in Wild Drift European
Championships. Um it's it's everything's
colliding. It's great. But the good news
is you're back with myself and Bandit
and that means we are closing in on our
fifth round of games. Players are
getting set up on stage. Uh, great vibes
in the arena. That was a Pike deck. Uh,
which we cast a Pike deck earlier. Very
interesting series. Oh, it I like a deck
that has many options available to it
because I feel the skill expression in a
deck that is time and time given options
to adapt to the situation that is
unfolding in front of them allows for a
game sense to be rewarded where you will
always have all right maybe I can't win
from here on uh from through through
this point but losing the minimum in a
great many situations
>> should feel like winning making your
opponent pay the absolute most for
winning a single showdown. Don't want to
call back constantly, but round one.
Yeah. Right. Overinvesting into a single
showdown only to be left exhausted. That
is what a pike that can do so well. Kind
of bait you forward like, "Oh, maybe if
you have one more pump spell, you might
live." Oh, one more pump. No. you were
saying uh earlier we were talking about
the Aurora matchup and you're like
Aurora players uh every time, how did
you put it about the cost?
>> So when you're not finding Aurora, you
either have two options available to
you. You can either play for the non-
Aurora game, just hard cast the mind
spplitter or you keep digging. And well,
it turns out that 99% of Aurora players
stop digging for Aurora when it's right
on top of their deck. So don't be part
of that group. You you are you are the
worst kind of player when I'm sat across
the table at Aurora hating that I
haven't like keep digging. Come on.
>> It's almost there.
>> Keep digging. [laughter] And then I'm
the worst kind of player that's like hey
I'm playing Aurora and we're just
playing a friendly at that point.
>> Like tying a stick in front of you on
string the Aurora like always out of
reach.
>> I as I said earlier I've swapped to Vex.
I I enjoy making decisions more so than
on curve ramp into my deck doing
everything for me. So I I think I'm I'm
I'm officially parking Aurora for now.
I'm a little contrary as well. So I'm
like, other people are playing it. I
don't want to play that deck right now.
>> You do have the out, though. It's like,
no, no, no, no. I'm not I'm not a slave
to the meta. It's market research.
[laughter]
I'm just doing science, guys. Trust me.
>> Exactly. I hope we're doing some weird
science in this next round cuz when we
were looking at the decks that were
still in the tournament, I think the the
moment that we start hitting 4 and 0 in
in that round is where we might start
seeing some some fun stuff make a run.
Uh we get a lot of the meta decks that
reach this point and we're like, "Okay,
cool. We're going to see Master, we'll
see Aurelia, we'll see um you know,
we'll see some Leblancs as well
throughout the the rest of the day." I
think I think we will. I think there's
enough good players in the room that
some should be making. I mean, what was
it like eight eight% of the field?
>> Yeah. Yeah, it was up there. It was one
of the it was on the first half of the
graphic. So,
>> and I mean, if you're talking about
decks that have a plethora of decisions,
Leblanc has to be up there.
>> Yeah. As we are, sorry, I was just
getting the word that we are coming up
soon with our matchup, but it is
essentially the point I was going to go
back to at the beginning. Apologies,
Bandit, is that now is where we start
building the stories of our best offs.
Because if someone's 4-0 on a unique
pick, um you you start getting towards
that moment of like, hey, a six and0 is
like you're really close to to
guaranteeing that being in contention
for a best
>> for just uh some some frame of
reference, right? On certain legends, I
think it was either Sydney
>> uh for instance, uh four wins on either
the Rumble or the Jin was enough to
secure your best off. So we are getting
into the point where you will be looking
over your shoulder making sure that your
closest competitor what are they doing
all right they won as well or maybe one
more win will pull me across the line
let's hope they get matched up into like
Allen or something [laughter] really
yeah let's hope they get paired up like
way up [laughter]
that's always always the case as we are
going into uh this matchup so the player
names are swapped but We have, would you
believe it, a jin that is 4 and 0. If
you could write that story line any
better.
>> I I'm I'm glad we got such talented
writers uh here working for us. Now, I
do have a very important question. So,
Jin Foro, very good. However, does that
mean he's at his peak right now or this
is the reload game?
>> Uh that's really probably reloading.
Game four was the big hit and now we're
like, "Oh, okay." It's that awkward spot
where you're running around in lane not
doing anything and hoping that it
reloads quicker.
>> Just a little more, guys. M I'm Trust
me, it's going to be really good again.
>> On the other side, uh we do get a
Leblanc as we were saying. It's one of
those matchups that with today we're
expecting to see one of those decks I
should say expecting to see some
presence of. um whether it does enough
different things to compete with the top
decks like a Diana and in some respects
uh the way that EI plays, I'm not 100%
sure. We haven't seen it quite enough
performing at the the top tables.
There's there's just there's different
schools of thought regarding the the
Leblanc and they can't seem to get to a
unified
>> deck was like no this is the best one.
But on one hand, you got the baited hook
uh Leblanc players. Yeah.
>> With a
with a fanatic following.
>> Yeah, I was going to say they are quite
quite like decided between themselves
that they know best righteousness
>> hook is the best version of Leblanc to
them and there is no arguing with them
like missionaries. Have you heard of the
great word of baited hook? No, let me
tell you. You got an hour
>> the baited hook emissaries at that
point. Um the other side of of the
argument is just the standard version
which is just like a little bit more
like hey I'll just play Rift
>> which is still incredibly normal.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's interesting. Uh I whether the
consistency is there I think is is a
really uh interesting conversation that
we'll we'll have a look at as we go into
the game. But definitely it's one of
those ones. Every so often you get a
deck that has a couple of different
flavors. And this is one where there are
those two big schools of thought and
until we see the deck lists eventually
we won't actually be able to tell you
which one of the two it is but we will
get there before uh before we actually
get to our featured match.
>> So in this case right um I think
Leblancs are there.
>> Yeah.
>> But maybe I mean you you you told us
before you are aware of the gym player.
You you've had some back and forth.
>> Yeah.
>> To stay on theme. Could could you lift a
bit of the curtain for us?
>> I I can and I will. Uh so Jibs who's
playing Jyn uh is a UK content creator.
So I' I've had the pleasure of meeting
him at many many events. Um I believe he
was actually in Bolognia like placed
around the 70th mark. So a little bit
just outside top.
>> I mean that is a good showing.
>> Yeah. Has has competed at that uh level
of of day two performance um in in the
Jin
>> world. It's not a deck we see very
often. Um
>> world like street
>> as in the Jin the Jin community. Uh
>> there are dozens of them, guys.
[laughter]
>> There there's four of them. Um
essentially what the deck does is you
have to play through the early game um
weather the storm a little bit early on
until the point where you can hit 12
runes, which is a a long way into the
game to be quite fair. But the moment
that you hit 12 runes, you essentially
have a loop of spells on your turn that
allows you to use 12 energy. And then
what happens is the fourth spell that
you cast is gonna end up putting the
spells into the trash.
>> Yes, you get to get banished.
>> Uh what you do is you float four power
by recycling four runes because before
the Jin uh ability happens, you will
draw four readied runes. It is one of
the only abilities that I can think of
in the game that is readied runes and
essentially you then have four and four
and you get to spend 16 energy in a turn
and then you can do it again the next
turn. So the whole point is like you
play big spells like uncheck power you
play I think some gens are playing time
warp that type of thing. So you just
having these massive turns if you get
there it's a big if. I I love this brew
because it feels like it really captures
the mind of a gin, which is well a
daunting thought to be be visualizing.
But if you go like through like the
cinematics and he's like setting up all
these convoluted traps and ah you walk
right into my plan building up to a a
massive
encore almost. Yeah. The absolute max. I
love that you're calling it
>> of uh of of the play where it all comes
together.
>> That is what you need.
>> If it's not already called that, that's
what I'm going to call that a bit.
[laughter] That's so good. I that is
that is so so good.
>> I The one thing I will say uh I've seen
a certain obvious lack of red gins being
played. Whenever whenever red jin gets
to move, first of all, he has to fle by
himself. Whenever he moves, you get an
energy. You get a power to be spending.
I've played against this card and every
time I'm like there that's a good card
to be running and
>> if I could be a fly on the wall for
pattern and why he's not playing the
Jin.
>> That would be such an interesting
thought.
>> Well, I have an interesting followup for
you that this chosen champion is Jin
Meticulous Killer, the blue Jin that
reads, "If you spend four or more to
play a spell this turn, play it for a
blue recycle. no copies in the main deck
of red Jin that does the getting extra
energy for spells. It does read the the
deck archetype on its own reads a little
bit outside of what you might expect the
meta to have. There's things like
falling star in there uh cards like
rocket barrage in the main deck cuz it
allows you to deal with uh dazzling
aurora, that type of thing. We'll take a
look at the deck list.
>> That used to be the answer from from
like Ezreal and the likes. A lot of
these cards have been meta at some
point, but right now in the meta that
we're in with the way that, you know, we
have a lot of RC, we have a lot of
counter spells, that kind of thing. Here
is the deck list for you.
>> Feast your eyes.
>> Feast your eyes on the deck list. Uh
including the uh signature spell,
Curtain Call, which has so many modes on
it you have to remember. You're going to
pay for each of them with a repeat cost.
>> Yes.
So you can either deal sorry draw one
deal two to a unit in the battlefield
deal three to unit in the base or give a
unit in a battlefield minus 4 this I
know a lot of people end up just drawing
a card off this [laughter]
like it's expensive but I just need to
draw a card
>> sometime but that is that is the cost
you should be paying for flexibility
right options come at a cost now
>> this is the part of drink where you're
even more happy you're not paying
against the ghee because if you
>> fully invest
into your signature spell,
>> it can still get the fight,
>> right?
>> And then you will cry yourself to sleep.
>> There's a lot of other things to get
through the early game and and help the
economy. Of course, we have like the
plundering pro uh in there. We have some
some ways to create sprites early on.
So, the early game is just about
creating your economy so you can get to
12.
>> But there is a problem here that is
glaring to me.
>> Sure.
>> Because to when a Leblanc gets the ball
rolling,
>> Yes. It feels rather unstoppable.
>> That's fair.
>> And if you want to stop a Leblanc,
usually you're fielding the gusts. So
you stop them conquering. You can stop
them holding. Once they have once they
have a foot in the door, they're like
vampires. Like once once they're in,
they're not going out.
>> You have to invite Leblanc in. Uh or is
she is she allowed?
>> Uh she she was already in your house.
She mimicked as a chair. So it is it is
baited hook version of uh Leblanc. So,
our first time casting a Leblanc game. I
know that we have seen them obviously in
other regions. So, we'll be uh looking
to guide our way through this. That is a
little bit of a problem for a deck that
is trying to get late. Is Baited Hook is
one of these decks that is like, "Hey, I
want to cheat my way to late game in the
mid game. I want to get there as fast as
possible by, you know, killing a
reflection uh token and and saying,
"Yeah, okay. I'm just going to get that
bigger might unit and suddenly I'm in
the game. and I have massive amount of
cards and I'm able to to to kind of get
the payoff.
>> Is it then a positive note that you are
also possibly facing an aspirin climb
which might inadvertently also benefit
the Jin a little bit more
>> because we're drawing the game longer.
Yeah, potentially. Potentially.
>> I mean, it'll come as no. Uh oh, we're
actually starting out as with Aspen
Crime from Jin's side.
>> Let's go. Yeah, I think the
>> the longer Leblanc can hold off on
committing to Ash Climb, the better it
will be. And I will say I'm looking at
like pre-board the main board, there's
not a lot of like
>> instant speed interaction
speed interaction to be able to deal
with things like the reflection token.
you said about Gust from uh you know
Chaos being able to to deal with things,
but we are in to game one of this series
and then we're looking for priority,
right? We're looking for goals to set
throughout the early game. Yeah. And
then as Leblanc need to get on these
battlefields ASA
B.
>> From there on, you can start
snowballing. You can start to see every
little bit of card in your deck.
>> You need to get there.
>> Yeah. And
>> from what it looks like,
>> it doesn't seem that Jyn can offer much
resistance throughout that early game.
Can he overtake early enough before it
gets out of hand?
>> It's a really good question. Um,
genuinely a good question that I I'm
going to be honest. I I this is one of
these times where I'm not even going to
pretend that I know the direct answer to
that. I'm going to say we haven't seen
Jyn versus Leblanc at this kind of level
of play uh on a feature match. You
haven't prepped for Jin and
>> I've I've you know I've done my
preparation but uh I can't
>> not the meta [laughter] Jin I forgot as
well. Oh no no and honestly that is the
beauty of the game. You can't be
prepared for every single interaction
and that is also the power that a Jim
cuz as you're sitting down to the Blanc
you have absolutely no idea what to
expect here.
>> Somehow they haven't been defeated yet.
>> Yeah. So, an interesting um interesting
I I don't know whether it was a keep or
off the mulligan to have the unchecked
power in hand. We have curtain call. Two
curtain calls actually,
>> but I I feel like the beginning of this
game is mostly just going to be how do I
not
>> curtain call do three damage and draw
one. Okay,
>> three damage and draw one.
>> How do I not spend too much early on?
How do I not recycle as much as possible
in order to to stay in the game? I like
that. I like framing Jyn as an avid
couponer.
>> And I will recycle.
>> He's going through the pamphlets. Oh,
yes. One,
>> two, three, four.
>> And I think this is a matchup we may
very well end up listening in to the
coms a little bit more than we would
normally.
>> I want to play this. Um,
>> always get it.
>> No, I'll pass.
So, Plundering Pro generates a gold
that'll help with that economy on the
staying in the game up until 12. That's
always the problemolution of the spell.
>> Yes. So, as long as I've played four
energy for a um a spell this turn, it
doesn't have to be immediately after I
play the spell. It's it's this turn.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. that again as I said coming into
it the chosen champion can be played for
one blue recycle as long as it is I
think in fact we're talking about the
legend ability where it's paying for it
this turn um a little bit of a the
numbers of four uh getting our wires
crossed for sure
>> what strikes me as a little odd
is that despite
>> the seemingly blossoming economy on the
site of Nox is here. Yeah, with
>> Leblanc,
>> there's not a lot of assets on the field
just yet. And partially
because [clears throat] of the the Jin's
intervention coming through time and
time again,
>> but you kind of have to pick through it.
And even if you get the baited hook out,
>> you get that card rolling.
>> The best [laughter]
>> once you're a Jin main, you really count
in fours. only. Um I think it's good to
to revisit the legend ability. Uh one
thing that I was chatting with Jibs
about is the way of representing the
number of spells that have been uh
banished by the Jin legend ability. Uh
Jibs will layer them under the the Jin
legend just for for posterity just to
say, "Hey, look, here's one." So
>> clear game state.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Curtain call into the watchful sentry.
>> Sure. Uh because it dies, death nail
trigger. Uh not death now, the kill
trigger. Get a gold
>> and they draw one.
>> Yes.
>> And there we go. Second spell again.
>> Once it's more than four, we'll get
tucked under.
>> I will pay two for noxious hopeful.
Trigger star spring on the porro.
>> Of course.
>> Um sorry. And then move here to conquer.
>> Yeah,
>> I would say this early game has been as
clean as you could envision it from this
point.
I am I'm thoroughly enjoying watching on
[laughter] screen because when it's it's
presented to you in this way, all I am
kind of left is that well yeah when you
play it like that it makes a [laughter]
lot of sense that this is working that
you're four on
>> and
>> and vision the top card
>> gets to use a gold token to pay for the
jin from the chosen champion zone
>> but I to the top
>> we do have to make it we have to start
making an impact right now.
>> Sure. Notice that get that Glasmologist
>> is ready to go.
>> Yeah,
>> I can't help but notice that still the
field of Leblanc remains a bit barren.
>> Yeah, it's quite empty for now. Now, of
course, LeBlanc can go from, especially
with Rift Herald, uh can go from empty
battlefield to I'm going to create a
token, sacrifice it, draw two, play a
bunch,
>> and they they have exactly that. And so
there won't even the pure need to
conquer right now is more of a
suggestion. Yes. Very moment.
>> Yeah.
>> So could easily kind of surprise out of
nowhere from the the mirror images and
and that type of approach from the
Leblanc.
>> Yeah. And not committed to to the
champion yet,
>> which is usually something we we come
out quite quickly. Right. The showdown
starts. No,
>> as a reminder, we're in a closed deck
list
>> tournament situation.
>> Out one. I trigger the fever
>> and I think I will discard
an blade.
>> The reason I bring that up is
you might not know about Jin. Like you
might not have the the deck list dialed
into your head. So you're like, they
have one energy available. What could
that be? I I I think that the Jin deck
might be even a better hidden deck than
Teemo
>> because no one knows what's in it. Yeah,
that's that's very fair. So, Rift Herald
will come down. Um not as much impact
this time, but that reflection of course
>> when it starts moving.
>> Yeah, there's going to be a big
>> end game. No, I'm joking. [laughter]
>> of units uh coming soon from the Leblanc
side of things. Of course, Rift Herald
when it does end up the having the death
nail effect trigger. Um and that does
work of course off Reflection of uh Rift
Herald. So
>> yeah, here is
>> seven might. Yeah,
>> where you really have to move yourself
into the shoes of Super Monte here.
Okay,
>> you are
>> in the dark. Yeah, you are just kind of
guessing what will happen next. It's so
hard to anticipate what will transpire
afterwards. And even though Leblanc
decks are in certain situations content
just playing their own game. The baited
hook version is a lot more interest.
>> Yeah.
>> So, consult the pass takes us to three
spells banished.
>> Now, this is now this kind of becomes
about the math on the other side of this
is you'll get four readied runes, but
that would only leave you with five
total energy at this point on this turn
if you were to end up doing it. I know
Jibs was was telling me earlier that you
kind of want to get to 12 and then
you're essentially having 16 energy in a
turn, which
>> You mean to tell me that timing is
everything? Yeah, it it certainly is. Uh
having a time warp helps with that as
well. But there is a curtain call in
hand so has a little bit of that um that
uh versatility
>> and I mean just to to to ponder into the
future a bit the unchecked power already
acquired.
>> I will play a curtain call. I'll pay
five and one um power.
>> Yeah,
>> I'll use the gold and I will not trigger
Jin with it. Um so I will not banish it.
I'll do minus four and two damage and
draw a card.
>> Really importantly, there is a may in
Jin.
>> Okay, draw.
>> The text says you may banish it if you
meet the condition.
>> Put these
one back uh here
>> because the second half of that is n do
the effect. If you banish, the effect
goes on the chain.
>> This one is gone.
And uh that main effect
I have this one in base
but I can play it in here to hold one.
>> Is this correct? You still it should be
correct cuz uh when the mixologist
Deathnell Oh, wait. That's if we're in a
showdown,
>> right?
>> Same up.
>> Uh no, it's it's hot. It's it's Yeah,
it's correct. Death now complain. I am
sensing
>> from super currently.
>> It's cautiousness.
>> I don't make a copy
>> like because and then now we are
assuming things
>> because it's so hard to make sense of
the situation in front of you
>> and you're in in in untreated in
untreated waters. [laughter]
You you have to be have to check
everything double like I don't want to
be caught with my pants down. Yeah. And
as you said so much of it is about
timing as well. So, Rift Herald,
>> three cards
>> and I pick uh Abby.
>> Yep. You can put unit
>> one shuffle.
>> It's a hand reveal. We did see a baited
hook.
>> If
>> you get to the bottom of your deck,
we've done something wrong. [laughter]
>> I will like to conquer the
>> Yep. Yep. I've already put yours point.
Uh three. Yep.
>> Three. And use the the silver effect.
I discard the uh solid scout.
>> I play
>> I do want to bring some attention to the
fact that we are nearing that critical
point for the Jin.
>> Yeah. Where we are hitting that 10 11 12
energy. And there's something actually
to say. We might be playing into Jyn's
hand here. If most of the units like the
Rift Heralds are stacked on the
battlefield and there aren't enough
units in hand to fulfill the death nail
effect of the Rift Heralds, this
unchecked power is going to decimate the
game plan that LeBlanc has. And in
contrast to the Ye, Leblanc loves
overloading her battlefield.
>> Yeah. All aboard the the hold down the
battlefield train.
>> And uh how many cars in Hunt? Three.
>> Three.
>> Three. Oh, there is a carus [laughter]
as well. Um,
oh, of course, Starring with the ruined
Rex allows the Rift Herald to be pulled
back. I believe our players were just
going through it. So, there are options
here.
>> And you got to keep in mind
>> you can't move from four.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter]
>> That's the downside of being a Jin
player is your opponent thinks
everything's funny about 42. you uh you
get for the the rest of the game.
Everybody's going to joke about four.
Oh, that's
>> I have more energy this turn. So, I need
to think ahead. So, I'm 11 with this is
theoretically potentially 15.
>> And so, the plotting begins.
>> 15 energy and rift pound.
>> How does that happen? That's not a
multiple of four. It's not a turn.
Pack it in.
>> And when either of these dies, you play
a unit from hand. Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> And it triggers twice because of this.
>> Exactly. So to be fair, the chances of
his opponent having enough units in hand
to fulfill I it would be unchecked power
on the battlefield. So the one in base
um isn't isn't going to be affected at
this current state. Now the question is
does Jibs test it by for instance uh
singularitying? Do you then if he's at
11 singularities?
>> How many cards in hand?
>> That would leave him with five. He would
have nine energy on the other side of a
singularity once Jyn resolved. You could
singularity
>> and uncheck power in the same turn,
which is disgusting when you think about
that.
>> Yeah, I'd rather not to be honest, but I
I do have to
>> here.
This is why the early game is so
disastrous for Leblanc cuz we said she
need to kind of gets that head start.
But Jin with the curtain calls.
>> I think if you singularity, you have to
singularity the carus as well. I think
it has to be the rift herald and the
carus because the carus otherwise is
going to double for instance ruined rex
death nail trigger and that'll pop
>> the death nail. Where can you play the
unit? Is it anywhere
>> only in base?
>> Only in base. Okay.
>> Or this one only in base.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So jibs just double checking
>> and maybe something else.
>> Okay. Uh I will start with a
singularity. Mhm.
>> I will pay uh gold and a power.
No, I'll pay two. I'll just pay the
power cuz
>> the reason is you'll get four runes when
Jin triggers. You want them ready using
gold here is
>> I'll play uh stupify on this.
>> Okay. You can resolve the stupify. You
can
>> resolve the stupify. Draw one
>> and then
>> and then you hit.
>> Yep.
>> Those will die.
>> It's happening. And I will trigger Jin.
>> Um,
>> I have the effect on stuck if you want.
>> Which effect?
>> The death nail. Yes, the death nail.
>> Uh, I think that does that go first or
do I do this first? Cuz I think they die
then I do the Jin. So I don't think it's
it's not this isn't reaction speed.
>> Is when you play the the spell?
>> Yeah, I've banished it.
>> Mhm. But for to play it as a result,
>> this is a good question of of when does
playing a spell count as playing a spell
with regards to resolution and both
things would put it
>> makes no difference to me, but I was
just asking.
>> So I will play by and I
>> and then I will float one blue energy uh
blue power
>> and then float the blue power and then
uh channel the energy. So I have one
blue power floating. Sorry
>> for that.
>> Uh not energy power. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Power.
>> Yeah. because I I I didn't
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I can float in reaction
to this.
>> Yes. So, with the the trigger on the
chain, you float power.
>> I drew for two for this. So, I'll draw
for that.
>> Um and then you play four ready. And now
you've essentially cheated out four
extra energy
>> power.
>> Um
>> with an extra floating power.
Oh, two unchecked power in hand. Yeah, I
mean you have to, right? You've got to
looking at the other options, you can't
time warp. Rocket barrage doesn't get it
done.
>> Situation six
or
Okay,
>> but does he get enough value?
>> I think we just
>> I think we just I think we just I think
we uncheck power and clear out those
battlefields and say, "If you've got
more, give me more." one of the power
and then just recycle one and then these
tap out
>> and
>> that is the other site right because you
have to exhaust all your own
>> unit
to be a cleanup craft after
>> both the same yeah
>> and I have war runs from
>> and now
>> that's it
>> no rift herald effect because there
wasn't a unit in hand
>> and here is the point why we
continuously heard Jibs ask for cards in
hand
>> because sure this is not the most
valuable unchecked power, but with the
information that they cannot rebuild.
They have no cards in hand.
>> The other information is with the
singularity. Uh you kind of made sure
you pulled one unit out of hand. Uh and
you know, you you're saying you're not
going to have more. You can't have more.
There's not going to be more back there.
>> Now, there is a dignitary off the top,
but it's two mirror images, a dignity,
and I believe Leblanc chosen champion is
still there. Yes, it is still in the
chosen champion zone. So, it is not that
Leblanc is totally out of units, but
going from having Double Rift, Herald,
and Carus in play to now having
>> you're building units is not where you
want to be.
>> I here I'm enjoying every moment of
what's happening right now, but I do
have to be critical.
>> Sure.
>> Are we seeing what we saw with the Pike
where we see a lot of fireworks, we see
a lot of back flips?
>> Remember, I'm a magpie [laughter]
>> and I am easily entranced by that.
>> Sure. on the bottom line. I don't feel
all that bad in the aselanc
to me. He has there's a lot of resources
still in hand.
>> Yes. Yeah. We need to see him capitalize
and this might be the last leg that
Leblanc is standing on.
>> Yeah. And now Super Monte going to go
back to conquer both battlefields. We
know there's another unchecked power in
hand. Now the question is where's the
value at?
>> Yeah.
>> Like in hand one one
>> where is the value? Is is it a case of I
just need to keep wiping my opponent's
board, keep it down,
>> or is it that okay, no, I need to get
better units with this unchecked power
than a couple of three might units uh
here and there
>> because we are reloading once again.
Yeah, right. We just had our our big
musical uh play, right?
>> Encore, [laughter] the big encore, and
now we are in I guess it's actually
crescendo, but
>> repetitions again. Yeah. Yeah. Now we're
in that situation where we're going
through the motions. Feels like
unchecked power is overkill here when
you got two might, a one might, and a
one might. [laughter] I feel like it's
not worth clearing it out. You can
actually do it manually at this point.
Now that I'm looking at the board state
fully now that like assessing it card
for card, I'm like, no, that that
genuinely you just keep that in hand, I
think, for now and just go through the
motions of picking pieces apart. The
problem is Jibs doesn't really have
units himself.
>> So actually building back into this game
and conquering at a pace that is good.
It's going to take a couple turns.
>> Six.
>> And the the time is starting to tick as
we're doing the the math that goes
above. I didn't know that was legal.
>> Like a metronome and nice. when the time
starts to tick
>> and uh
>> you are in a situation as Jin where you
can now get multiple four cost spells
off.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Will that be enough to get a second
usage of the Jin Legend of Cuz that is
really what they're looking for right
now.
>> Yeah. I mean preferably uh chain it with
a time warp as well.
>> Yes. Yeah. Importantly, that's the other
thing is you
>> and draw one
>> because if you manage to do that and you
manage to stay on, then suddenly you can
start threatening the game.
>> Yeah, you can
>> from from like four or five points even.
>> Absolutely, you can. And that's the
thing is um the unchecked power counts
as the first one again in the in the
next loop. So, you need three spells
that are going to cost uh above four.
So, it it's it's a deck we don't see too
often at the competitive level, but it
really does make you have to think in a
different way to how that this game is
going to play out.
>> This deck is rarer than an Ireelia
played at Legend. I'm just [laughter]
going
>> This is a true one of one in the world.
>> Wow. We're we're thematically
appropriate with a deadly flourish, a
card that I'm pretty sure no other deck
plays, which uh deadly flourish is going
to be deal three to an enemy unit. When
a dice's turn, play gold gear token
exhausted. Thank you behind the scenes.
>> I'll get this
>> riptide rex on top is going to be enough
to clear out more units. And again,
didn't need to use the unchecked power,
of course, because you had enough um
utility in hand. That's two casts. So,
>> wait. Uh the the copy is the copy of the
of what
>> it was the Yeah. Yeah. Uh I will trigger
the star spring. Move this back. when
Jibs goes to the next turn
>> can afford to play two spells and then
get the Crescendo Ankle whatever we're
calling it again the the legend ability
to pay off. So at this point it's a game
of just keeping Super Monte down in
units and down in card draw. This is one
of the things that the Leblanc deck can
struggle with. The card draw in this
deck relies on having units to sacrifice
or hidden blade or whichever version of
your I'm going to kill a unit of my own
and I'm going to draw for it.
>> Like any engine, you need that spark.
>> Yeah, keep the cycle going of
>> you are at five.
>> Light up the fuel.
>> Let me try to go in.
>> Which when you have a soaring scout,
>> you can just kill that and get a rune
and draw like with a sacrifice or Oh,
sorry. sacrifice wouldn't necessarily
work, but it's it you can see the point
that I'm making. When you're using
expendable units, it's easy.
>> When none of your units are expendable
anymore, it becomes a lot more tricky.
My that's three vice [laughter] in your
hand against a deck that is really all
not all that interested in contesting
you on the battlefields. And that is
kind of what I meant in the early game.
We saw the the turning gears of
>> losing it over seeing a Riptide Rex
>> gked up.
by a a curtain call here. A a we're
nipping away at your chest there.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And keeping them at an ar length. And
now they really can start threatening
the game.
>> Ruined Rex an oldie bit of goodie. Don't
see him too often anymore, but here we
do. And you you make a valid point about
the vise as well because so much of it
you don't want to play him out. you
don't want to to like put him in base
because so much of it is the ambush with
the stun. Like
so how do you actually balance what
comes next for Super Monte? I will still
say
>> Super Monte has done a good job of
staying in the game for for this point
and still could very well look to take
it. I think it this is an odd game state
to be in don't typically find ourselves
in.
>> Made a mistake. I want to play uh B in
my purity. Second one. Y.
>> Okay. So, it will while Super Mante has
priority use the ambush ability.
>> Stun comes through.
>> There is the the VI that we're talking
about. It now has two V's.
>> Oh, one of those.
>> If Vice stands for violence, I'm not
quite sure what two vice stands for.
That's a lot of eye. I know what
punching first and asking questions
while punching gets you.
unchecked power
>> in this situation because I feel like
>> this man in a writing room right now
>> that could be where Jibs is going with
this three vise pretty good target
unchecked power 15 right yeah
>> and despite that
>> here's the thing you're just so not
ready for [laughter] second unchecked
power so
>> the second power or just uh what you
have to keep in mind as well
>> you're not really anticipating
>> I'm at five you're at six
a a time warp as well as as an optional
win theory here.
>> Do you move?
>> Okay, I was going to ask, do you move
the sentry first to score the point, but
you're on five? So, actually five is the
same as six
>> on one of them
>> because you're going to nine. Typically,
if you're trying to hit that point to
win the game, you you care about being
on being away.
>> Does this resolve? I I Yeah, I have no
interrupt. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, sacrifice is going to resolve.
>> Jib is going to And that is a lot more
impactful than you might want to give it
credit for.
>> Burst
coming through on the trigger for this.
>> Uh
>> he has the option to banish it and
trigger Jin.
>> Yeah, but
>> not trigger the Jin.
>> Okay. Doesn't trigger it. He's just
looking to jump to seven. This tells you
it's a setup for a time warp next turn.
>> I will move here.
Okay. And six. And I will go here.
>> Goes to seven. Gets to
>> essentially game point like the
tipping point where you can get up to
nine. Superman has to think, okay, uh, I
haven't watched it. I don't really want
to do it to put it on a battlefield, but
I kind of have to.
I've seen big spells. Now, can we afford
time war? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. Yes, we can
afford a time up on the next turn if
your jibs decide. So, Super Monte, you
have to have that in the back of your
mind, right? You have to think, I'm
seeing a lot of blue. I'm seeing big
spells. Surely it's there.
>> I
I'm not sure if that is that obvious
when you're in that position.
>> No, I I I'm not saying it's obvious.
Certainly not obvious, but when you're
think
>> it takes a while for my mind to to
wander off to like, oh,
>> maybe the time war
>> to be fair, time warp has been out of
meta for a while. We we used to have
Original.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like we were playing
Draven in Spirit Forge and we were
playing like big units in the the tail
end of Spirit Forge.
>> Mage.
>> And here is also the moment where the
>> sorry
>> the Rex
>> Aspirin's climb is really beneficial to
>> Gibs is keeping Superman out of out of
threatening the game.
>> Yes, importantly the ruined Rex. Now, if
there's a way of
>> killing this ruined Rex reflection,
taking out one of the units, and it's
going to force Jibs
>> at least to play a unit before the time
warp turn, which then comes down to the
economy of like how many do you have? Uh
although I guess no, you just go to one
battlefield, time warp, and hold, and
then you get a winning point. I'm
talking complete rubbish.
>> Or you or you could like uh get the
sprites out again.
>> Yeah, if if you have it. Yeah, exactly.
That's some big battlefields. You can
go.
>> Surely there won't be a third unchecked
power, right? Uh, wasn't in hand last
time we saw it.
And we've seen on the deck list there
isn't. So, is there enough to go over
the top?
There's a frigid touch in hand,
which
I'm pretty sure if you repeat it.
is spending four.
>> So you can frigid touch the six might
reflection token on aspirin's climb. Go
in to conquer that battlefield. Hope
that everything is okay with the one
>> energy that's up.
>> Okay, I will pay two four
uh frigid touch on this twice. [snorts]
>> Okay,
>> repeated.
>> Okay. And now I I will trigger Jin and I
will float four blue power when I have
the
uh does the matter the minus? I guess it
doesn't matter. Um and then should I get
the four energy and draw?
>> Okay. Um
>> now it's all about getting onto the
battlefield.
>> Yeah, as a reminder that reflection is
minus four as well. Thank you very much
to Super Monte for that.
>> A single one will do.
>> Yeah, one battlefield
plus time war.
>> And you're just so left in the dark here
as still a Blanc. Are there enough
runes? I I swear I can't
>> I will die, I think.
>> Mhm. Cuz you're
>> And my death trigger shoots uh four to
go here.
I don't have sacrifice. Okay.
>> I don't win. I just go to eight.
>> I know, but you have time.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I have time. Yeah.
>> Oh, [laughter]
I don't win now, but I do win when I
reveal the time war from hand. Super
Monday knowing that the time warp was
there anyway. You're trying to set up.
>> The presence of mind is there. And oh my
god, that felt like such a hard fought
win from both sides. So, I've got to be
honest, that that was like getting right
[music] into Thank you. You can see
Super Monty could see the pace of the
game and how it was going. Uh, very
funny. Uh, but very [music] like in it.
You can tell even that in an unorthodox
match up saying, "Ah, no, I think I I I
can tell if you can get through my one
of my battlefields, you have time
waring."
>> And you got to remember world word
travels fast at a regional qualifier.
Yeah, people talk and [music] let me
tell you, if you if you just lost to the
Jin that was three on zero, you bet your
bottom dollar that you are are spewing
that to anyone who will hear that.
[music] Now, the question that has to be
on the mind,
>> how in how do you start boarding against
this?
>> Yeah. [laughter] Uh good question. Um,
>> you don't you haven't brought many uh
>> I I feel like you have to lower to
>> I think you have to move the timeline
and not allow the Jin [music] to get
this second usage of the legend to
>> to the battlefield.
>> Yeah. And to add on top of it, we
haven't seen a lot of baited hooks, but
is that even the plan still? Cuz usually
when you're going into baited hook,
like, oh, I I want to get big dragons
that will shoot your units. Yeah.
>> And Jyn is like, yeah, sure. Um, which
one? Oh, the one might or or or the Nox
is hopeful. Yeah, exactly.
>> It's not that impactful where with Lanca
usually supposed to get these blowout
results and we saw them almost get there
with all the Rift Heralds. A dream
scenario and it was still not enough.
>> Wouldn't surprise me uh to see things
like Falling Star come in. Um, we
haven't actually shown the players deck
list, the the sideboard on stream. There
is a card I want to talk about if it
comes in. I will not mention it now. I
think for the benefit of players in a
closed for the environment. I think uh I
will not actually talk about a card
until we see it.
>> But you have to imagine direct damage
comes in. Anything else that can keep
track of the units like hold any way of
Leblanc with an open board you'd imagine
would be good.
I can't believe we just
>> they're they're still going through
their options uh as as we're
sideboarding because I mean you really
have to be in the moment at this point
and think on your feet and that is what
regional qualifiers to me are all about.
How do you handle the four on O Jin in
round five [laughter]
and and is that just a bump in the road?
>> Yeah. Meanwhile, this is Superman's main
deck. So you're saying let's lower the
curve a little.
>> Yeah. So much of this deck you want to I
imagine you want to keep the Shellon. I
must admit I've not actually played
Leblanc enough myself to like have the
the the meat and potatoes of the deck in
my muscle memory, but I feel like, you
know, if you're playing the baited hook,
then you you kind of have to leave the
things like the Rift Herald in as that
mechanism. Even though they're the high
energy units, you still need them as a
gear, as like the ramp.
>> In the past around Spirit Force, we saw
baited hook Fioras.
>> Sure. Yeah. and they had the option to
sideboard out the baited hook package
and go for a more mid-range strategy. I
was very fond of that.
>> Okay,
>> the Leblanc, however, doesn't have that
luxury. They are way more committed to
the baited hook package because
>> it is so powerful and it is kind of the
catch all in 99% of the matches when
you're facing other vice kaises. There's
a lot of value to be had in that regard.
But for me, the battlefields are still
pretty fortunate. You still have the the
the heath to start ganking over, so you
can make use of your reflections to get
onto the other battlefield just a tad
bit quicker.
>> Make sure that well, at least we'll be
playing for eight points in game number
two.
>> Yeah, that that is a good point. Those
are two adjustments. If we do see uh
yeah, windswept Hill and we will get
Jib's uh battlefield update as well.
Frozen Fortress. This changes the pace
of the game quite drastically. Having
the ganking ability with the tokens plus
only going to eight is is huge.
>> Same,
>> which they'll need. Yeah,
>> because tick- tock tick tock. There's
only 27 minutes left on the clock.
>> This can still be a draw
>> despite I I'll we're supposed to be
unbiased. I am rooting for this gin
actively. [laughter]
>> We can't even hide it.
>> We are unbiased. I will say bringing
something else that we don't often see
uh to the field and that is a frozen
fortress which is the battlefield that
deals one damage to all the units that
are there at the beginning of each turn.
It is not just the active player like
the person whose battlefield it is or
the person who controls it. It is every
single turn. So things like soaring
scout cannot go to frozen Fortress
because they Yes, you'll get the Death
Note effect, but the whole point of this
deck is you want the original unit there
in order to make a reflection of it.
>> Exactly that. And this was a really
important early game unit in game one.
>> Copy.
>> Yeah. the porro, the plundering porro
that kind of
>> bankrolled the early game for Jin
>> where he was actually allowed to move
all the way up to that 12 energy where
he started dictating the pace of the
game.
>> Now, Superman does have hook in hand.
>> Uh, and honestly, you can move the
reflection over and say, "Yeah, fine.
I'll I'll lose that at the beginning of
your turn. I'll channel a rune from it."
That's fine. I don't mind that so much.
Leblanc
base.
>> This hand doesn't do a lot at this point
in the game for Jibs. You got to be
honest. Stupifier is essentially draw a
card at this point. Or maybe if you get
lucky and they put a two might unit on
frozen Fortress, you can stupify to to
lower it. The unchecked power and I
think there was a time warp in hand as
well. Right now, it's too early to see
those cards.
>> They're nice to have them. You don't
really want them [laughter]
>> here. I I will say, but this is not the
moment we're looking at Jin yet, right?
This is about surviving.
>> Yeah, this is LeBlanc's time to play.
>> Yeah, this is Jin in college is they're
eating noodles at night. [laughter]
>> Hasn't been picked up by the the
symphony uh orchestra.
>> Yeah, they're they're they're a
struggling artist. This is this is this
is before they put on the mask.
[laughter]
[gasps]
>> Okay.
>> Truly a theater kid, Jen. So, Super
Monte
has like probably the quietest early
game you could hope for with that unit
in base. Uh, Jips is basically saying
pass, which is still, you know, there's
a little bit of danger there of like
what can be drawn off the top. We, as we
said, we stupify as one uh at least
look, I think that's also a frigid touch
or maybe a consult the past in hand. the
uh animation the animation on the cards
the uh the
>> the
cards it's a frigid touch
>> if you look at what is currently sitting
in the hand of a bunk and I know in a
baited hook deck it's not always about
what is sitting in hand that we should
be worried about
>> but that doesn't really scream tempo
tempo tempo to me and
>> well you know even though we we we are
>> coming forward this might not be quite
my tempo.
>> Sure. Sure. I'm just going to make an
observation that Consult the Past and
Frigid Touch when you're looking at them
sideways or upside down are actually
surprisingly similar artwork.
>> The White Swoosh was what I was looking
at and both have it. [laughter]
>> I I kind of hear what you're coming
from.
>> Yeah, that's my excuse for
>> for when you when you go upside down,
you can actually see the face in Bridget
Touch. But we are getting dramatically
off track.
>> That's important though. Uh what's
important is Super Monte up to three
points. Uh two units on the battlefield
already. Um this has been a much better
early game
>> and I go there. We'll put
>> And I think most importantly what was
happening in game one is we were taking
care of these early game threats that
Leblanc was presenting giving minimal
value of the first four five turns that
Leblanc had available to her. Baited
hook is already out. The engine is
turning and I'm not sure if Jin is
capable of derailing it at this point.
>> Yeah, this is a rough spot to be in.
Potentially two turns away from
>> uh Leblanc.
>> Um
>> if you're uncontested taking the game.
Um so we're having a damage marker put
in there again at the beginning.
>> Every turn. Wow. Just going to slam
uncheck power.
>> I'll use two blue. Um
>> saying, okay, the economy doesn't matter
if I'm out of the game, so I have to
just
>> use the gold destroy everything. True.
>> This really feels like the emergency
break.
>> It is. Yeah. For
>> in game one, it was a power play,
>> right? It was really hurtling us ahead.
This is digging in your heels, hanging
on to the skirt of Leblanc. Be like,
"No, you're not."
>> This is it. Yeah. Hitting that stop
button to just be like, I need to slow
you down now. Baited Hook is already,
you know, it's it's here. It's ready.
depending now on what Super Monte
>> chooses as the next line tells us what
we're looking for off the top with the
the baited hook. That's a lot of runes
being [laughter]
>> they have the opportunity to accelerate
out the the thousand tilt box.
>> Yeah, and that is exactly what it's
going to be.
>> I agree. And I like this
>> because even though the
>> quote unquote value from the debuff that
you're getting is not there, you are
remaining in the position of scoring
points, conquering, getting out
reflections, moving over to the other
battlefield, and this one will survive.
>> Oh yeah, this one is exactly what you
need as hell watcher now going to be a
copy of it. Um, it does put it in range
for things like singularity and ruined
Rex
>> and with the last one
>> because of the frozen fortress.
>> We'll deal one damage at the beginning
of Jib's turn. So, that is something you
have to be a little bit careful of. But,
you're just going to say, "Nope, we're
going to hook it. Get it out of here.
Just see if I can refresh it into
something a little more useful. You can
see Super Monte maybe not the happiest
with what was found."
>> I mean, I kind of get it. you are down a
game and even though you're in a
commanding position currently if you
leave this series having lost your
friends will never let you hear the end
of it.
>> You got to you got to you got to take
that into
>> hey that to be fair that only applies
depending on the Jin's after
>> one card in hand.
>> Jib's double checking the game state
from Super Monte.
I mean, Super Monte is in a great
position, but
minus four, three damage.
>> Okay,
>> three damage to the backline. Minus four
to the watcher. That's only the third
spell, though.
>> Uh, guess we should do this correctly.
Minus four might. Sorry. Thank you. And
then I'll move here. That's enough.
>> And now it's a
>> will take out the thousand tail watcher.
>> Jin only goes to two though. So for
Super Monte, there's still time in the
tank if they can restock, get onto the
board with more units.
And here is the part where I am not as
concerned currently because we have the
baited hookout.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> There is a lot of uh it doesn't matter
that we might not have everything we
need in our hand because our hand is now
plus five. And and that's the thing is
like even things like um the mixologist,
right, is like with hook you're getting
good value
>> because
>> uh two
>> to get the death nail trigger,
>> I think.
>> Yeah. And just be like, "Cool, I turned
one unit into two units."
>> Um
>> I wish I was at three.
>> I mean, and and we see that even though,
you know, the Jin has answers for
multiple smaller threats, you see its
efficiency. Yeah. when they're either
all huddled up on battlefields. Oh, and
with the carus and the mixologist, we
might be repopulating.
>> Exactly.
>> Rather swiftly.
>> Exactly. As you said, Carus in hand as
well.
>> Your trash for you.
>> That's pretty cannon for a for a
bartender.
>> Six and one. Yep.
Rex.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, just taking the other approach and
saying if you have no units, you can't
contest me.
>> Death now goes on the trigger. Do you
need to declare it before the hook or
after? After the hook. Okay,
>> correct.
>> Yeah, I believe that's the case.
>> Clarifying just the sequence is uh I
mean honestly even just
>> sorry
>> the
>> just explain what Yeah, that's fine.
>> Even just the fact that you're clearing
out the units is is significant enough.
I feel like right situation.
>> No, not this time. I already miss one. I
play another Rex.
>> That's rough [snorts] to see, especially
when it deals four.
>> That feels backhanded
>> again. I don't think it matters. But
>> there's a story in our story.
>> It
>> We uncheck for stream as well, right?
>> And I will shoot to
>> It's kind of hard to to
>> Yep.
>> move on.
>> And you're good to go.
>> Thank you. Yeah, you're threatening it
for next turn.
>> It's just hard to remain calm in this
situation when all
the alarm signals on your dashboard are
blinking.
>> Yeah. Screaming at
>> two.
>> Now Jibs is probably going to have to
just keep clawing and scratching. Sadly
doesn't really have
>> the curtain.
>> Play a deadly flourish doing three
damage here. Yeah,
>> but it can trigger the unit. They can
have another card if they want.
>> Get another card and that means they
would have another deadly flourish which
would
>> and I will float at least
>> take out the unit.
>> You have to play to your outs.
>> Yeah, you have to
>> sitting on your hands and hoping for
things to improve are not helping you
survive.
>> Yeah, exactly. You get one more look one
card.
>> Yeah,
[clears throat]
>> that looked like a rocket barrage from
what I could see.
>> Yeah, we'll we'll we'll confirm that
one. It it's a that is a rocket barrage
in hand
>> player.
Sorry.
>> So the sub goal that you're trying to
cover off right now is to prevent at all
cost a conquer trigger from the
>> rocket barrage twice doing four damage
and killing this.
>> Oo the repeated rocket barrage takes out
the baited hook as well. I feel like
Jibs even went to go and just do the
damage and went hang on a second.
>> You have two cards in hand. Yes, I will
pass.
>> Hang on a second. I can cut through
this.
>> Get those two back anyway. Right. game
as as Jim says, you got to get it back
in any way and Superman is still
>> inches from the finish line.
>> Yeah, it just has to establish one
battlefield and then kind of
>> next turn either hold through direct
damage spells which we know that Jibs
has some
>> right
>> or conquer both.
I mean with the ganking that is just
such a
>> it's almost a certainty right the moment
one battlefield you're able to
>> and Jin is only sitting on one open
energy right we we have seen him play a
lot of spells mostly on their own turn
>> and this is where the problem with with
a lot of the direct damage from Jyn uh
it's not an actional reaction speed it's
only on Jyn's turn for the most part so
that's a difficult situation it means
you can't allow that showdown to even
begin for super monte on the next turn
>> are we playing soldier is busy for two
recycle and three power. I will try with
a mirror image.
I'm mix.
>> Yes. GG cuz you just you have one card
in hand, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I won't.
>> Okay. There. Enough with the discard.
Enough for the conqueror. Enough for the
gank.
>> Was cracked, bro. Your hand was cracked.
Yeah, every it always drew like
>> So looking ahead right now, the the
entire tone of the match has changed
because we have seen that Leblanc is
capable Yeah.
>> of [music] going through it. We have, I
believe, around 10 minutes,
>> yes,
>> give or take left to be finishing our
first round. We will then most likely go
into overtime
>> and and coming out of the gate swinging,
right?
>> She's looking, but that was heavily
dependent on being able to access the
ganking.
>> Yeah,
>> from the Hill.
>> I'm not sure if they'll go through that
again. A curtain call is going to be a
card that you will have to mulligan so
aggressively for cuz we saw the damage
it did, how it gked up the gears for the
Leblanc. anything they can do to stay
ahead.
>> But this is a point where how do you how
do you look at sideboarding now? Do you
if you've for Leblanc surely you have to
keep the curve low, right? Like just
like game two, you're like I have to
just get a a handful of units and and
ability to just get out on the board.
for for Jyn's side of things. I we we
didn't actually see the the sideboarding
plan from from Jibs that I took note of
where if units came out, they have to go
back in now, right? We didn't see any
sprites so much in in that exchange. Um
so maybe they have to to come in to try
and fight early on, but then you're
you're hurting your direct damage
spells. This is the moment where being
the unique deck player and and I I
appreciate Leblanc is not exactly uh the
most meta. It's not we see it every
single day. I mean like you might not
play this matchup as much as you tested
Diana if you're Jin for instance.
>> Sure.
>> But my point is if you're uh the one
that has been testing probably Jibs
knows the the sideboarding plan just
that tiny bit better. You would imagine
for game three. There can be no doubt
that in the Jin Leblanc matchup
experience, Gibs is winning out.
>> That [laughter] that was what I stumbled
my way to say by saying a few things in
the middle there that people could
question.
>> That's that's why you need two casters.
>> Exactly. You got to save me. [laughter]
You got to come in.
>> Save. No, no, no, no, no.
>> But what we're going to have is a
Starring and a void gate. So void gate
is going to help Jin quite a little bit.
>> Exactly. You were talking about direct
damage.
>> Yeah.
>> This is the way we're going.
Does that lean away from the sprites? I
feel like you can be living in in both
worlds.
>> Oh, wait. I read it backwards. We're
actually going on aspirants. It's not
Starring. Star spring was game one.
>> Yeah,
>> it's aspirin from Leblanc. Apologies. I
had it I had it flipped.
>> She waited as long as she could knowing
that it would pay for the Jin as well.
>> Coming round now
>> getting to 9 in 12 minutes. It's not
impossible,
>> but there there is a lot of plotting and
scheming happening.
>> We are flying right into a second turn,
>> and I do respect this. The players are
keeping pace. They are looking to play
out an entirety of the match. This is
what sportsmanship looks like.
>> Yeah. 12 minutes in the round. The the
argument is of course you only need to
be up by two points in order to win, but
you at least need to give yourself the
time that when it comes down to the
final moments of the game, you you have
put yourself in the best situation
possible. Uh there is a Nox hopeful in
hand
>> and a curtains call. This is what we
were looking for to to slow down the
early game of the Aurelia whilst also
loading up your Jin legend.
>> Yeah. On the other side the Leblanc of
course uh playing out the baited hook I
believe saw a um Rift Herald in I think.
Oh, it's get it's immediately rocket
barged.
>> That's huge for hopeful. Yeah, noxious
hope can come out right afterwards.
>> The Legion cost for it.
>> And here's the thing. I
>> think I Yes, I will.
>> Costwise, that is not a too attractive a
play, but you keep loading up your Jin.
You can even start to threaten it in a
turn or two.
>> I won't play Jin. I'll pass.
>> Okay, Jibs actually declines to play the
Jin. Doesn't want to end up recycling
more. Looking forward at what's in hand,
knowing that there's some big recycles
there with like the likes of
Singularity. If two units came out from
Super Monte now, you want to be able to
pop them immediately. Whereas Super
Monte is like, how do I establish this
board? How do I keep things alive? And
also what you have to take in mind as
well when you are playing the Jin in the
early game, it was all about ramping up
and getting to those higher rune totals
by getting carried away and getting an
early body out. What is that doing for
us really?
>> We I mean 10 minutes is not a lot of
time, but they've been upping the pace.
>> Yeah, they have. as Supermani thinking
through this turn. It's going to just be
a ruined Rex which will deal with the
Noxus hopeful alone
and honestly is not the target that
you're looking to use a singularity on.
Singularity for one unit is never never
feels good, never feels optimal.
Sometimes it is the right thing, rarely,
but it doesn't feel good. So, you do
also have your access to your own
Riptide Rex.
>> This is going to be really important.
the fact that the time warp is already
secured in hand.
>> Yeah.
>> Now I am
>> I don't like to admit it. What is the
interaction in overtime with time warp?
Does that take one of the the turns away
from your opponent?
>> Uh it does.
>> That is
>> there are three turns. I will have
judges make sure that
>> Yeah, let's let's double check if that's
the case. If you time warp, there are
only three turns of overtime.
>> I want cards.
at one point.
>> So, we'll have to keep that in the back
of our mind.
>> Yeah,
>> I will do um three damage and draw a
card.
>> Sure.
>> By paying a power.
>> You know what? I read curtain call and I
was like, nobody's doing multiple of
these. It's not going to be good.
>> Now, I'm watching it like the
flexibility is undeniable. However, it
is straining the economy of the gin.
Currently, we're not
>> okay. We don't have the luxury
>> that the plundering pearl gave us.
>> We are
>> he's actually going to trigger Jin right
now. It's not for for later on.
>> Uh trigger Jin.
>> Uh so
>> so run
>> is going to pop the uh pop the hopeful
>> J is going to
fors a unit on the back end
>> and one power for a Jin
>> and Jin.
And this is the moment where it gets
really tricky for LBL because
>> it's kind of hard to get something out
of the gate swinging
>> even on seven energy
>> interesting one
>> and whatever you're playing
>> will be most likely met with a
singularity
>> bottom that and [snorts]
>> so Jibs is just uh deciding over the the
vision effect of playing Jin of deciding
whether to keep it on the top of the
deck or to recycle it to the bottom.
Opted to recycle it and once again units
are costing a lot for Super Monty. It's
a unit and pass in singularity range
>> and not just singularity. Does he still
have the riptide rex in hand?
>> So I'm at one.
>> I mean there there's options, right? I I
double check the the hand.
>> All the plants that Super Monty is
laying are just they need more time.
They need more love and attention. And
currently Jibs is just not giving it.
>> The deck that we were fearing that oh
no, it needs to get to late game is
having a way more restrictive early
game, choking out the Leblanc out of
this deciding game three.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Up to three.
>> Three.
>> Wow. I genuinely thought after game two
I was like super super monte played
really well through it. Going to time it
now.
>> Just flat time warp just says yeah we're
doing this the oldfashioned way. I'm
jumping to five
>> saying I can hold your board low enough
to take points up
>> at the bottom like this. Yeah. Um end my
turn. the midame time war
>> ready and hold for
>> the time warp to not win the game but
just to make sure that you're keeping
your opponent pinned back and the gap
that is now falling for them
>> it's getting larger and larger they can
still deal with divine through the
singularity
>> and suddenly has stupify rocket barrage
>> to keep another unit down and get a draw
>> I will react to his sacrifice
Um,
>> look at the resource available for the
Blanc as well.
>> They are not rich. They are not well off
currently.
>> This is like
>> the the count.
>> Can I not react to the
>> in like a dilapitated mansion [laughter]
>> with broken windows.
>> Uh, this still resolves
>> if uh my resolve first.
>> Okay, sure. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, resolving the sacrifice first.
>> It's a weird spell. Well, I'm I'm never
sure whether I can actually react to it.
I'll draw for super play. Um
I mean, sure, if it's dead, it's dead.
I'll pass.
>> Gibs is really good at fing madness.
>> Yeah, I was like, oh me, bro.
>> So, Superman does
have a lot of options, but which of them
are fast enough to to get to get there,
right? There's a baited hook in hand.
There's
>> I mean Jib's stupifying
first
means he still has the rocket barrage in
hand, right?
>> He does.
>> So if that baited hook comes out
is rather than going rocket barrage
stupify and saying, "Okay, I'm showing
you my game plan." They they have so
many cards already.
>> They
feel like they're so well prepared and
currently
against the expectations is
>> looking more and more like Leblanc is
stuck in Jyn's web crafted
>> on zero points which is crazy at this
point. Like Super Monte the game two was
so clean. Game two was like, yes,
getting ahead, getting everything you
need, making your way into this game
where Super Monte the no unit has really
survived long enough to awaken on Super
Monty's next turn. And that is kind of
the tricky part for Leblanc where
>> confirming not to rub it in.
>> Once you get the ball points, right?
>> Okay, just checking.
>> Just confirming Super Mon, you need to
get the ball rolling for Leblanc.
>> It's five to zero,
>> but they never got there. Not a single
conquer, not a single hold.
>> And Jibs even just confirmed that. You
heard him as politely as possible. Say,
I just need to check that my track of
the game is correct,
>> which to be fair, both players are
responsible for maintaining the uh the
game state, and that includes, you know,
keeping track of your opponent's points.
If you play at Nexus Knights and you're
looking to get up to skirmish level, I
would suggest using pen and paper. is
required at a competitable competitive
level
>> of all time.
>> Here comes the baited hook. Yeah, we're
going to be delving once again.
>> And kill himself with beta hook.
>> Let me kill your stuff. Stop killing it
for me.
>> I [laughter] know you won't want but
>> this one's scary cuz the hook comes out
after.
So, what can be found from the hook?
There's an ash.
>> I didn't get what I want.
>> No, did not get what you wanted. I I'm
assuming what was wanted was a thousand
tailed watcher to be able to create a
reflection token from it
>> here. The reason uh why the ash is is
not all that great.
>> Maybe even could
>> I mean they're not currently holding
right now. At least getting the
information out there and seeing if we
can take out the next domino out of the
row to maybe let them fall flat. But
they're going to need a whole lot more.
>> I don't need the time up.
>> I don't have time up.
>> Not yet.
>> So misplay. I believe you have time war
and you lose the game.
>> Interesting. Superman is saying I
believed you have time war or you lose
the game
from zero points is a quite a
>> not a misplay. You're playing around
something. That's correct.
>> And as Jibs alludes to, when you're
playing around something,
we can't put ourselves directly in the
the shoes of these players. Every player
has a line that they're playing around
the worst case scenario. You have to
play around what you think is the most
likely to take you out of this game. And
you heard Superman say that's time war.
>> You're just mulling your options. You
need to safeguard that baited hook. It's
it's it's like the only way Leblanc can
be
>> impactful
>> on a turn where she doesn't have any
use, right? Where she can still get
something done on the board and interact
with the pieces in front of her. But
importantly, if Super Monty cannot stop
Jibs from holding on the next turn, the
the rocket barrage will come back.
>> It's just delaying the inevitable.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> and just look at the economy discrepancy
that is building up right now.
>> Yeah.
>> Fin is absolutely rolling in it.
>> But no no spells tucked under the
legend. So, we're not going to get the
the encore, the crescendo, uh the the
big finale.
>> Exactly.
Not going to get that.
>> Yeah,
>> but Jibs will go up, you imagine, to
seven quite
>> aheadandedly. Y
>> goes up to seven as we close in on
overtime rounds.
>> And I was at seven.
>> For all of those who are not in the
know, now is the time to call your
friends and tell them to watch the live
stream right now cuz we are witnessing
history.
>> If you know a Jin man, check in on them.
Yeah,
>> because they they might be uh have a
raised heart rate currently
>> cracking packs to try and find copies of
curtain call if they don't have
>> with only a minute left. It seems like
we're we're stafing off to what can only
lead to a standing ovation from the
entire of the center here cuz
>> and to be fair, both of our players did
play quite quickly through the beginning
of this game. So naturally it has slowed
down as the decisions become uh more
impactful and and more kind of do or die
situation.
>> I mean the game develops, more options
become available. We have to m a little.
>> That's the thing is
>> n
could watch either way.
>> The ash can be dealt with. It's what
what do you want to deal
>> what do you want to use to deal with the
ash?
>> Which means I probably do need that
>> if jibs manage to pass it through in the
next 20 seconds. deadly flourish and
then chain to it. Uh, frigid
>> a repeated frigid touch. Doesn't need
the repeat, but wants it for the Jin
Legend for the next turn just in case of
course gets a draw.
>> Um, and then I will play
two
for a hopeful and base.
>> Well, too long.
>> Um,
>> I will say when we're on the featured
match, the uh the timer
>> I passed or is it too late? judges will
be Oh, that's going to be the
concession. Jibs is actually going to
take the win on Jin and does get a round
of applause. Jin, that was stunning.
5-0, [music] which feels weird.
Undefeated so far for Jibs here at RQ
Utract. He looks like he can barely
believe it himself. It's a mad scientist
piece, but the harmonies find each
[music] other. They complement each
other, cover each other's weaknesses.
And what looked like it could never work
in a million years. All the the Jin
doubters have to give it another think
in all future tier lists.
>> And I mean, I would say Superman played
this out as carefully and as well as
possible, picking up game two, looking
really strong doing it. Like again,
you're in the adv the disadvantageous
seat where you're like, I don't know
this match up as well.
>> You don't know what you're facing. even
though he
>> really really strong second game up and
then the third game just unable to to
keep a board state unable to maintain
units because of just how quickly
[music] they were dealt with. We see
even like a board state of three vise in
the second game or ending up getting
wiped out. Just such a different game
than what we've seen for a lot of
Unleashed. And this is what regional
qualifiers are all about. showing that
you have what it takes to make a deep
run [music] throughout to make to show
to the world look what I can do on my
legend because I'll be very honest you
for except for maybe a very aggressive
aggro list that looked like it had
answers for practically everything.
>> Yeah, it it really did. I'm I'm that
that series made me happy. I saw so much
from Rift. I
>> I have goosebumps. I'm going to be very
real with you. It's like again getting
to I know it sounds I I I obviously want
to focus on the Jin, but like I I love
watching LeBlanc baited Hook. I I would
love to see it more. Um and you know
what I would love to do is send it over
to an interview with Barrett and Jibs.
Thank you so much for that incredible
cast of an incredible deck and an
incredible pilot. Jibs from Rift Lab,
how do you feel? One win away with a
legend that I think everyone was not
keeping an eye on. You're one win away
from making day two with a legend that
nobody's playing. How does that feel?
>> Um, yeah, unbelievable. I don't know
what to really say. Um, yeah, it's it's
it's a fun legend, right? It's it's
different. It's got a lot of combos. You
really need to think ahead. Um, there
was a number of times where, for
example, in my game, I didn't utilize
the Jin Legend. Um, it's little things
like this that you can really abuse. Um,
so I really enjoy the deck. Uh, yeah,
it's not the best, right? It's not the
best, but it's super fun. And I gave
myself a challenge. I wanted to do as
best I could with Jyn. It's one of my
favorite ADCs in League of Legends. Um,
and yeah, I just, yeah, really happy
with my performance.
>> Well, and I kind of want to ask you,
too, cuz I actually also have Jyn built
because I just think the deck is so fun.
And I think a lot of people want to say
the argument that it's like, oh, well,
it's just like a sideways Kai'Sa deck
with a legend that's not as good. But
like I play the hex anomaly version of
the echo and doing all the fun like
extra energy and and power floating. We
saw even like there for you, right? Like
the point of the legend is like it's not
even that it's fun, but when you have
those huge explosive turns where you are
banking, you already have your three
bullets loaded in and you're like,
"Okay, well, if I play pay play four
here, we can see the turns like you won
in that other game where you spend the
four, make a removal onto a battlefield,
get up to it, play a time warp, because
you have all these extra tools
available, and that's just actually not
possible in these other legends." So,
I've got to ask you, how many calm decks
have you played against, though? Because
I can tell you that I struggle every
time I play against Defy. So, how's the
run so far as a whole? I I I wouldn't
lie to you guys at home if I if I didn't
say I've dodged Aurelia like a boss. Um,
yeah, Aurelia is like
the worst matchup in the world. I may as
well like almost scoop, right? They have
all the pump spells. The Defy working on
four energy is like super rough. Um, but
I did play against an Azia player, so I
have I have gone through one so far. Um,
but yeah, there's plenty more games to
go. It is a rough matchup. Any green
deck or even purple with the um hard
bargain or abandon, I always have to
play around if they have two energy. So
yeah, but you're correct. The combo is
effectively you're playing with 16
energy and you you have seen some decks
with the hex anomaly where they can
really abuse the amount of energy you
have. Um, and it's great, but I feel
like it's a win more card.
>> Sure. Um whereas I've gone for something
a little bit more consistent and a few
extra spicy cards. I don't know if you
guys saw a Riptide Rex in my hand.
>> Yeah. Oldie but a goodie.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And and that is uh helpful
in specific matchups like this where I
know their might is around six or seven.
I'm not doing it. Um where you could
play a supery um and and finish
something off and still have a body on
the board. Um so there's certain things
in my deck that I like to surprise my
opponent with. Um, but yeah, it's it's
not easy. And as you said earlier with
the Kaiser similarities, it is very
similar to Kaiser. Um, but you don't
really have that early to mid-range
package. You are an effective removal
deck.
>> Um, and from what you saw in game three,
I didn't even have a two drop, but I
still managed to take him.
>> And those plundering porros are so
important like because you need that
gold to help even get your your runes
higher count so you can play more forc
spells of course. And I think the
biggest thing and the last thing I want
to end on the power of unchecked power
is really showcased and you did a
phenomenal job with that because I think
a lot of people are of course talking
about it. But Jib, congratulations once
again. You are one win away from day two
here with Jin. But that was some great
dramatics. We're going to send it back.
>> Thank you Barrett. And shout out to the
Rift Labs crew, which Jibs is a part of
in the UK scene, keeping everything
riffbound going forward. Ah, that was
such a fun game. That was such a fun
series. Fun interview. Ah, this is fun.
>> Honestly, uh, it's going to be very hard
for for round six to top what we just
>> N don't say that. We can always bar.
Now, this is this is a match that
maybe I'm being a little dramatic, but
to me, this is a match that will go down
the books.
>> I hope so. I hope so. So, I hope uh I
hope you enjoyed it at home. Uh we are
going to stay in round five for a little
moment longer because we do have some
matches still being played out in the in
the hall. Uh which means soon we will
jump right into our second featured
match up which I've heard is Fiora and
so if you didn't have enough spice
already uh get ready for a little bit
more. Yeah, exactly. This round we heard
you Mari is going to be on pause for a
little bit uh as we look at other decks.
We are going right into game two of our
second featured matchup. So, we will
take stock really quickly. It is a Fiora
list.
>> Um that you know, we've seen Fioras
running lots of different things. I've
seen Aurora Fiora. This one I'm going to
assume is not so Aurora focused up
against an which you've seen aggro orn a
little bit talked about. I don't know
whether this exact list will be the the
aggro variant. So nine up a lot of I
guess
>> taking stock real quick. Uh lonely pores
coming through. Some death now effects
coming through. This doesn't scream
aggro to me at all with the uh with the
shard ofis to buff up the units
throughout.
>> Up like just the top one is not there
and the other ones are there.
>> Uh 10. Yeah. So I have three yellow, six
orange.
>> Uh so
>> we are uh I think I'm floating a lot of
runes.
>> I did just catch a look at divine
judgment which is what is about to hit.
>> So
>> talking about blast from the past, huh?
>> Uh you know what works really well
against deflect? um saying, "Well, I
don't have to target you." Now, of
course, with divine judgment, you you
don't get to to pick what you take out.
So, you'd assume or will still survive,
>> but
>> lots of things are going to get wiped
out from the board now.
>> Uh
>> thinking on that.
>> We were talking about emergency break
one more, right?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm I'm going to mild
>> just to to have a manageable situation
out of hand. I I misspoke. Uh it is
actually uh Aurora Fura. I you can see
in hand the Aurora is there. So
apologies. A list I actually wanted to
build but [laughter] didn't end up
building. So uh it's certainly
>> okay
>> one of the differences
>> in play.
>> Yes.
>> And
>> Oh yeah. Then here's something. I I know
that the information isn't uh available
right now, but I I do wonder is this one
of those fur lists that can actually
swap out the the package in a similar
way that
>> that Ben Hook Fiora was a list and kind
of catch opponents off guard maybe in
game two when they're, you know, siding
out all of their gear hate. We're going
to have to to latch on a little bit
because I feel like
>> there's a lot of
>> there's a lot of non elder dragons on
the field for [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. But the rift heralds do kind
of help you get there. That's the other
thing. Allowing you to cheat out a unit
real quick.
>> Sure. Uh recycling everything or
>> Yeah, recycling everything. So you don't
get to trigger the death knobs.
>> That makes sense.
Do you want to or
>> uh
>> as you heard uh Frozen say, you don't
get the it doesn't kill. So you don't
get the the death nail triggers. You're
actually recycling rather than uh
destroying or or or killing.
>> So this at five, right?
>> Uh yes.
>> Oh, challenge her and that paid deflect
with
>> all of that. Yeah, perfect. That works.
>> So that comes with a hefty a hefty
little price tag. to get rid of the
>> but it gets the job done. And now look
what is left. The empire of or is
reduced to to rubble and just one lonely
power
>> attacking
>> against two big old Rift Heralds
>> and you get to refill the hand for
frozen. Although this is one of the uh
only things with
Aurora Fura. It it's a little bit more
resilient to having your units in hand
than Civer or Misfortune. Seiver
Misfortune, that's your nightmare is
like drawing multiple big units. Fur is
like, "Nah, Rift Herald will sort that.
Even if I have to sacrifice a Rift
Herald, I'm fine."
>> I've been I've been word smithing a
little.
>> It's right there, right?
>> Fiora,
>> but I like saying Fiora Aurora.
>> Yeah, the hardest thing to say on
>> I think it works too well.
>> Fiora that it's it's tough to get over
the lips. I think yours works better.
>> It's still hard. I every time I I talk
to any of the other casters, like I was
saying to Lothar uh during his stream
the other day, I was like, "Fior Aurora,
we got to play it just cuz it it's hard
to say."
>> I think we should start including it in
our vocal warm-ups.
>> You know what? You're not actually not
wrong.
>> Genuinely not wrong. Uh
>> but this How did I
>> But this is the uphill battle that they
have to to climb up through. Now Orin is
all familiar with reducing mountains to
rubble. However, when it's his own,
>> he
Can he dig himself out? That is really
the question that you're left with here
because there's plenty of time for F to
still surpass our despite them being
inches away from
>> slay with a time lord. Uh
>> oh, I don't get to see what you
>> of dark ice. If he had a time warp, that
would be thematically appropriate, but
uh we'll see if he ever ends up getting
there after the divine.
>> That's a pretty deep.
>> That is a really deep. I like that.
>> Sure.
>> You know what? You didn't react for a
moment and I was like, "Oh, please
please no."
>> Oh, I I'm just like,
>> "Wow."
>> No, take.
>> Okay.
>> Action comes in.
>> Oh.
>> Uh, so
>> that is a big old
>> P. Okay.
>> I'm also going to eight.
>> Yeah.
>> Not too often you see the Aurora.
>> I'll pass to you. You hold the six.
>> Are are we certain it's the Aurora? Yes.
So many units that you possibly hit it.
>> That's That's how resilient this list
is. You actually don't care what you're
getting from the Aurora. It's fine. Um,
but if you get a Rift Herald, you get
any other unit in your hand. Uh, we it's
100% the the Aurora list. We before
Divine Judgment, we saw Aurora in hand
frozen
>> um to get recycled to the bottom.
>> We're still we're still hyped from that
Jin game. That's what I'm going to say.
Anything for like the next 20 minutes
out of us, [laughter] it might take us a
beat. Uh, just coming out of that that
uh incredible Jin win. No, because cuz
here's the thing, right, for me.
>> In all of the the prep up to to read
qualify, you do kind of
>> you kind of got locked into to
archetyping decks. I was like, oh,
Aurora decks look like this. Yes. And
there's no way to build Aurora in any
other way except that one mind player
>> and three Elder Dragon, right?
>> Seeing Seeing players innovate uh on
Aurora of all things, it kind of caught
me off guard. Yeah, we we have seen um
here and there for your Aurora. Um I'm I
I'm pretty sure there were some players
in Vancouver doing it. Um just here and
there. Again, as an Aurora enjoyer, I
keep my uh
>> we we have to cuz this could be the
final push through.
>> I mean, at least to stop Frozen from
double holding.
>> Yeah, I have to commit. What can you get
out of one more draw? double hot or dark
ice to to make one sprite
>> bigger
>> and I will pass here
>> because both of these engines
>> are running on fumes. So Frozen holds to
eight. Is there a way of procking
the Rift Herald? There's an Elder
Dragon, I believe, in hand.
>> Yeah, but he's poor.
>> Yeah, but you never play it. You're
never you're never going to pay the the
cost to play it. Was that just a pass?
>> That was that was just a pass to say,
"Okay, I don't have it right now."
>> Sadly doesn't
>> temporary will trigger on the sprite, so
isn't able to hold to nine.
>> Of course, that happens before scoring.
>> Does he have another? That is really
kind of like one of the few outs that
you have to that is the right amount of
mana. I believe
>> it needs to deal with both.
>> Good.
>> And the thing is if you clear this Rift
Herald, the Elder Dragon comes out from
behind it.
>> I'm pretty sure the Death Nell trigger
will still happen while inside the
showdown. The Elder Dragon will get
played. The damage will come out before
the showdown completes. No one will
score.
>> However, Frozen will wake up with an
Elder Dragon next turn.
>> Yes, exactly. At that point, you're
you're feeling okay about that. That's
if that's the line we end up going down.
>> Yeah. So, going back to the the greatest
just for another draw.
>> Oh. Is actually going to take the
opportunity
>> to get the elder dragon regardless.
>> Uh, sure.
before
>> while they're at two different places.
Now, it's a situation is going to look
to get that elder dragon
trigger and just say, "Nope, no more
units for you."
>> But this is a risk cuz if there's
another unit
>> that comes behind, if there's a way of
creating another sprite, a sprite
fountain, sprite burst are both lethal
right now.
>> You But it's not because you don't score
off Arena's greatest in this situation.
The elder dragon damage happens again,
as I was saying, before scoring. So, you
haven't scored either battlefield at
this situation. Lonely Parro will be the
play following. Elder Dragon now comes
up
>> of all time.
>> And how are how are you going to kick
off an elder dragon? It's a question you
have to be asking yourself. And um
>> not a fair challenge.
>> I am not a therapist, but Clay does not
look comfortable right now.
>> This lonely parro if if this challenge
actually happens at any point,
>> not a fair.
>> You're getting a fair way right with the
shadow. It's plus three out of the top
of my head.
>> Yeah, but all you need is one. It
doesn't matter for the the Elder Dragon
side. All you need is that one point of
damage. So, as long as challenge is a
viable option,
>> that'll definitely do it.
>> So, even on the next turn, there's an
argument to be made for like, do you
want to hold it just in case from what
your opponent does, but the other thing
is they now have to once again find two
big units to go over both battlefields.
Otherwise,
Frozen would hold to win. Has not scored
that ninth point. There's the
concession. Very tense end of a game on
Aspirin's climb and the Fura Aurora for
Frozen will close out the game without
casting Aurora in that we saw at least
this round has been such a pure display
of creativity and innovation from from
the player base coming through.
>> I am deeply impressed. Honestly,
that win on Aurora was very much
deserved and I'm glad it paid off for
Ah, you got me wanting to play Aurora
again. Now I need
>> I I think too soon. Problem was I think
if you stayed loyal to Aurora a little
longer, you might have seen more
success.
>> There were some cards that were missing.
I I got I I I traded for some Rift
Heralds and got there. Congratulations
to Frozen uh for piloting the Fiora
their way to a win in round five. Uh
that means things I'm sure will be
wrapping up in the playing hall very
soon on that round. Uh what a what a
great great round to bring the viewers
at home, especially at such a pivotal
point in day one. You're aiming for six
wins to get into day two. You're looking
for six and two spot cuz you're looking
for 18 points. We haven't talked about
it too much until now, but 18 points is
that threshold for getting into day two.
So a win in the next round if you are 5
and zero guarantees you that we'll move
on to day two. If you got one loss for
now, that's not the end of the world.
You can still fight your way back in,
but it's going to be a tough rest of the
day. Anybody that's accent two from
here, you cannot afford to lose again. I
mean, winning is one thing. Doing it
with the flourishes and style that we
saw in round number five is going to be
a tough act to follow. It will be. We've
heard from one winner from round five.
Let's hear from Frozen, who's with
Barrett.
I'm joined here with our other feature
match winner, Frozen. And first off, I
just have to say I've actually been
following you quite a bit because this
is your fifth regional qualifier now,
right?
>> Something like that. I've been to all of
them, but like the earlier ones, I had
no time to actually play the game. But
yeah, recently since this set came out,
uh I've been I I been just completely
focused on this game. So, I'm traveling
with uh some really strong players and
yeah, just practicing with uh the group.
And it's been paying off because you
just came off of a top 64 finish in
Vancouver. Two weeks later, you were
playing Fiora.
>> Yes.
>> And that game two was so fun to watch.
Just the tools that order and body can
do with the divine judgment, but you
float all the energy and the power. The
challenge
>> was awesome because you know that
they're going to keep their best units.
You get rid of it. They're so far
behind. And because of the Rift Heralds,
you don't care about your runes anymore.
You can play things like the Elder
Dragon, something that looked really
scary for a moment where they almost win
because of the Sprite Call.
>> But can you can you just tell me why a
deck like this can thrive in a in a
format right now cuz you're now 5 and0.
>> So the difference between this and
regular Aurora is that we have a lot of
mid-range units, so we can test in the
mid game, so we can like delay their
point tempo. And then um the the
strength of orange yellow is that you
can uh is uh red hero plus uh elder
dragon, right? So you can have like a
huge comeback mechanic and uh the the
amount of damage your units deal can
like clear any board. So if you can
stabilize to like mid late game, uh you
really don't even need Aurora and you
can win most matchups. Uh the Divine
Judgment deck is like really strong
versus like the new combo decks like Lux
and like uh uh other Aurora decks. any
slow matchup, any deck that's not trying
to like go double conquer on one and
just win the game really fast because
you're the one who who dictates uh
divine judgment. And um by being able to
do so, the deck has a lot of synergies
like I can bring like if I had
sacrifice, I could bring out the elder
dragon on the turn of not not lose
anything, you know, to kill kill my
opponent's board after they only pick
two. Uh there's a lot of combos to do uh
with the deck and uh both me and my
practice group uh think this is one of
our best decks.
>> It it it was so fun to watch. I It makes
me cuz I I play set so like I have the
colors, right? But
>> it makes me want to go and even mess
around with it. Obviously the Fiora like
the R the extra channel rune after
you're playing all these units is really
good obviously, but I'm over here like
play a divine judgment maybe save
another one, you know? Like I'm over
here thinking like, man, you can do this
in anyone with these domains, but Fior
is for sure the best pick and you're 5-0
now. You're one more win away locking in
a day two, so who knows, maybe an even
better finish than Vancouver. So,
congratulations. I know you have more
tournament to play. So, we're going to
go ahead and send it back.
>> All right. Thank you very much.
>> Hello, Rift Bonders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields, [music] but with
unleashed, holding the fields becomes a
whole lot stronger. A standout example
for this is back off. Three energy, no
power. This card on action speed stuns a
unit and draws a card if played from
hand. Incredible. But leaving three
runes open isn't always an option.
Luckily, you can also hide this card if
your runes are exhausted or you want to
keep them open for another card. Fury,
on the other hand, brings plenty of new
ways to assert pressure onto your
opponent. Every jungler's dream is
coming true with smite, finding a new
way to remove units. It simply deals
three damage to a unit at a battlefield
for two energy and one power. While
those stats are not too impressive, the
unit will also be banished when it would
die. This takes powerful death nail
effects out of the equation and can also
remove follow-up if your opponent relies
on resources from their trash like Fiora
worthy that can't be played through
spectral matron anymore. Order has been
known for its hard removal and kill
spells. Now, what if I told you that you
can remove your opponent's hand as well?
Ash Focus gives you full information
about your opponent's hand and lets you
banish a card of choice for five energy
and one power. They will get it back as
soon as they hold the battlefield. But
with full information in one card less
in the opponent's hand, it's now on you
to not let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center.
And now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base. Starcross
reaction speed removal is revolutionary,
especially when it hits [music] the base
as well. For three energy and one power,
you can return a friendly and an
opposing unit back to the owner's hands.
While this can give you an incredible
advantage with play effects, it also
disturbs your opponent. It slows them
down massively and can sometimes deny
powerful effects like Elder Drankren's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the Mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The Mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to Dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units
[music] that are boosted by equipment
gear, you can easily take care of seals,
dazzling aurora, or other great gear
that stands in your way. Now, what's
scarier than body units that are
standing on your opponent's side of the
field just waiting [music] to overwhelm
you with their physical prowess? The
ones you didn't see coming.
Ringa Trophy Hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the bot
states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power,
either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
smite. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after Unleashed?
Show us at your next tournament.
Have you been feeling moody lately? Are
you also tired of conquering for your
points all the time? Do you not want to
play a normie deck like the others? Then
we got the deck just for you. Vex
Gloomist appears in Unleashed, a legend
that massively profits from holding
battlefields. Stop your opponent from
ambushing or accelerating consistently
as early as turn two with Vex apathetic
as your chosen champion unit. Tell your
opponents to back off by stunning their
units when they try to conquer. Play
your shadow ready into battlefields to
immediately use its ability on the
opposing turn. Vex can rely on so many
different defensive tools that the calm
and chaos domain already have. Use
guardian angel and zona's hourglass to
protect your units from dying. Not so
fast and defy to counter opposing spells
and deny their tempo. But also new
defensive cards can be found in
unleashed like existential dread or the
mutated mouser. But in the Shadow Isles,
a monster lurks supporting Vex, giving
her near unlimited defensive and
offensive possibilities. Enter Viol. The
spider god has ambush, meaning it can be
played offensive and defensively. With
this powerful eight might, [music] it
jumps into a battlefield that you are
attacking and crushes any unit smaller
than it without taking a single hit. If
your opponents doesn't manage to push it
out of a battlefield, an additional draw
for holding is a free bonus. With these
cards in your deck, you're going to be
able to keep all the others away from
your battlefields. Keep holding, rift
bounders.
All right, then rift bounders. The
bracket is building. The pressure is
piling. Every single decision could be
the difference between glory
or going home early. That's not what we
want to see. But my name is Shay and I'm
joined by the one and only Leo. Leo,
what's going through your thoughts right
now?
>> It's round six. Nobody is safe yet. You
need to guarantee day two by winning six
rounds even if you're 5 now. If you
don't keep the focus up, you might still
be going home early as you said earlier.
So this is already a really important
round for our players. It really is. And
I'm sure if you are, you know, in that
5-0 record, even if you
thinking, I need to get in day two, try
and get those best offs, try and make
those top cut and beyond. As you say,
you can't really take your foot off the
gas yet if you are 5 and0. However, if
you are 5 and0, you got to win one more
and you can sort of put your feet up a
little bit and say, "Okay, we're in day
two." That's the hard work, though. And
there's a bunch of legends that you can
actually almost get by going to day two
that don't have the highest win rate
ever. So, for example, in Le, I think
there were only like five Lein that made
day two actually. So, you get a
significantly higher chance if you make
it to day two. quite curious to see
because this is the last European event
where you're going to be able to get
those best off prizes for the Origins
Legends. So really, really curious to
see how it goes.
>> Yeah, you know, there are some fan
favorites there in Origins. Of course,
it's going to be your last chance here
to get your hands on those best of. So
those players will be trying their
absolute hardest. If you are in
contention, this rounds that matters.
those sort of best of dreams are made or
broken in these rounds and beyond.
>> But there's also something bittersweet
to it.
>> What's that?
>> That means that probably so many of the
players are going to drop their origins
legends. Actually like
>> seeing prismmeticism on something else
other than any is going to be a little
bit odd. But maybe also players decide
that the legend is just good enough to
win the tournament and they bring it or
it's just their favorite legend. But of
course, playing for a best of pricing is
always a nice little incentive.
>> Of course it is. Those cards are
stunning. So, we're actually going to
get to play a little game ourselves.
Leo, I'm a little bit nervous. Guess
that flavor text. How you feeling about
this one?
>> Horribly. This is the last time I played
that together with James. And I think we
got none. We got decently close with a
card that might be related to the card
that was actually asked for.
>> Okay.
>> For like three corners. So, I think this
is going to be a disaster/massacre for
us, but we can try.
>> Okay. So, are we working as a team or do
we get two separate votes?
>> No, we work as a team.
>> Okay, we're working. Okay, let's sound.
Let's Here we go. Guess along at home in
a venue if you're listening in.
>> Nobody wants to be left holding the
explosive end, the exploding end of the
stick. Okay, this has to be Fury, right?
>> I don't know. I think I mean, I would
have said Ziggs, but Zigs is obviously
not in the game yet. the exploding end
of the stick.
>> It sound like it been that rocket
barrage from last round, but that
doesn't really stick.
>> It's kind of a stick.
>> Okay,
>> it is. I I It's sticky.
>> Okay, are we going to Are we going for
rocket barrage?
>> You know what? Lock it in.
>> Okay, lock it in. I'll be so happy if
that was right. Come on.
>> Oh, detonate. Oh, yeah. True. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> And there's an explosive end to the
stick. It's detonating.
>> That makes sense. I even played that
card in a skirmish with the nice miracle
Draven deck. You know, everyone loved
that detonate
>> treasure trove. Fantastic deck.
>> It was a good deck. I think Prismat had
that in his side deck, I believe, in
coming in our round where we had on
stream as well. So, yeah, currently uh
what 01 on our on our guest to play. We
get do we get another one? We do. Piracy
is universal language. Okay, there's
only a few this could be, right? I'm
think it could be a misfortune. This
could be a first mate perhaps. Pit crew
is pit crew a pyro not pit crew what's
the fella pit uh who gives everyone a
buff when he comes in
>> pit rookie
>> I mean there is also plundering porro
>> so I I pirates are actually really big
part of law so
>> there is a bunch of I I would go for a
pirate card
>> yes I agree hot
>> I definitely agree on that one it says
piracy in the [laughter] name you've
really given us some insight there Leo I
think I've read this before and I I
think I haven't played that many pirate
cards. Misfortune and first mate. I
don't think it's a misfortune. I'm
leaning more towards the first mate for
this.
>> You know what? I'll join you again.
We're going with your gut.
>> Okay. [laughter] So, if it's wrong, it's
my fault again. Here we go. Show us the
first mate.
>> No, it was actually the plundering
borrow. Nice.
>> Oh, production are laughing at me in the
headset right now. They're loving the
fact that we got that wrong. We were in
the ballpark at least.
>> I love the little guy. Yeah, I know.
Okay,
>> it's actually plundering Porro key part
of the Kaiser strategy which is
something that is really really cool to
see.
>> Oh, they have an update. Okay, as
harmless as it is
>> porosex. It's porosex porosex. I'm
locking in poros.
>> Okay, let's lock in poor. He sounded
very very confident there. Oh, do we get
to laugh back at production? Is it?
>> Oh, you are so confident as well.
I guess that's why Scott or Crab has
zero might because everyone's just
eating him apparently. But yeah, we'll
have one more production staff if that
is okay. Yeah, let's go with that. I
guess it is harmless. Well, zero might.
We could have put that together perhaps.
>> Yeah, but I wanted the poros. They're
very harmless as well. [laughter]
>> True.
>> I don't want to eat sem.
>> No. No. Crab is very nice. Okay. Don't
you dare suggest it's a hairpiece.
>> The hair. Shepherum. Oh, okay. That
makes sense. That would be a great
unleash card. I thought it was going to
make Fiora a lot stronger than she
eventually became. I don't even know if
that's the complete name, but I I'm
going to go with
>> Shepherd's Alum. Production is asking.
They're taunting us. Production is
saying, "Are we sure?" That could be
They could be in our ear saying, "Are we
sure?" That could be us trying to throw
us off the scent here, though.
>> Also, if I got that name wrong, that's
going to be super embarrassing. But I
think we we lock in the Shepherd's head.
>> Okay. I haven't got a Scoobies on this
one, so I'm safe to lock in. What were
you said?
Area Kingpin, of course.
All right, that's been a UT regional
qualifier stream and we'll see you
tomorrow. That is a joke. Of course,
we're not actually going anywhere, but I
do need my co-caster to come back and
accept your losses like a man.
>> I'm sorry. I'm [laughter] sorry. I'll uh
>> to be fair,
>> I'll accept this.
>> To be fair, I locked in and I was wrong.
It's only fair that you lock in and also
wrong. There we go. That is why we're
sitting here talking about the game.
We're not playing guesses flavor text
because apparently we're not good about
it.
>> The thing is we are avid TCG players,
right? Traditional TCG players,
>> they don't read the cards. So that is a
whole another example of that happening.
But we of course also have two players
ready. They don't have the headphones on
quite yet. Therefore, we are not going
to reveal any
>> No, we are notation yet. But because
there's a chance they might hear us. If
you hear us, dance a little.
>> Nah, they're not paying attention to
you, Leo. I can tell you that.
>> That's good.
>> But what we can say though is that both
of these players are on a 4-0 record. We
can say that. 5-0 record, I should say,
not 4 and0. That would be the case if it
was last round. But yeah, both of these
players are doing fantastically well. A
win would secure themselves a slot into
day two. We can say that.
>> Yeah. And we have of course looked for
some fantastic decks again which we are
not going to reveal quite yet. There is
a there is a good chance that they have
already revealed the legends to each
other. But of course
>> in case of doubt
>> break glass. I don't know in in case of
doubt just don't say anything yet.
>> We don't want to we don't want to reveal
anything if we could we don't want to
ruin the game of course
>> until both players headsets are on. But
okay, but we can look at this.
>> We have also seen that the players have
already shown their legend. So, we can
say it is Kya versus Ezreal. Super close
matchup. And I'm quite curious to see
how this is going to go in the end. You
know, Ezreal was an absolute powerhouse
in Spirit Forged. Cold shot was probably
the best tool that it had to its name
and that is no longer a thing. So as
player had to change a little bit in
their play style and now the deck is
still pretty strong. You know it shares
domains with Diana.
>> Yeah.
>> However, Ezreal is super controlly and a
part of which players are afraid of is
that they might go into time because it
is so controlly doesn't have any fast
winds. Speaking of fast wins, Kai'Sa, a
deck that was originally in Origins such
a controlheavy deck, has swapped
somewhat
to aggressive versions, even more
aggressive. You know, sometimes people
play Plundering Porro in Spirit Forge
and now Raven Bloom Student has taken
over that party. You have Watchful
Sentry and Raven Bloom Student and
Inferna.
>> So that is an aggressive lineup.
Honestly, looking at this deck list,
almost every single card here is built
to do one thing, and that is deal damage
and remove your opponent's units from
play. Very aggressive. What I like to
see,
>> not every single card because there are
some texts in there. So, first of all,
we have the long sword.
>> Yes.
>> And which you would say, hey, why are
you playing long sword and Kaiser?
That's odd. It's not a spell. You cannot
use the Kaiser legend ability for that.
And the cleave. You want to increase
might in order to combat your biggest
enemy, the Ruin Runner, which is not
going to be necessary versus Ezreal. So,
there is actually even a case to be made
for siding those cards out against
matchups that do not play the body
domain. There's a plundering porro. Aha,
piracy is a universal language.
>> There we go. It all comes full circle
with the plundering porate. It's going
to be a very interesting match cuz
obviously, you know, Ezreal loves to, as
you say, be very controlling, bewitching
spirit. You know, you've got the pack of
wonders and all that stuff. So, he can
draw a lot of cards and, you know, usual
repeat spells over and over again. And
then Kai'Sa, we know using that legend
ability to get an extra power in and
amongst spells. It's going to be a clash
of the magicians here.
>> You know, Kai'Sa was my first ribbon
love
>> and draw for
>> Okay, and here we go. Our Swiss round
six feature match is getting started
here at the regional qualifier here in
Utre. The winner of this will advance,
well most likely advance to day two.
Both players have had their turn one and
we are getting started of our turn to
our Azerial player here. What are they
going to cook up? Leah
>> lecturing Yod on the first turn always
feels so incredibly good when you're
playing generally being the rune is not
the worst thing in the world for that
deck. Oh, a deadly flourish immediately
pushing out the lecturing y and then
getting a gold together with the
plundering porro. That is really, really
nice. However, it's interesting that we
are immediately
>> we're not going into the frozen
fortress. I was going to say that would
be weird, but we went to do the star
spring, so we are not threatening a
stupify kill.
>> Oh, actually looking at that hand, that
hex tag ray looks juicy. We might have a
few too many of those.
>> I'll tap one. Use my legend and play
this on the portal.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> Kaiser legend ability. Very very nice to
just take this out and perhaps go for a
Kaiser or a two black Nox.
>> Wow. Yeah, look at that synergy there
using the hex tech in combination with
the legend letting you activate Legion
for the Noxus. Hopeful
>> and then it is over to Ezreal now with
two gold one of which is being used.
It's looking like going to be for that
champion unit. trigger
and
>> you don't want to DM too early. So
getting early gold with something like
deadly flourish on the plundering borrow
very valuable
>> draw two cards
>> gusting discarding gust is
>> also pay for
>> I think in this matchup better than in
other matchups.
>> Yeah,
>> but gusting something like a watchful
sentry can really help you.
>> So it is going to be back over to Kaiser
now. Nox is hopeful is ready can get
involved.
Let's see what we can cook up here.
>> Oh god,
>> I'm going to charge in for the showdown.
>> That's going to be a nice conquest there
to get Kaiser on the board. One point.
>> Let's see what else we have in the hand.
You mentioned there might have been some
more hex tech. I haven't had a chance
myself to consult the hand yet. Going to
see two. Oh, it's going to be a falling
star letting you target. We do three
damage twice.
>> Will we see a response? No. It looks
like that is going to be the board right
with a falling star. Uh,
>> and now it is over to Ezreal now. Oh,
no, it's not, is it? Wait, is it? No,
>> we still have a lot of runes open. I
would be surprised actually, Leo.
>> I mean, that does happen with any deck,
right?
>> Oh, no. Here we go. Oh, we see a lot of
runes. What could this be?
>> That is the Kai'Sa.
>> Accelerated.
>> We're going conquest.
>> That's fine. I press back.
>> Okay, I conquer.
Trigger Kai'Sa. I draw one.
>> Mhm.
Okay,
>> two, right?
>> Strong turn there. Hasn't got any runes
open. Is over to Ezreal now.
>> Yeah, and Ezreal is also in singularity
range. If you have this in I think that
is a lightning fast
>> that's going to deal six to two units at
battlefields. They are both at
battlefield. Sorry, but they are both
going to get sent to the trash.
>> Question is, is that a hard punish on
the situation on the Ezreal draw again
as well? One rune to few to drop that
bewitching spirit which will be the
icing on the damage cake.
>> Question is how
>> dish out now. Does not look like he has
anything two time war in hand.
>> Yeah. Oh wow. No playables or nothing he
wants to play I should say. So is back
over to Ezreal now.
>> I will start with a pack of wonders.
Yep.
>> And follow it up with a bewitching
spirit.
>> Uhoh.
>> Okay, I'll discard
>> time warp.
>> Surely.
>> But I mean, maybe you will need to have
>> time warp.
>> Okay, we we get rid of the time warp.
But at some point, you might have to
cheese a win and double time warp is
>> a heck of a way to win a game.
>> That is a very cheeky way to win the
game. I can tell you that. But here
we're going to see the sort of
bewitching spirit loop which makes this
Azerial deck really terrifying cuz it
can do damage. It can hand rip from your
hand as well. Quite honestly, it can do
a great lot of things. It's over to
Kaiser now. Didn't play a card last
turn. Will we be doing something here?
Surely
>> now the Ezreal unit has been removed
already. And that one was a way more
important one
>> back in the day, right? When you could
repeat call shots were almost free.
>> I've recycled one red
to my base. Yeah, that's fine.
>> Still got four open.
>> I mean, that is the scenario in which
Ezreal wants to be in, right?
>> This is looking so incredibly good.
You're up in runes. Your opponent has
passed one full turn already.
>> Yeah.
>> Deck
>> and now you're looking at just the
Darius
>> top three.
>> And Darius is a decently sized body, but
Azer has a multitude, a cornucopia of
ways of just keeping your opponent's
board nice and anemic. And then you can
just start to run away. As you do say,
this domate shares the domains
with Diana which we all know is a
terrifying two domains to be have access
to.
>> Do you want to cut? No.
>> Serate taking the Fizz Trickster
swimmingly to hand.
>> Gets plus one. Yep.
>> And I will play another
>> Oh, here we go. See that Bewitching
Spirit coming down again.
>> We're starting the nasty stuff. Pack of
wonders on the field already can bounce
back the bewitching spirit with haste
and just play it out again. As long as
your opponent doesn't pressure you,
there is no issue in the just
>> three runes recycling one.
>> Three. This is going to be the star
crossing spirit and Darius.
>> Wow, that's going to remove the bering
spirit and the darus that is going to go
through.
>> We can play beritching spirit again.
>> Student getting buff
and
>> stronger. Oh my goodness. Be witching
spirit again.
>> How many times can you afford to just
eat those bewitching spirits?
>> Leah sword.
>> All right, I'll return it to my hand.
>> Quite a few times. I mean, you're now at
one rune open now. Pushes the Raven
Bloom Student into the Starring
>> which will be a negative trick. Oh, and
I think we are going to see a hex tech
following this up immediately.
>> Should I use this? Okay, so we'll have
plus one
>> and then uh tap one use my legend play
hex tech ray targeting it.
>> We have a gust to answer this but we
don't want to go for it. Want to keep
this defensively
>> as does.
>> Okay, so was some nice defensive play
there
>> from Kaiser
and
>> but after that hand being removed so
much on the bwitchian spirit I need to
see some options. What are we? We know
that there was another time war in the
hands. You say might have been holding
on to that. Might need to be able to use
that to try and get back in this game.
>> And I think Serat also keeps the gust
for a potential conquer with
>> Darius coming straight back down after
that star cross.
>> And then I'll top two play this guy.
This red is Darius. He gets plus two
mate.
Thanks.
And I'll move here and pass to you.
>> That's fine.
>> Okay. So, Darius's coming in with that
ability coming in ready. After the
Legion,
we'll be able to get up.
>> And I pass the top.
>> All right.
>> I will ready.
>> Is back over to Ezreal.
>> He's usually a deck that can have so
many cards in hand, so many different
draw effects. Progression Day also a
card that has been played a lot in the
past at least.
>> Cards in hand is two.
>> Two. Uh oh. You know when your opponent
asks how many cards are in your hand and
you apply with two,
it might not be two for very long. I can
tell you that for free.
>> Yeah, I think Bewwitching Spirit plus
Pack of Wonders or another Bewitching
Spirit is just a full hand loop already.
>> Yeah.
>> Thing is, if you do that, you're not
going to get rid of the Darios this
turn. You're going to give your opponent
unnecessary points,
>> which I'm not too sure you want to do.
>> Yeah, I guess with no units developed.
card time warp.
>> There goes that second time
>> war to my hand.
>> Yeah,
>> I will play.
>> Oh, no. Straight back down again.
>> K is on a zero card hand now. Leo.
>> Oh, wait. We have six runes open after
this. So, wages of pain getting a gold
token and then a Fizz play to just Wages
of Pain again from the trash is
definitely a possibility here.
>> Wow, what a turn. The Fizz is going to
reuse that wages of pain. That's going
to be six damage dealt to that Darius.
No response from Kaiser.
And this is what Azeriel loves to do.
Remove options, remove units, remove all
counterplay.
>> So I get to draw one with
>> Oh, gets to draw one as well. So many
targeting effects can pass. And now this
bewitching spirit and the fizz
trickster.
>> They're just threatening units all of a
sudden. Of course, you have the watchful
sentry, but if you decide to conquer
with the sentry, you could get a free
point. It's going to get traded away and
then bewitching spirit is going to be
looped so hard again.
>> Yeah. I'll go here and pass you.
>> With the gust, you can actually
guarantee it, right? You can conquer
with fizz. Let your opponent draw a
card, then play the bewitching spirit uh
back with the pack of wonders. Play it
into the battlefield and then gust it
from there.
>> You can still
dupify just to draw one from one.
>> So that would be what two in hand
currently I believe. Is it two?
>> Should be at one.
It's just so scary to be in that sort of
top deck mode. Yeah. But that's I think
that's all we can do there for Kaisa is
over to Azeriel. Now as you do say
>> as a multitude of ways just to remove
all these options from Kaiser.
>> I will move to Starring with Bewitching
Spirit.
>> Past priority
>> and that is such a funny thing to see
opening the combat
>> with Bewitching Spirit. Of course fully
knowing.
>> Okay, I'll predict from
>> Oh, an eclipse. You're going to look at
the top card of your deck. But how much
is that going to help you? I think you
either let this bewitching spirit die
here or you save it. In the end, this
card doesn't matter too much anymore
because it just doesn't really, you
know, rip a lot of cards from hand
anymore after this.
>> I will gust your watchful sentry.
>> Yeah, really.
>> Oh yeah, that makes a lot more sense.
>> And I move to conquer.
>> Yeah,
>> you conquer. You gust the watchful
sentry. Then you pack of wonders, your
bewitching spirit, and then you play it
out again. conquer in the fortress with
a fizz as well. So you're starting to
slowly but surely reps
>> and that's going to discard that there
back into the into the trash now
>> for Azerial
>> stat. And this is where Azeriel loves to
be with your opponent having no cards in
hand and you can slowly just develop
your units and start to take over the
battlefield. And
>> I will move with fist into the frozen
fortress.
>> Yeah, we are going to see a conquer
there to three.
>> Yep.
Ezreal is so far ahead
>> right now. Almost impossible to get back
from this position as the Kai'Sa. I
mean, it does not look too threatening
what's on board, but how are you going
to find your way back into this? This is
I think it it could be a possible scoop
angle where you're not coming out of
this to save some time
>> potentially. I mean, you have so many
runes up, but then you're only playing
off a top. I can't think of a one card
answer that immediately gets you back
into this game. Kaiser is a really
aggressive deck. What are we finding
here?
>> Play Falling Star.
>> Falling Star
>> and Raven Bloom.
>> Yeah, that's answers the board just a
little bit, but you're also not scoring.
>> That is not developing your board. You
have very few units in the deck that
will have to get a lot of conquers. The
play styles of these decks, they are
somewhat similar.
>> I will give you that. However,
Ezreal has a lot more removal and then
can rip cards from hand so that the
removal of Kaiser doesn't stick. So,
Ezreal will play with so many more units
in the long game
>> is looking so much better for the Ezreal
player when it comes to the matchup.
>> I think Ezreal is just so versatile,
isn't it? Has removal, has ways to
disrupt your opponent's hand,
>> quite honestly, just do so much. And as
the the the longer the game goes on,
Ezreal just feels so much more favored.
Quite honestly, it seems like it can't
do no wrong at this point. Can put the
Fizz back to hand because of the pack of
wanders.
>> Yep. Targeting you, but uh
>> yeah, I don't have cards in hand. As to
you, [laughter]
>> targeting you, but you know,
>> but you know, turns out you haven't got
no cards in your hand, so it's not it's
not going to do anything. But
>> that's a tech doesn't even have to say
it anymore. It's just, you know,
>> best card.
>> All right.
>> And the watchful center gets played.
Holding point from a witching spirit. Do
you see that every day? actually when
they get to start looping. Yes, you see
that every day.
>> You see that quite often. That's how you
know that's sort of the you're in the
driver's seat in the bridge and spirit
start to hold. We are going to see that
conquer. No response of course
>> going to six foren fortress. A very
neglected battlefield so far in this
game. There was only always conquerors
in the star spring.
>> Pay two and recycle two runes.
>> Pay two recycle to bellowing breath.
>> And we are so far ahead that we can just
repeat that for the Ezreal draw. I will
return the bewitching spirit to my hand.
>> Leo, this is this is hard to watch at
this point. Any defense
>> player is trying to put
>> one. That's fine.
>> He's just getting answered straight
away.
>> Mhm.
>> I'll bottom this.
>> Oh, that is also not the top deck that
>> wanted. But what?
>> Yeah, draw with repeat. So, I targeted
twice. Yeah,
>> use that Ezreal still after having this
bellow and another plundering porro. A
army of small units that don't seem to
threatening build up in base going wide
wide wide
>> is going to get one draw. But what are
you trying to find here?
>> An answer. Anything quite honestly
something ruination.
>> I'll pay bars breath.
>> Oh,
>> okay. Yeah, that's fine. In your base.
Yeah, hold on.
>> There we go. That's a pretty good
answer. That Bellarin breath has going
to be the reverse board wipe now. It
feels that was the bare minimum for
Kaiser to stay in this game. It's over
to Ezreal now. What can we do?
>> Play Fizz.
>> Fizz. Well, it's just going to find us
then.
>> Yeah, I think Fizz is just going to
>> get more and more value in there.
Another stack deck. Then Pack of Wonders
is going to bounce the Fizz. You're
slowly but surely cycling through all of
those spells in your trash. checking
because of Fizz.
>> You're filling up your deck again. So,
you're also not going to deck out with
this uh pack of wonders.
>> Fizz, dude.
>> Look at this. Multiple stack decks use
just being able to just filter cards
into your hand. I took decision between
bellowing
spirit, sorry, and the fizz as well.
Look like spirit was taken.
>> Bewitching spirit.
>> I mean, you just need to find any unit
to threaten, right? You're on six
points. Play the spirit. try to target
you, but obviously there is no card in
hand. So, we are setting up for a game
in the next turn. Dizia will need to
find another card to save him somehow.
Maybe a watcher that pushes itself into
a
>> battlefield, but pass.
>> Fizz is secure. I also really like that
if we have anyways.
>> Yeah, here we go. Big draw. We saw the
bellowing breath last turn. That was
very helpful.
The speed of which Kaiser is playing
here makes me realize
>> cross in trash.
>> Uh, yes.
>> Probably not the greatest.
>> No, it's fine.
>> What can we thinking about asking about
what's in the trash? Just trying to work
out what options have available, if any.
>> You're at six. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> So, let's go next.
>> All right.
>> And it is just going to be the
concession there from Carson. And Ezreal
is going to win our game one here in our
Swiss round six feature match. Remember
the winner of this will find themselves
[music] in day two. But what a solid
masterass that was from Ezreal.
Absolutely dominating the Kaiser.
Removing all the options from the hand,
removing [music] all the options from
the field. And we are going to a game
two.
And if you are the Ezreal player, you
must just be on top of the world right
now. That is what you want going into
this, you know, a win and in scenario
putting on a strong game one. And you
still have side deck pressure.
>> Exactly. Just really showing off what
Ezreal is supposed to do here in the
unleashed format.
>> And what a dominant showing. Of course,
you go to the feature match, you are 5
in the RQ, and it is already a little
bit stressful, right? You have played
few hours of riftbound already. That is
exhausting at some point. And then
you're seeing a matchup that you can
start dominating.
Yeah, quite honestly, you know, that's
what you want, especially, you know, if
you are going into your winning scenario
and you find out you're going to be the
feature match, but you think, "Okay, now
I've got all the cameras and the lots.
Got all this to deal with here." But,
you know, as long as your deck does what
it needs to do and as you said, the the
Azerial Azerial [music] deck did exactly
what it needed to do. It looks like
we're going to see some sideboard. And
there's like the caric coming in
perhaps. Was that taken out? I'm not
sure. But that caric that's a scary
card.
>> Yeah. I mean, Serate just really, you
realize that's not his first rodeo,
right?
>> Yeah. really dominating that game. Feel
like we've seen said dominating so many
times now about this, but that was just
what it was, right?
>> That was a domination. But let's talk
about the reverse side now for, you
know, if you're the Kaiser player here,
you know, game one hasn't really gone
your way. Are there any changes in
strategy or any cards you think could be
included here from the side deck that
could make this, you know, a bit more
better?
It's that was a deep I think you need
some sort of gear removal so that you
can have the chance to stop the pack of
walkers madness
>> together with the bewitching spirit.
>> You need to basically hope a little bit
that your opponent doesn't find all the
pieces to the puzzle immediately.
>> Yeah. And then if your opponent can't
fizz or pack of wonders loop their
bewitching spirits and you get to
actually find some god. But I mean,
we're not even playing cards like
Progression Day. Those cards
traditionally help you in this matchup
quite a bit. Maybe something to put in
from the sideboard if there is one
because then I mean if your opponent
really works hard, spends like 10 runes
to just or 10 energy to get your hand
discarded. Get get you like three hand
trips or sometimes two if you involve a
phase and a gust
>> and you draw four with progression day.
I think that's a better progression for
you than for your opponent. That could
be a way to progress onto day two. It
could be could be said. So, gear removal
potentially and progression day could be
moving in to our main deck if you are a
Kaiser player. And I think if you are
Ezreal, I think it's just business as
usual to be fair. That was a solid solid
game plan there. Just removing all the
units, removing all the hand, removing
all hope quite honestly. And that's what
you want to do. So, let's we are going
to be starting our game two here on our
Swiss round six feature match. We are
going to see the fist bump and let's get
into some rift bound.
>> All right, Arena's greatest. That is
certainly going to help Kaisa
usually. However, in the last game, we
reached four points in total. [laughter]
>> Still falling a little bit short, it's
safe to say. And it looks like Forbidden
Waste will be the other battlefield of
choice, I'm assuming. Yeah, from our
Azreal, our Ezreal player.
Time warp in the hand again. It looks
like that is going to get mulligan that
we don't need to be holding on to that
right now. I can tell you that we need
value. We need quick aggro cards here if
you are a Kaiser player.
>> But here we go. We are getting started
over to Kaiser. Jaw for turn. Two runes
open. And I think was that just a pass?
>> Nah. Nah. I think that was just the
arena's greatest trigger that we
>> Oh, okay. Yep, that works.
>> So, we note that down. That is uh Oh,
very close though. That's just a pass
that is very harshly punished especially
in this
>> I think it was. Yeah, it was. That's not
what you need Leo in a win and in game
two. We need units. We need pressure. We
need something to stop this. Ezreal just
walking all over us. But it is over to
Ezreal now. I think Plundering Porro was
in hand. There it was.
Oro is absolutely insane providing gold
for free soon especially if you don't
want to develop another unit in the next
turn because if we're looking at Sarat's
hand there is not too much maybe you
could play from the champion zone
>> there's a letter in order now the
chances of this porro conquering and
then getting punished for it
>> getting lower and lower actually
>> and you don't want to be giving Ezreal
that free gold that can go into honestly
it can just power so much
>> trust me
>> but at least At least the Yoda will be
able to draw.
>> We're going to see a response. Hex Tech
Ray.
>> I don't know if we want to let this go
through. There is a potential to
>> bounce it back with a Gust, but says,
"Nope, I'm playing the long game here.
I'm playing the defensive game. I just
need to drain you out of resources. So,
I will take that trade."
>> Also, Gust is a powerful tool in the
endame to deny cards like the Watchful
Sentry.
Okay, Yodoro is ready. We can charge him
in.
>> I will play a stupify
>> on that Yord.
>> It's going to get to draw one.
>> Another card.
>> I pass back.
>> And now are we using the wages of pain?
Yes.
>> Oh wow.
>> Get the legend prodigal explorer
legendary ability.
>> So the skills I get gold.
>> Feels a little bit reminiscent of game
one here.
>> Sure. Ezreal has had to jump through a
little bit more hoops, but
>> doing the game plan.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh
>> Oh, the champion coming down. Not with
Accelerate though. Is over to Ezreal.
>> I like the way Dier approaches this one
now because
>> we don't play hard into the singularity.
Like last game was a really really high
commitment into singularity completely
tapping out with an accelerated Kaiser.
>> At least with two runes open, there is a
possibility for a retreat which might be
a card that Sarat needs to play around.
Apathetic
>> really really strong card against Kaiser
as well. At a certain point the deck
wants to either accelerate its own
Kaiser which now is redundant.
>> Uh but Thousand Tales Watcher or Darius
are cards that are not going to do a lot
of work against it. So you're either
forcing your opponent to play them out
now or Kaiser ever. Also X has the
deflect keyword which itself makes it
kind of broken versus drop from Kaiser.
>> Yes, at least you have the Kaiser to pay
for that deflect cost essentially. But
you're right, forcing more resources
than you'd otherwise like.
>> Kai'Sa can only pay for spells.
>> Oh, I apologize. Yes, that vex
apathetic. Honestly, what a card that
most played unit here in. We are going
to see an inferno coming down.
>> Oh, we are going to
>> play this guy.
>> Mhm.
>> They hopeful. I like
>> I like this.
>> And it is going to be the pass. But I
like it's just getting units into play.
So if Vex was to get developed at the
battlefield, at least you can charge
them in.
>> Oh, how many runes do we have? We're at
589. That is
>> Oh, but there is the singularity.
>> What are we targeting here?
>> I think Kaisa plus Noctus hopeful. Yeah,
they're the obvious choices.
>> Will that go through?
>> That is going to be a draw for the
Azreel as well.
>> Then I will draw with my legend.
>> Yeah, massive turn. We were just saying
how much we like that turn there for
Kaiser. opposite of game one, but Ezreal
just immediately closing the door of
opportunity there.
>> Yeah, if he had one more rune, the
deadly froze could have been. I really
like the conservative play with the Vax
Apathetic. The card is so useful and
especially this match up and basically
every fury matchup
>> that you don't want to risk it at all
against an inferno that is developed in
the base, right? You only have wages of
pain as aust.
>> You are not really threatened. Oh,
there's the wages of pain on the
inferno. That's going to stop that
conquest there. It
>> does.
>> Wow. This honestly Ezreal is just having
its way all over this game.
>> Watchful sentry.
>> I mean, we haven't started
>> looping the witching spirit yet.
>> No, we haven't.
>> Mhm.
>> Oh, another Noxus hopeful though.
>> If he finds stupify, then deadly
flourish plus stupify would be amazing.
drawing two cards. Getting rid of that
card.
>> Fellowing breath
>> works. Oh my goodness, that card is good
here. [laughter]
>> Fellowing breath. Deal one to two units
or three units at the same location, but
you can repeat it. Of course, that will
also get you the Ezreal draw as well.
>> You don't need to because you will throw
the deadly flourish at the Noxus Hopeful
afterwards. That one is going to die.
You also get the gold token and you will
get that draw. This has one.
>> Yeah, one damage immediately.
>> And here,
>> but you can also deadly flourish and
then get rid of it.
>> Wait for four.
>> Yes. Four, not three. This is not wages,
although it plays like wages.
>> I will play Eclipse.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, Eclipse gets you there as well.
>> Yeah. Resolves. He's dead.
>> Wow. This is honestly Leo, if I'm the
Kaiser player here, I'm thinking I'm
just putting stuff down and it's getting
sent straight to my trash. Like, what
[laughter] what how am I meant to try
and win this game, Ezreal? You're being
a bit rude if you ask me. And you get
the draw as well. Still got all those
runes open as well, Leo.
>> Now, I can imagine that we start going
for Vex Conquers because quite frankly,
there can't be anything that is too
threatening. However,
>> in Battlefield, you're opening up
something like a wages from the Kaiser.
>> So, as we have very few units, I could
still see Ser.
Yeah, I don't mind it. Just make sure
there is no options. And fora has been,
you know, putting loads of cards in
play, but they have been removed. So,
you know, in theory, the hand rip is
still kind of alive cuz they're putting
multiple cards down and they are getting
removed.
>> Haven't quite been able to see what's in
our Kaiser players hand here, but
I can't imagine. I mean, what what
ideally what we looking for here? Units.
>> Singularity of course. Yep.
>> That would also be fantastic firing off
at yourself. Your response doing six to
two
>> units. Also, you can then of course
exhaust the Kaiser legend and pay
deflect cost and then you are just
dramping for two, which would be perfect
since you're already at 12. So, ding
kind of is efficient actually.
>> Here we go.
>> Recycle spell targeting this and this.
One more for the deflect.
>> Yeah, looks fine.
>> So, that's is going to remove the Ezreal
champion, but Vexaffect will still have
one left
one.
>> I think you're right.
>> Targeting. There we go.
>> For deflect.
>> I'm liking this. And that is going to go
through as well. Leah, the reverse
board, right? I love this. We are
trading blows here. The pendulum of
power is swinging left, is swinging
right.
>> Wow.
>> Uh, pass the turn.
>> This is one of those games where
nobody's going anywhere. Both players
have identified that if you play a unit,
it most certainly won't stick for a long
time.
>> So, we're just chilling now. But I think
it's still of highest priority to fight
units.
>> Yeah, it's interesting. You want to get
units down, but they are just swiftly
getting sent to the trash. Stack deck.
Did find a stack deck. That's going to
give you an effective six cards to look
at. I think that Sar is really trying to
find Bewitching Spirit now.
>> And
>> oh, there's one. Is that That is one,
right? Yeah, in the middle.
>> Let's see. Is Is the theory correct or
not? I could Oh,
>> cards in hand.
>> Is that pack of ones? [laughter]
>> There we go.
>> Six. Did he say was that six?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Quite a long time before we get
into spirit bewitching spirit loop then.
What was that? Did you see what was
taken?
>> Yeah. Pack of wonders.
>> Pack of wonders.
>> That sets up for quite some loops.
>> And I will pay a plundering porro for
two.
>> Yep.
>> Immense pressure oozing out of this
plundering poro. Of course.
>> One, two,
>> gold. Gold and pressure at the same
time. I do like not dropping a
bewitching spirit here if you would have
taken it because then you can just push
for a point with the plundering.
>> You're a play into battlefield and then
loop it with Gus.
>> But also just setting up a pack of
wanders and then I mean at some point
you will have to find Bewitching Spirit,
right? We're halfway through our deck
already. There's three copies in there.
We know that one is under the deck now.
>> I don't know how many we recycled so
far. If we have maybe mulligan to away
some of those.
>> I'll pass.
>> Oh,
>> ready.
>> Just to pass. I say just a pass. There's
a lot of runes open of course, but no
units developed. Is over to Ezreal now.
Could this be the turn that he has been
waiting for? Pack of wonders comes down.
Plundering Porro Conquest. Is that going
to go through?
>> And that is surely not.
>> Two in a legend.
>> Smite. Is that going to go through? That
is okay.
>> Yeah,
>> response number one. That's absolutely
fine. And I think that Serat is really,
really happy about that even because he
just traded a plundering pearl for
another card in hand. And now you can
just start slamming down Bewitching
Spirit. The less cards your opponent
has.
>> There you go. Right on Q.
>> Yeah.
>> Discard a card.
>> Discard one.
>> Discard
Singularity. And I will
>> That is a huge discard. And we do that
same stuff again, but not yet, of
course, because otherwise cards like
Singularity or Deadly Flourish. You
discarded Singularity kind of telegraphs
that there is another one of those. And
if your opponent hits it, you're out of
Bewitching Spirit. So, you have to be
very, very cautious. I love this about
the way Sarate plays. He's a control
player and he knows that he has to get
the maximum amount of value out of every
single card he plays. Therefore, he's
really really cautious. Also, if you
have analyzed the last turns closely,
not a lot is going on for Dizzia
aggressively. [laughter] There is
there's just not a lot happening. We are
at two to one points in the arena's
greatest game, mate.
>> That is a great point.
>> And yeah, you're right. It's not like I
could go gung-ho on the hand, but you're
right. I mean, what has Dia been
presenting threats?
>> Not a great deal.
>> Oh, play turn to dust on your pack of
wonder.
>> Okay. I think that was a sided card
there. That turn to dust. that pack of
wonders been given that temporary tag
that will be getting discarded at the
end.
>> Awaken.
>> But
>> there we go.
>> Pack of wonders also traded for another
one of those cards in hand. And now
Serate, his opponent is not really doing
too much. So he can basically just
really easily chill.
>> Bewitching spirit number one.
>> I would have said he would have not
played the Bewitching Spirit if he
didn't top deck one more.
>> That mean Yeah. Yeah. Now you've got
more free reign to get more liberal with
your Bewitching Spirit usage. And I'll
drop
>> Is that just a pitching spirit and a
pass?
>> Yeah.
>> The battle of attrition here in our
Swiss round six feature match. If you
are just joining us, the winner of this
match will advance to our second day of
competition. Diz is currently one game
down. We'll need to win this and game
three to get to that 6 and0 record.
Zetic currently one game.
>> How much of a battle is it really
though? because Dizzy can really not
afford this bewitching spirit to conquer
because otherwise it's just going to get
gusted back and we have a whole more
hand looping action going on.
>> Yeah, but he isn't to know that but I
mean I don't know
>> has a ton of options.
>> Recycle both
>> two and recycle two bellowing breath
>> that will be a killed bewitching spirit.
No looping shenanigans yet.
>> Do we see a unit? I would like to say
how many cards.
>> Oh no. Going to be the inferno.
>> How many cards Dizzia still has in hand?
>> Don't have any runes.
>> I think he could be down to two cards in
total.
>> I think I make it two or three. Yeah,
hard to tell.
>> Oh, are you seeing what I'm seeing? This
might be a dead unit. Can we Can we kill
the Inferno? Can we do it? Can we do it?
Double.
>> Wow.
>> Now we're going to get Ezreal drawn out
as well because of the repeat.
>> Wow. Honestly,
>> there's the beitching spirit.
How many cards do we have?
>> It's more than one. Otherwise, you
wouldn't be thinking
>> three. Currently three cards in hand.
>> All scared watcher. I
>> think that was the watcher. Yeah, I
think one of those other cards is time
warp as well. Leo, I think
>> and draw for turn.
>> That is actually a very brave bewitching
spirit. But maybe you're looking at the
treasure of Dia. There is not too many
more cards that can get rid of this
card. You have the Star Frost in hand to
bounce it.
>> Uh, your opponent doesn't have a unit on
board. Never mind.
Tap 10.
>> Oh, there's a time warp.
>> Here it is.
>> The time warp.
>> I think you can respond to that with a
star cross. And I would not even hate
that play
because then your opponent doesn't even
get a conquer off of it.
>> That's banished.
>> Uh put it here.
>> All right.
>> Then again, you can also just chill,
right? You can also use the time warp on
the second turn.
>> So let's see what that time time war.
That's a very very costly
>> ready a card. Draw a card. Actually,
it's fine. arguably the most expensive
way to ready a car, but that time will
give Dia a second turn essentially.
>> I'll move here and pass two.
>> That's fine.
>> We'll get the conquer. We'll get the
point for his third point of this match.
By the way,
>> he just doesn't care, does he?
>> No, he's so nonchalant been like, you
can do what you want. I'm still in the
driver's seat. But hey, Da is putting
points on the board. This is what you
need. Points is how you win. Not the
most explosive of time warped turns I
think it's safe to say but does get a
point on the board. Does get a unit to
stick. Star cross currently in hand
though
>> into the forbidden waste.
>> Oh into forbidden waste. That makes this
card go zero when it's being attacked.
However, not too much attacking action
going on. Deadly flourish being
considered onto this Raven Bloom
student.
>> Yeah.
>> Do we have something like a super fight
so that we can trigger the
>> Ezreal legend? No.
>> And
Doesn't look like it yet.
>> Two cards in hand currently for Dizzier,
but it's just going to be the pass.
>> I think Serat is chilling massively on
this because he knows he has double gust
in hand to just bounce it back whenever
Dizzier just attempts get rid of this
spirit. That is one of the cards you
don't want to see. Cards that put units
on board and then replace themselves
immediately like the lecturing yord.
>> But at least it can't be followed up
immediately by a time war.
>> Yep.
uh hold to.
>> So we are just going to see the hold
there. So Zeretic is actually catching
up on points here.
>> Drop.
>> We are jostling for ball control. Wow,
another gust
off the top. Thousand eyes watcher
currently in the hand as well. Quite a
few options, but
Singularity currently in hand as well.
>> At which point do you just start gusting
your bewitching spirit?
>> Yeah, I think you're right. Just close
the door down.
Well,
>> there's a singularity,
>> but I mean, I think I'm just suggesting
this gust play
>> because I really want something to
happen [laughter]
>> because I think he's in no position
where he has to throw gusts down. He
just singularities one singular y
because he knows my opponent is not
going to commit to the board.
>> Oh, we get a look at chance to consult
the hand perhaps. Four cards now. I'll
tap five recycle one red play Darius in
base
>> Darius going to come down.
>> Okay.
>> Was that a car six as well? I think in
the hand as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Is a
>> but yeah
>> cannot be a Kha'Zix
>> and
>> so it cannot cause it can't. So I
apologize.
>> Don't worry about it. Oh, another unit
that can be developed. Now we're going
completely loco on the side of Sarat.
[laughter]
>> I will.
>> So many options.
been very patient
>> into this battlefield.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, now we are not getting the debuff
for defending. Things are looking crazy
here.
>> Is that Darius going to hang around
though?
>> Starcross is in the hand. Of course,
>> Starross.
>> There we go. Right on Q.
>> Ah, he wants to force his opponent to
play more cards as well with the Darius
so that it has to accelerate otherwise
it gets bound every single time.
>> Do we play this into the battlefield?
Yes, because we want to be able to gust
it now. Our units are actually safer in
the battlefield rather than in our base.
>> And you've seen that the last time Shay
and Drop turn.
>> Wow. Okay, Ezreal just slowly advancing
that controlling resource management
strategy. And if you're dizzier,
I don't know. You know, Darius is
currently in the hand, but I just say it
would cost a lot of resources to get
that accelerate off.
>> I'm getting dizzy watching this. We
>> rich in spirits just flying around. I
mean, we have been in a time warp this
game as well. You mean I wouldn't blame
you for forgetting that. That wasn't the
most explosive of time warp, but you
know.
>> Oh,
>> here we go. Uh-oh.
>> Eight.
>> That must be an accelerated thousand
tailed Watcher.
>> Okay, here we go.
>> Just right after we've seen a star
cross, so I know where this is coming
from. However,
if you have one star crossed in Ezreal
after 20 turns, there's a good chance
there is going to be another one. Just
>> you wouldn't. Oh no, Zeretic.
>> The star crossed immediately sending
that thousand tailed Watcher back to the
hand. Any combat potential, the door
gets closed.
>> But at this point, Seritech is also not
making too many points, right? He's F5
now.
>> That's fair. So that watcher problem is
delayed for just a second.
>> That's the thing about star cost isn't
removed to
>> what do we what do we see? What do we
see?
>> A pack of wanders that is going to be
absolutely massive here.
>> No,
>> three long sword is discarded. So we
know about Darius in hand and we know
about the thousand tailed watcher in
hand.
>> Don't know how many cards are still
left. Pack of wonders. Be witching
spirit. We are bewitching you so hard.
>> Singularity. So now we know with that
pack of wonders, we can get so much more
liberal with our bewitching spirit.
>> Bewitching spirit.
>> Here we go. This is the turn you was
talking about, Leo, where bewitching
spirits are going to be flying around.
Everybody close your windows. You don't
want spirit to enter.
>> All on tap.
>> What can Dizzier do?
>> Channel two and draw one. Yeah, I think
I'm cooked.
>> I think you might be as well, Dia. I
think you might be too.
>> I have to three.
>> How many cards in hand? Uh, three.
>> Three.
>> It's also not too many cards.
>> Not too many cards to be. It did just,
you know, unleash a flurry of cards to
get the Bewitching Spirit out of course.
Pack of Wonder Gus and Beiriting Spirit.
>> What can we do? Dizzy, are you cooked as
you are you cooked? That's what you
said.
>> Here we go.
>> Tap eight again.
>> Mhm. and two blue to accelerate the
watcher.
>> Yes,
>> mine will have one.
>> And I'll go here and pass two. That's
fine. You conquer the
>> got to score some points at some point.
>> I mean, that is a big body, Leo. Not the
easiest one in the world to remove.
>> You know what? Removes a watcher.
>> Hey, watcher.
>> You'd be so sad, wouldn't you? Play your
watch against my base
>> and then the opponent just immediately
th watches you in response
>> has been taken care of before I think by
the right there
>> accelerate my own
>> and you are correct there's the response
thousand tailed watcher with accelerate
that can just charge straight in
>> remove that threat red ones
>> okay thanks no worries
>> there is still the raven bloom student
in base that will have to do a lot of
work. That is going to be over hours for
the studies for the
>> I was about to say that's going to have
to be a Raven Bloom professor to be
honest with you. I don't think this dude
can get this one cut.
>> We're going to see the conquer into the
other battlefield. Leo as well up to
seven.
>> That is presenting lethal with seven
>> with the plundering.
>> Yep.
>> Trying to hold to battlefield. Which
singular card could win
>> or save Dizzy the game? Not even a
singularity. Y the star cross. So for
Bellerine Breath, even better is going
to remove the Raven Bloom Student.
>> He dies. This will be recycled and I'll
return fist to my hand. Mhm. And pass.
>> Wow. So Dia needs to clear off both
battlefields here with no units in play
>> and no cards in hand. One card in two
cards in hand, sorry. But it is just
going to be the concession. Ezreal wins
2. Congratulations.
You find yourself in day two here at the
UT regional [music] championship. And
Leo, what a performance that was.
Look at him all smiling there knowing
this. [laughter]
I have played the Ezreal game of my
lifetime there, knowing full well, hey,
we are no [music]
time pressure actually because you can
just dominate the game so incredibly
hard versus Kaiser taking out those
units. While Kaiser has a more
aggressive approach with a similar play
style.
>> Yeah,
>> Ezreal bounces his own units back. So,
he has absolute control over which units
can stay in play and which can't. And
that really showed in this game, right?
He always was the player who had units
in play or at least in hand. Well, Dizia
was just struggling to get anything on
board. Couldn't even really get points
in a Kaiser deck, which is usually so
aggressive. Closed it out games rather
fast. And I also love this this backline
vex pressure. You know, the deflect
doesn't even matter in this match up
because everyone is chilling at 12 runes
anyways, but just forcing your opponent
to commit so much into certain place and
then bewitching spirit looping that is
it's almost unplayable.
>> I just think we see the difference when
you have Fury versus Chaos. Chaos just
has so many more tricks, you know,
starcross, Fizz, Bewitching Spirit, Pack
of Wonders, and I think the problem is
in that match up it feels Fury just
seems too honest. Like, yeah, I have my
removal, I have my board presence, but
when your opponent can just discard your
hand, remove your threats with Star
Cross, has your own thousand tailed
Watcher as well, what are you meant to
do?
>> I mean, you have Star Cross for a
falling star as well, right? If you're
investing so many runes for a falling
star already and you just bounce your
own unit to save it like a bewitching
spirit or anything that can be played
fast like a fizz and immediately has
impact and you bounce something of
theirs, they lose tempo, they lose a
card as well. You save your cards and
then you're profiting off of that by
such a big margin. And that's eventually
what happened in that game, right? Every
single trade that happened was just a
little bit better for Sarat and he just
ran away with the games after a
very long time.
>> It was We have to really appreciate that
patient play though. You know, had many
turns to do the Baritian Spirit plus Gus
combination was very patient. But then
the second that pack of wonders came
down, it was like and there goes your
hand.
>> I want to say that there's there is
something malicious to this play style.
Yeah. When you're looking at your
opponent, you know,
>> we're both at one point. You know, I'm
in the driving seat. I know I'm in the
driving seat. I have 12 runes open.
Pass.
>> Yeah. But I think that we are going to
pass it now over to our winner of the
last round and Barrett. Over to the
interview
and pass. You absolutely did. But who
didn't pass? But they passed the test.
Serate locking in your day two now 6
and0 on Ezreal. How does it feel knowing
that no matter what what happens after
these next two rounds? We're going to
see you tomorrow.
>> It's exciting. I mean, when I got here,
I did not think I would make it even
though I really, really wanted to. I
mean, it's my first regional qualifier
and to be able to make it day two on my
first attempt, so to speak. Uh, it's
crazy. Uh, it I almost can't believe it
almost.
>> Well, you better believe it cuz it's
happening right now. So, what is also
happening right now is an incredible
match against Kai'Sa, who was I was also
kind of surprised being at this 5-0
level. But, you know, I want to ask you
because a lot of the Kai'Sa decks have
now shifted to be a little more
aggressive, whereas you're playing this
Ezreal deck and especially in that
second game, the sort of like immaculate
amount of control that the deck was
already very good at even even back
when, you know, we were still thinking
of things like miracle decks of course,
but the Bewitching Spirit really
showcased here where it wasn't just
about playing it, getting the discard
out, but we saw how many gusts you saw.
Obviously, Starcross is such an
immaculate card, but that sort of hand
control while also just playing around
your opponent's removal. I can imagine
this is like the perfect matchup you're
looking for.
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, Kaiser can get a
little bit difficult because they're
able to remove from your base. So, you
have to be very careful when you put
down the spirit and if you can afford to
lose it at that moment. But patience is
key. like being able to play it slow,
not feel like you have to put score
points, holding back the Vex as long as
I did, just knowing that I'll be fine. I
win the long game. Uh it's uh it's a
very good matchup for that reason. And
uh yeah.
>> Well, and that's great cuz you are now
definitely telling the story about how
control decks I think are finding a very
quick way back into the format. Maybe,
you know, of course, a top eight might
be a little harder to do, but the story
very much is that these decks that can
take their time, fight against the aggro
decks, just slow down their tempo and
getting these points early really can
matter and function into this
tournament. So, can I ask you just maybe
real quickly, your past matches in the
day today, have they also been against
other aggressive decks or have you had
to win maybe like a control mirror
match?
>> Uh, it's mostly been aggressive. I would
say there was an Aurora matchup which
tends to be a bit slower. Uh but I do
also think that Ezreal has plenty of
tools to deal with and turn to dust to
get rid of the Aurora star cross to get
rid of those big units especially with
Elder Dragon. You can sort of like
counter the uh the play effect. So yeah,
it's mostly been aggressive decks and I
do think that Ezreal has a pretty good
time against those. And maybe what I say
is a bit controversial, but I do think
he only has like one real bad matchup,
which would be into something like uh
Ireelia because of the defies for one,
but also the deflect being a real issue
for uh a spell control deck.
>> Yeah, I mean you both play the Vex
apathetic, but of course the Ireelia
ferance can be really really hard to
deal with sometimes. But regardless of
that, you are being fervent here in this
tournament. You are now 6 and0 on a res
Ezreal moving to day two, but still two
more rounds to go today. So, we're going
to go ahead and send it back to more
action.
>> Thank you for that, Barrett. Yeah, we
are coming in hot and fast for our next
action here. But it's always great to
hear from our winners there. That is
Zerial player being so, you know,
patient, meticulous. Said did have to go
through a few aggro decks, but now he
finds himself for that record to find
himself in day two.
>> I love the fervent punt from Barrett, by
the way.
>> It was Yeah, we have to give attention
to that. Yeah. And that might also be a
shout out to the backup feature match
that we're going to show because Elia
Fervent is definitely going to play a
role in that. It is going to be Urelia
Blade Dancer versus Darius Hand of
Noxus. And I will say of course I know
people at home chat is going to start
rooting for Darius immediately because
of the underdog story
>> for sure.
>> Ireelia also as a as a year-long league
player for me. Yeah, I have loved this
character so much. I'm the biggest
Urelia fan
and I love the play style of the deck
quite frankly. I know it's very strong
and that's why people like other decks
more because it's like the underdog
story, but Urelia has a special place in
my heart. So, I always root for Aurelia.
>> Okay. Interesting because I'm rooting
for Darius. I love this play style where
you really lean into the legion and
that's what your legend power can do.
You can essentially use that as an extra
one where on a legion activation. So,
it's sort of like a very well the polar
opposite in play styles, right? Aelia
loves to just protect that queen, you
know, have her dancing around the field
destroying everything like a wrecking
ball and Darius wants to go wide.
Legion, no hopeful, all of that jazz as
well. Keep an eye on that safety
inspector though.
>> That can
be very very difficult to play against
for Ilia as well. like these token
decks, the decks that can go for so many
pushes, especially with something like
Rally the Troop when you all of a sudden
not only go wide, but also go big, but
there's also not only Grand Strategim, a
one of the blowout cards from Origins
back then that sees a bit of play,
>> but also Baited Hook as an option.
Baited Hook in this deck doesn't want to
find the big super huge drops. I
remember Origins, one of the best cards
you could hit with Baited Hook in Darius
was Draven Showboat.
But now you of course have a spectral
matron card that is going to get back
your vanguard captains and get you even
wider and wider and wider. But there
we're seeing a very nice and cleanless
only one Vexpoa. Wondering if we're
playing more of those in the side deck.
Double Raza. Where is that coming from?
One Fizz Trickle. That is a very very
high utility
deck. That is very interesting. Only one
Starrust. Not so fast in the main deck
as well.
Traveling Merchant.
All right, we're in for a treat. That is
a very different Ireelia list from most
of the list that we're used to. We're
playing a interesting amount of two
drops. We're playing three Merchants.
>> Yeah.
>> And then two two on the Titan and the
Scuttle Grabs. We're having of course
Guardian Angel in case we do not find
this unit two drop. But of course, we're
also going to run Z's Warren I think. So
this is something that you can cycle
through your deck with rather swiftly.
I'm very curious to see how these cards
that are not always being played in
Aelia are going to show off because Raza
is something that is sometimes really
hard to utilize. However, if you're in a
longer and grindier game and you have
used most of these one energy low power
spells like stack deck, like define
dance on guard,
I think the deck can pop off quite big
then.
>> Yeah, I've seen it happen. It can get
out of hand. And I think Aurela is one
of those decks that can get out of hand
ridiculously fast, you know, with the
boots of swiftness signature spell
buffing you to silly amounts of might if
I'm being perfectly honest. So I'm
intrigued to see how Darius of Darius
player I should say will kick us off. I
believe we are going straight into a
game two situation where it looks like
Darius Mice Diamond Hat was able to
swipe that game one there from Aurelia.
So, you know, Aurelia on the back foot.
Rarely finds itself on the back foot
here. Can come back King do his namesake
and come back.
>> And or is Diamond going to put on the
head and win? Yeah, that wasn't as
clear. [laughter]
>> Not as square. I see what you tried to
do, but it looks like here we go. Our
Swiss round six feature match B game two
is getting started there. Combat King Ty
Turner back over to Mo. It looks like we
have what is that? the Tagon's peak
there and Emperor Deas as our
battlefields of choice.
>> Absolutely gorgeous spirit forged Nexus
Knight.
>> Do we have the Noxus hopeful as well
with the Darius Power? We do. The
Legion. That's probably your fantastic
start. You want to see a two drop in
combination with your Noxus Hopeful.
>> Yeah, Legion at one is really, really
strong. I was surprised when the origins
came out that Darius did not see more
play because that is so much
>> tempo even your opponent started with
just a two drop and you played cards for
the energy amount of of their second
turn now. So they're going to go out
with the Stellon Herder and the Titer.
>> Dreamy start especially with a Targon's
peak trigger in end of turn to get to
runes back up. Are we going to save that
tie turner or is the Noxus hopeful going
to take it down?
>> So we are here. He's going to charge in
>> have any response
>> versus two currently
>> high and dance or are we on guarding
stack deck to possibly find a card that
helps us in that situation.
One thing I want to keep an eye on in
this matchup though is that defiant
dance. It's essentially what like a four
swing. If it's used with your champion
unit though, it gets even more.
>> It's a five swing. Yeah,
>> that's five swing.
>> But uh we haven't found that one.
>> Come back king is picking up that gust
now.
>> How much is that going to help in this
match up? You can opt to save your tie
turner,
>> which is something I do not hate because
it is going to draw you extra cards with
the Stella corner her. But we decide not
to save it. not to use that one last
energy there, Stellacon Herder in the
battlefield. Perhaps a little bit more
important to save if anything would
happen. But we're just stopping our
opponent in an aggressive deck from
conquering here. Profiting off of that
Emperor's Deas, even though I don't even
know if you want to emperor's deis back,
your honest broker. I think heavily
depends on what you're doing. And there
is the first power paid. Vanguard
captain. One of the most impactful three
drops. Yeah, we get the recruit or its
ability coming into play as well. And
here's the sort of strength in numbers
as it were. The Darius deck, the
complete opposite to an Aurelia.
>> Speaking of which is over to Aurelia
now.
>> Honestly, Vanguard captain is quantity
and quality.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> And there is already a defined dance.
Come back. King just deciding earlier
that he does not want to use this on a
tie turner.
>> Tempo isn't that important. You got to
protect your queen in which case in this
case it's telecon herder.
>> Yeah, it's interesting. You got sort of
two massive standout units here for the
deck. You obviously have the Aurelia for
for I can't pronounce that, but a
champion unit I should say that's going
to come up and just wreck ball, but then
you also have the Stellorn Herder who
draws you cards every time it move moves
which now has ganking due to those boots
of swiftness.
>> And we have readied it after attaching
the boots of swiftness to it that DMs us
for quite a bit. But I think we have the
discipline also in
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> hand because otherwise this is Oh, no.
It's a four to four five to four trade.
Of course, this is a very very clean
trade here for the combat king with
other protection spells in hand. Oh,
that is actually looking quite clean in
hand.
>> Yeah, I think. Yeah, there's nothing we
can do there if we're mice diamond
hatch. Have to let that one go through.
Getting points on the board of your
Stellicorn Herd. Remember, it draws
every time it moves.
>> Fantastic for your card economy. and
wants to be as efficient as possible
with the Taran's peak trigger. So,
decides to develop one more unit into
base to get to runes ready instead of
ending on four. Falling behind on runes
quite heavily is something that Aurelia
does a lot versus especially aggressive
strategies,
>> but you kind of have to do that. If
you're just sitting there and waiting,
you are going to get taken out rather
fast.
>> Shinjzho is now being played readied, of
course, because you have two or more
units in your base. And to be fair, that
is a stacked looking base there. Leo, if
you're marked, you can just go charging
into that Tagon's Peak if you like.
Three other cards in the hand option not
to play anything of yet. We do have the
Legion power of course from our Daryus
since you know Le was played of course.
The thing is, if your opponent is three
runes up, hasn't developed too much yet,
>> and played a ST deck before,
>> the chances of you getting massively hit
by these combat tricks, it's quite big.
I mean, that's a big Stellon herder to
begin with.
>> It is.
>> If you throw everything into that
Tagon's peak,
>> surely something surviving though,
right? I mean, sure, free runes are
open, but you can't. We're eyeing up
free units here. The recruits are they
joining the Noxus charge as it were.
Here we go. Three, four units slamming
in. What has Combat King got to defend
that onslaught? Currently 10 to five.
Stellicorn Herder versus the Noxious
Army from Darius.
You see signature spell
>> and I see a discipline
>> that is already countering the 10 to
five.
>> Yeah, I was about to say that gets you
there. Okay, fair enough.
That gets you to 9 versus eight.
>> But then you're also completely
exhausted on your runes. Now coming
needs to take a big think for sure cuz
pity would pass back over. Might have
some extra tricks up his sleeve as well.
>> Discipline.
>> There's a discipline.
>> That's going to be plus two draw one.
>> Does that Darius deck play any other
combat tricks? You could have something
like an inferno.
>> That would absolutely do the trick.
>> Plus,
>> maybe a hidden blade.
>> It's going to be 10 vers. But I think
that is going to be all she wrote there
for that showdown. Mice Diamond Hack
clears away that Stellicorn Herder.
Boots of SWness returns to the base of
course, but we can obviously charge in
our recruit there. And we can obviously
pay one if we like
>> to get that sand soldier a little bit
extra if you so desire.
>> Oh, actual matron paying a lot of power
here to get that captain back in. It was
the plan all along to just sack it there
and replay it. Basically, all the units
that were lost are being built up again.
Just lost no power. just exha
>> the matron
>> now combat king
>> he doesn't have a stellicon her anymore
that was a big big swing and if you want
to develop your now if you want to have
a powerful unit to combat all of these
stats on the side of mice diamond head
>> you are very late to the party you have
to basically completely tap out here and
give your opponent almost
>> a full hold or sack your traveling
merchant
>> discard scrap
>> okay Okay,
>> traveling merchant coming down. We do
get the ability of course discard one
draw one priority passed two runes open
>> that is just going to go through though
>> sneaky little conquer
and coming is sitting on I think already
two defies in hand that is something
that makes you usually feel really
really safe about scenarios however
against this deck
>> what are you really defying falling star
you can't defying inferna you really
can't defy as well grand strategim you
cannot defy hidden blade and rally the
troops are targets for you. Do you want
to defy those? Questionable.
>> You kind of have to if you have it.
>> Yeah, it needs must when you are in a
win or go home situation as it were. Two
runes being used here. Scuttle crab draw
one. Don't mind it.
>> That is a Raza and Raza would already
only cost four energy and a power.
However, I would say that a Vex sounds a
little bit better so that next turn you
have more axis.
>> Oh, I like this. We are racing for
points again. Two power is being used.
Get that merchant ready. Merchant on
four might versus the three might on
Taragon's peak.
>> You could play that Vex afterwards into
your base and of course also still have
two runes up
>> trigger.
>> Actually, I think com is really
>> looking good in this comeback here.
However,
>> resource wise, yeah, we're getting rid
of the first realizing that is nothing
we can capitalize on. Okay, so the
traveling merchant with a little bit of
might here. Currently on the four versus
three at this showdown. And I think
you're right. Yeah, no other modifiers
for mice diamond hat. The traveling
merchant doing everything he can.
Obviously Tagon Pete will activate here
as well.
>> Going to ready up two runes for combat
king. Could the comeback be on? That was
a great turn there. The boots of
swiftness quite honestly so versatile
>> expert a lot of might from gear trades
super well into these token decks into
these might heavy decks because you can
just use it again and again and again.
>> This card has given so much value to
come backing already and Vex now
developed in base. We see this
>> multiple times now already that players
don't play Vex into the battlefield just
because then it's it's so vulnerable
already and in this scenario, let's be
honest, you are not too afraid of
something accelerating or something
being ambushed. Traveling Merchants's
kind of already dead on board.
>> Yeah, the Vex Apathetic is rather safe.
Remember, it does have that deflect cost
as well. So, people going to try and
target with something like a falling
star would have to pay that additional
cost. And Mice hasn't actually got too
many runes developed. Currently at five.
Does have a decent board presence
though. Of course. Hasn't found a seal
of unity.
>> No.
>> Something too.
>> Oh, here we go.
>> Go for six.
>> Oh, wow. Okay. Are we That does smell
like a bait somehow. This smells fishy.
>> They're throwing so many units in there.
I mean, it plays around a discipline.
So, if your opponent has two runes up,
that does work quite well. If you just
push in a form might unit that is tough
but you're going to
>> defant dance
>> put a lot of work in with this defiant
dance that is actually a blow out for
three units.
>> Yeah the defiance dance coming in close
that signature spell death for a give
one of your well give a unit plus two
and another unit minus two. So M's hat,
>> I mean my diamond hat is just going to
have to forgo that battlefield and
charge into the other one.
>> Points currently looking rather, you
know, rather good. Four versus five.
>> We are going to get the
>> Emperor Deis activation.
>> Going to give us a Soldier, but come
back King is kind of running away with
this game so far. Yeah,
>> now has to play the in oh dreger from
hand. But of course you have Darius as
legion ability. So you can with the
power from the gold token play the
vanguard captain of course after playing
the dredger
>> developing a lot in base as well. But
that is going to be a whole point to
six. That can be a ganking to seven and
then we're already looking pretty clean.
>> Yeah, this is looking like a rather
great scenario for combat king doing his
namesake here. was on the ropes a little
bit at the start of the game, but has
stabilized rather well. That traveling
merchant of all things becoming the
wrecking ball and we have a lot more
cards to play here. Vex apathetic and a
scuttle crab currently. I mean, you
could obviously charge in your scuttle
crab to get hand knowledge. I guess
actually with most diamond hat tapped
out as it were, you've got free rain.
>> I think throwing down the scuttle crab
doesn't even sound too bad just so you
know what you can play around later on.
thinking here move trigger
>> does decide to go for that traveling
merchant though and that one is going to
be huge because it discards another card
and as you might have seen already there
is the Raza in hand so I think the
synergy between traveling merchant and
Raza is what makes it so strong here as
well because you
>> now it only costs one energy one power
for a six might unit you have a vex
developed yes there is a lot of units in
the base of mice diamond head
there is an argument to be made that
you're trying to stack everything in
that Emperor's D, but I I don't think
you need to do that versus Darius.
Darius is not a holding deck. I think if
you develop a bunch of units in your
base, you're more than good to go to win
in the next turn with a dumpling
conquer, especially since you're playing
and more especially since you have the
boots of swiftness already developed on
board.
>> Yeah, I think that you definitely eye up
that Resza there, the Raza, I should
say. Oh, we are going to send Vex in
first and we could obviously play the
Raza to the battlefield. I'd like that
idea. Oh, looks like we are going to
counting up the trash. Here we go.
>> You've been talking about this. You've
been eyeing it up. That Raza comes in
one less for each card in your trash.
There it is. That is a big hefty six
might unit now on that battlefield.
>> Big guy Raza.
>> We still got Vex in hand as well. Wow,
we have so many runes open as well.
>> I find the fizz so funny in this deck as
well because you can not only of course
go for this broken interaction of fizz
star cross bounce fizz.
>> Y
>> but you can also aggressively when you
want to break a hold from your opponent.
>> Yeah,
>> you just go yo fizz defiant dance my
trash and then I get plus five on my
irrelia versus your unit that I'm
targeting. So
>> thank you.
>> That is Oh wow, are we picking up the
grand strategim? That would actually
indeed thank you production be a really
really good pickup that can break a
board like this.
>> Everything basically.
>> Wow.
>> Six energy three power is going to give
a total of 20 extra might this turn.
However, leaves your options afterwards.
>> It really does. It's sort of like an all
or nothing play here. Everything's got
plus five. That is a ridiculous amount
of might. Those recruits feel like
they've been promoted to captain or
commanders now. Six might each. Are we
going to go charging in? The only thing
you have to worry about here. Come back
king. Four runes open. You're not to
know what those three cards are, but
you're right. They could be some scary
cards there.
>> But right now, this is everything M
Diamond needs to do. Needs to clear off
both of these battlefields, might I say,
to have a chance in this game to feature
match here.
That is the craziest thing about this
calm and chaos decks, right? There's
four runes open. What do you have to
play around? You have to play around
rebuke, star cross.
>> Y
>> not so fast in this deck. Probably not a
right the wind can also be critical if
you overcommit into one battlefield.
Then of course also
>> something like defiant dance or on guard
or discipline.
>> Okay, here we go. Sorry Leo. We're
charging in six to four right now. That
traveling merchant has been so impactful
and so economical.
Currently staring down
>> thinking
>> a scary showdown.
Come back king thinking. What are his
options?
>> Does the merchant have to put the fries
in the bag and go to trash?
>> I I don't see a way in how I mean having
a chance to consult combat king's hand
but I don't think there's a way of
getting out of this. Was there a star
cost in hand? Actually,
>> I [clears throat] think so. Yeah,
>> it might be. But I feel that's just
delaying the inevitable though.
>> The results. Okay.
>> Nope. The showdown is going to go
through. The traveling merchant that
done everything it can to keep Combat
King in this game has been sent to the
trash. And now it's only a matter of
time. Here we go. Triple Showdown.
Currently 20 thanks to that grand
strategem versus 10.
That grand strategy really caught combat
king offguard.
Really unsure if there was ever a
possibility in which the Vex Raza board
could have been broken, but Grand
Strategy really does the job. And now
all of a sudden, if Diamond Head goes to
six, really, really big swing of
momentum because you have, of course,
the way to accelerate so many different
cards. However, scuttter crab, not the
mightiest of units.
>> Play your Urelia, you're down to one
rune already.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you play that, you accelerate it
by putting the BS of swiftness on it,
you conquer, and then you have to make
your Aurelia legend ready again by
exhausting the last rune. And then you
can't play anything that targets the
Aurelia anymore.
>> So that is rather tough.
>> And it is just going to take out the
Vanguard captain. Wow, what a turn for
comebacking. Did have a star cross in
hand. Opted not to play it. And the turn
isn't over. Wow, we even get the dreg
carrier up on that battlefield and all
of a sudden, what a swing of pendulum of
power that is. It's like a metronome
this game, isn't it? Mice favored,
combat king favored. Back over to Mice.
What can combat king do?
>> Honestly, I think Combat King, he's very
much fine in this scenario because
there's just too might in any
battlefield. Scuttle crab actually does
something here. Scuttle crab can put on
some boots.
>> Yeah, it can. Here we go. I love this.
The offensive crab. Is that what we're
going to see?
>> Fizz first. Or what are we define? St.
>> Is Fizz going to discipline our scuttle
crab? Oh my goodness.
>> Well, we're going to see a disciplined
boots of swiftness scuffle crab.
>> We're going to Are we going to see
scuttle crab for a game? That would be
absolutely phenomenal.
>> Scuttle crab for game. That is as
certain as I don't think I would ever
say but we are muttering it here.
Discipline looks like being up there off
the Fizz.
>> It does depend
if he has another card to target that.
Oh, targets the Fizz and readies it of
course with its own effect that is super
strong.
>> Fizz basically being able to accelerate
itself. That is very very nice.
>> Oh yeah, that is an interesting
interaction.
So now Fizz is what plus two,
five.
>> Fizz alone holds game here by crashing
into one of the battlefields and then
getting these boots of swiftness
attached, paying one more than
getting the swiftness on it, ready it
up, and then gank over. If there is not
an answer on the side of Mice Diamond
Head, something like a not even a hidden
blade because you're all into fury runes
right now. conquers puts up the
exhausted energy
for that Ireelia.
>> I think you're right. I think that could
be it. Boots of swiftness have been
equipped. Fiz can just charge on over.
No response from most diamond. And come
back king does his namesake and evens it
up here. Go into a game three situation.
And what a game that was there. I cannot
understate just how much it looked like
Combat King was on the back foot. was
able to weather the storm against Anox's
army and now we're shuffling up through
a game three.
>> What a cool utilization of pizz tricks
in an Aurelia deck. That's not it's by
far not a standard card in the Aurelia
deck, but it looked so good here. It can
accelerate itself. Never even thought
about that. That is so so strong,
especially when it gets disciplined.
Plus five might could also work with
something like a defined dance. But then
that is one of the issues with those
aggressive decks like Rexi, like Darius,
especially in the fury and order
domains.
>> Really is. We saw it all. Normally
>> no defenses.
>> Normally with Aurelia, you think if
Aurelia is not out, I'm all right. But
we saw, you know, we saw the traveling
merchant.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we saw at the end the fears.
But I think we are going to actually
have to join this game three with five
minutes to go due to time constraints.
Let's have a look. It looks like most
diamond out is currently in the driver's
seat at six points to come back kings
three. What do we see? A Darius on the
battlefield there. And we see a Noxus
Hope, but it is Combat King's turn. And
we are going to see it looks like that
Darius getting sent straight to the
trash. My diamond hat is a player that
has play paid a lot of power in this
game with double seal on there and still
only being at six runes.
>> But so is the comeback king. We are in a
arena's gracious game.
This looks like it could be a similar to
game two where we see the Aurelia
champion hasn't been developed and we
see the boots of swiftness. That tells
me that something has been equipped with
those boots and has been traveling
around the board. Might have actually
been a scuttle grab. That was the only
unit I could swiftly spot in that trash.
But
>> Elia doesn't always necessarily need to
develop Aelia F. It's an incredible
card, but against those token decks that
put on some might, but not like
incredible amounts of might where you
don't need to push through the biggest
>> battlefields like versus a Vex deck for
example, then you're very much fine with
just playing your Stellacon Herder or
your small units or a Vex and then
pushing because five energy is quite a
lot. Now combat king passed on this
Stellon Herder. Two seals are tapped for
the spectral matron is going to enable
every single Legion trigger that you
want. So that could be a big big power
play to redevelop your board.
>> One thing I want to draw attention to in
a game three there is that Aurelia has
access that abandoned hall. We know how
ridiculous that can get.
>> How ridiculous can it get though? First
of all, in the next turn, there is no
unit developed for coming. He is only
going to be at five runes. He can gang
into the arena's greatest, but you
cannot leave open two battlefields.
There is going to be that one conquer
point. So, we're going up to seven. That
enables us a possible draw on the next
turn when we're conquering again.
>> Oh my days,
>> there is the safety inspector. Not
feeling as safe if you are come back
king. That is going to force coming to
get rid of that stellar cone herder. And
when you're threatening game next turn
and your opponent has count them zero
units in play, you have to be feeling
confident in a game free situation. Come
back king thinking about his options. I
don't think there's many that Stella
Herder is going to be getting sent in
the trash.
>> It would have been even cooler if he had
a defian hand because that cannot be
defied. Come back king now thinking
through his options. Are there any? No.
Has to put away
>> the hurdle. And I think that right there
could be the game deciding turn.
Look at all those units in play. Leo
threatening game. Combat king needs to
clear off that arena's greatest.
Currently has a noxious Noxus hopeful
and the safety inspector. I tell you
what, if I employed him as my safety
inspector, I'd be a bit questioning if
he bother. You're not causing safety,
you're causing carnage, killing units is
over to combat king though. What can he
do?
>> Five runes is very, very limited option
for the deck. What you can do is play
the irrelia. You can attach the boots of
swiftness to it. That is plus two might.
You're going to ready this and you're
going to choose it. So, you're going to
get two extra might. So, you can push
yourself up to eight with just the boots
of swiftness. Therefore, also a
interesting decision to play the safety
inspector into the arena's greatest, but
yeah, already putting them away because
complex. Okay. No. Yeah, he's offering
it. He's like, "Hey, you want to you
want to go in there, but you know your
opponent is completely exhausted. Three
runes left, but they're turned sideways.
You are going up to eight. You already
have so much might on that battlefield.
Isn't that just game on board if there's
I mean, you can still always hide cards.
We can, but I think you're right. This
does seem
>> rather a strong situation.
>> Elia at six. The recruit goes into the
abandoned hall and then the others go
into that Urelia. But of course, if
there is a card hidden from combat king,
even if it is just a bluff like that
doesn't really do too much.
>> People might start spiraling and giving
up another turn. Let's see. Was that the
secret win condition? True.
>> We could even just see something like
that grand strategium again just to say
right I don't care what that is I'm
charging everything in but we going to
see recruit charging into abandoned hall
>> because I'm seven
>> get draw more information more cards to
push through coming in
>> here we go anything else for moist to
just push into that other battlefield.
Here we go.
It's going to be the switch room, but
that's all we wrote. And Mice pulling
out the game three advancing to day two
with the Darius deck against [music] the
big bad scary Aurelia of the format. The
difference in play styles. Strength in
numbers versus the lone wolf. And this
time the the strength in numbers. Darius
will win.
Mice Diamond that clutching it out there
with the aggressive Dario strategy 6 on
his best way to get this best of legend.
This origin legend the last time in
Europe that you're going to have the
chance to actually get your hands on
those. So huge huge win for Mice Diamond
Head. Also really really well played. Of
course, we cannot say anything about the
other 20 minutes of the last game there,
but it was really nice that we got the
option to still see how that match
played out because game two that was
absolutely phenomenal. The way that
comeback king actually found the
comeback and got back into this game
with the Fizz Trickstar that is going to
do wonders in that deck.
>> Yeah, I think you really did see some uh
what's the word I'm looking for here?
Reactive play there from Comeback King.
think okay I haven't really got a lot to
work with here but this boots of
swiftness let me start maneuvering
around and take us to a game three but I
am glad we got to see the conclusion of
game three there and I must say I am a
Darius fan so I'm glad to see that doing
well especially when it's our last
chance to get that best of legend but
while we prepare our next round for you
guys we're going to have a quick break
but don't go anywhere cuz that's round
seven coming at you real
Allan's first rendevous with
league-based card games was in Legends
of Rune Terra. His commitment to become
the best in the world paid off when in
2021 he won the inaugural Legends of
Rune Terra World Championship. Four
years later, Allan makes his debut in
regional qualifier Houston, ready to
show the world he still got it. I mean,
there were not believers in my version,
but it's been proving and proving back
and back, running undefeated in
scrimmage back here. Yesterday, being
undefeated again.
>> Allan not only makes it to day two, but
pushes eventual champion Dewali to his
limit in their top eight match, narrowly
losing out in game number three.
Regardless, Allan secures himself a top
eight finish and the best of Kai'Sa, a
feat that for many would be their
crowning achievement. But not two months
later, the beast from the east shows his
true colors as a flourishing partnership
between Allan and Ezreal starts. Allan's
loyalty [music] to the legend he knows
better than anyone else pays off as he
steamrolls the opposition at Bolognia,
starting not only the longest [music]
winning streak in competitive rebound
ever witnessed, he also becomes the
first undefeated regional qualifier
[music]
champion. Allan ZQ. [cheering]
>> 24 official matches in a row. Allan goes
undefeated. In Las Vegas, he secures
another top eight. A result that he
mirrors in Atlanta where he claims his
third best of Ezreal. The dedication is
unmatched as are the results. But Allan
wants more.
unleashed releases and with it Allan
creates a new deck. Staying true to the
chaos and mind domain, he runs a
spell-heavy Diana list that rivals the
consistency of his earlier Ezreal and
secures him yet another top eight in
Sydney. Having found his footing on the
lunar legend from Unleashed, Vancouver
is ripe for the taking until a familiar
foe rears his face in the top [music]
four.
Dwali is once again in the way of
victory. This time around, Alan's EQ
gets his [music] revenge for Houston. In
game three, he outpaces Dwali and finds
himself standing in the finals, closer
to a second title than anyone ever
before.
Or is he? Because in the final, awaiting
Allan is no one else than the final boss
from Vegas, Sam D. Sherman, also on the
hunt for his second trophy.
Two titans clash and Alan ZQ's dreams
are hanging on by a thread as the pride
stalker strikes first and takes game
one. Game two has Sam two points away
from greatness, but Alan Ziko gets to it
first, equaling the score. Game number
three is a statement. The best Diana in
Vancouver ramped up through the entirety
[music]
of the finals match. Alan ZQ rises above
rivals, charges past champions, and
becomes the first twotime regional
qualifier champion. Matej Yajinski Alan
ZQ a 100% day2 conversion rate six top
eight appearances five best of medal
cards two regional qualifier trophies
Welcome back to day one here of our Q
[music] Utre. We're getting ready to go
into round seven. And what a profile
piece on Allen. Undoubtedly, I think in
many people's minds, the top player
right now in the West here for
Riftbound. I think Allan himself says
other players are better, but I think
that might just be a little bit of
humility as as a true champion should.
>> Yes. Yes. [laughter] Uh, and believe me
when I say the script writers have been
at it for this round. Uh, James and
Bandit here to take you through round
seven. We have unsurprisingly Allan uh,
on stage. And those of you that joined
us earlier saw an interview that Bandit
did with one of the big names in the
Polish community on the the community
building side.
>> Very, very true. So um so for for lack
of a better term consider this the the
the front man of the Polish delegation
leading the the the travel outward from
Poland to the RQs. He is at the
forefront. He is cheering everywhere he
goes. He is undefeated and now has to
face his countryman his brethren Alan
Zik.
>> He gets drawn against Allen. Uh, so two
Polish players that have traveled here
together as a part of the the the I'm
sure the Polish contingent as soon as I
heard that now in the venue are going to
be over in the the viewing area as well.
Uh, and that also means um we I'm sure
in chat when I pull out my phone for
like the I never do it on broadcast. I
never have my phone on me on broadcast,
but I'm like I know that chat is just
going to be like Paul Gurrom the entire
time
>> as they should.
>> As they should. You can see
>> they uh they know each other incredibly
well. I I imagine they have played
against each other quite a lot. This is
the first time that we're seeing it in a
high-profile matchup.
>> This is I mean this is for some serious
marbles right here, right? Yes, we we
they both been on undefeated runs. I
will tell you uh from the pre-regional,
Silvin had didn't do very well. He he
struggled yet he's staying committed and
he's proving that tides can turn
undefeated today. Looking to stay it
still, but that is a tall order. Yeah, I
mean there's struggling in the
pre-regional is fine if you come out
from like the the training chamber,
right?
>> It's a general repetition. You make all
the mistakes there. Get them out of the
way. Come out the gate, swing in on day
one of the main event.
>> I mean, the facts speak for it for
themselves.
>> Yeah, they do. As uh you know, this is
going to give us some other uh things to
talk about from that as I can confirm
the chat are indeed following suit and
giving us the the love for appreciate
it. Um, so this is also going to allow
us to to talk about something as
somewhat of a less uh uh celebratory
thing where we were talking about like
Mari and how that goes against Diana.
Now I will spoil it. This is a Diana
Mari matchup and we've talked about how
Mari has a lot of presence today and I
put forward that I think that Master
does start to struggle when you have a
little bit of this complex matchup on
top of it. Silven is running Master Y.
Uh this is the variant that does not run
uh Trinity Force. That's one of the
changes in it. So I wonder how Silvin
will fare up against the Diana player,
which is already quite a struggle
regular like in a in a regular matchup
now against one of the best out there.
He has his work cut out for him. We were
talking about it earlier. And the way
Matri gets so such consistent results
over and over again is they sacrifice a
bit of their own agency to present
obstacles and problems for their
opponent. They'll get situated on the
battlefield and like, "All right, solve
this. If you cannot solve it, I'm going
to win." Well, if there's one player
that solves board states, Allan on Diana
and and previously Ezreal before it, as
we saw in that uh retrospective piece,
uh great at finding just those threads
of saying, "Okay, this is how I undo
your entire board state." And you can
see with Diana, there's quite a few ways
to do it, whether it's through like the
damage from like Eclipse and a few other
things. You've got the the reduction in
might that comes from stupify and and
and smokec screen, or you've got just
pure bouncing. I mean, of course,
Moonfall is always there to move things,
bounce it around, reduce the might.
>> A a a very interesting aspect to
highlight on this one is the fact that
previously as well, I mean, just look at
the camaraderie that is shared on
screen. Even though this is as serious
as it gets, we should never forget the
connection we have with the person in
front of us.
>> Now, it is important to know both of
these players have locked day two. So,
while it is not on the line for them of
making stays at 100,
>> this goes back to what we talk about
with regards to like you can't win the
tournament today, but you can definitely
hurt your chances of making top eight
and potentially lose the tournament
today. a loss here basically puts one
life down and you're like I have to now
win out in order to try and make
[laughter]
>> Allan laughing at the fact his opponent
played nothing turn one. Uh I it's funny
but at the same time if that's
>> we we we laugh the pain away. Exactly.
>> Appreciate it.
>> Exactly. [laughter]
Whoopsie.
>> How do you cut the deck?
>> Yes, of course. [laughter]
>> And that that's one of the reasons why
you cut your opponent's deck, just in
case they have no units when you finish
cutting it.
>> It makes a lot of sense when you are
when you are playing for those top
spots. You need to bring the highest
cope you can get. So [laughter]
only the only the highest grade cope and
and not taking accountability will do. I
will accept nothing less.
He always has the turn two play though.
That's at least there in the tank. You
always can just play that from the
chosen champion zone and move on. Um
we've talked about how important it is
for Ye to establish themselves a lot
today. Uh Diana on the other side has
this not slow early game, but like
certainly the deck doesn't power up
until Hay is there, right? It's like
Diana has a lot of tricks to pull out in
the early game.
>> I here's the thing with the
reintroduction of Kha'Zix. Yes, we're
bumping up the curve a little bit, but
Diana really th like
>> putting down early tempo for for Diana
is a hallmark for that's why she can can
afford to to have those more costly
turns in the mid game that are fully
devoted to either Aay or Aay and the
play.
>> Okay. Yeah, that's a very fair way of
looking at it and and I guess
>> in comparison to like the Ezreal for
instance which was way more timid or an
Aurora which is way more timid in the
early game
>> maybe in that regard. Um, the way I
structure it at first is a way of
looking at it of like actually the deck
kicks into another gear when Hi is out
and kicks into another doineering
pattern where where you go forward. And
that's something that I wonder whether
Silven's going to be able to kind of
bounce back into uh Ruin Runner
potentially scuppers a little bit of the
plan with some of the bounce aspects
from Diana, but
>> we'll see exactly how it ends up panning
out. that is going to be the the ruin
runner going on.
>> And and this is the reason why I think
it's very fair to say that as Yecks get
exposed to tougher and tougher
competition, the cracks start to show
because a Diana deck, which already has
a lot of options available to it, is
actually geared really well into a ruin
runner. Yeah, you can't target it, but
you know what? It can target that
battlefield. Give it the minus two
regardless. pull something else in, deny
you the legend from Asi and with a Hay
to come over the top. The might is there
with a Kha'Zix ready to go. The might is
there. He will still get that plus two
extra might.
>> Yeah, and that's fair with I mean it's
scary to think there's double Moonfall
in hand as well from Allan. So, always
options available. Um, you can see
there's a lot of utility. That's kind of
the thing talking about the puzzle of
how you put forward uh you know a board
state that your opponent has to figure
out. I feel like Diana perhaps has the
widest pool of tools of most decks right
now. I think there's just like so many
ways to deal with what your opponent is
presenting. Yes.
>> And
>> what makes it so scarily consistent
>> with the quay
>> with all the stack decks, you get to see
any cards,
>> which means you can have a two up in
your deck and consistently see that
pretty much every game.
>> Yeah. And we uh did see Allan's deck
list having a number of two ups, having
a number of uh different balances of
cards.
Awaken channel
>> draw.
>> Okay.
>> And hit the ACD.
>> Go AC again. [laughter]
>> Mhm.
>> ACD. See the top of your deck.
>> I see what you did there.
>> And now that
>> it's a good job there was no hold in the
beginning, otherwise that would have
gone.
>> I I think to put the the two ups, one of
and and three of kind of in perspective,
compare it to a Rengarist, right? Runs
primarily three ups. Sure.
>> Just draws inherently less cards. So you
have to be more onto the rails. You need
to invest more to see the same results
over and over again. Meanwhile, Diana
doesn't suffer from similar fates.
That's very fast. Quay has been
developed. And the noteworthy thing here
is
>> charm.
>> Diana is finally kept out.
>> Huay to seat of power.
>> Charm to seat of power. So giving a
draw.
>> Discard plus three. Mhm.
Top five recycle one orange play ring
here.
>> Mhm.
>> Surprise defender. Rengar.
>> So that will go up to seven.
>> Scratch that.
>> Up to nine.
>> Jinky.
>> Uh draw from discipline.
>> Allan has no
out.
>> Yeah. Has no runes available. So we'll
be able to deal with that.
>> Trigger of power. This is the
vulnerability that we talked about.
Similar to an Aurelia deck, those turns
where you fully invest into your Quay,
that is the opportunity you have to
strike.
>> Silven takes full advantage of it. And
if you need if you want any shot making
it through, that is the round you want
to go. Now, the charm on top as well
takes out another unit. So again, that
was a lot expended.
>> Mhm.
You talked about the only real hidden
card is going to be the Zas, but that is
difficult enough to to break as uh Yep.
Rengar will go back.
>> Still got to chew through it whether you
know it's there or not.
>> Yeah, exactly. You still have to be able
to deal with it. And that's one of the
other things is, you know, even if you
bounce it, they're still going to play
the Zas and it just goes back to, you
know, just a gear at that point. It
doesn't matter once it's there, once the
turn is passed, then you're fine. You
you you're able to just cast it whenever
you want.
Now you you need to take a step back
here as Alan ZQ. You took a tremendous
blow and one of the worst moves forward
right now is to step out too early. You
have time. Ye is still catching up.
They're on two. They'll go to four worst
case.
>> There is time for you to rebuild.
a
advance right now would carry so much
risk. The other side of the coin in this
regard is now it is ye who is out.
>> Yes, the results
>> got to be mindful of the outs here and
we are going to launch our first assault
that has to scream Moonfall.
As you said, you can target the
battlefield. So, Ruin Runner not as
protected as you might imagine. There is
the moonfall.
>> Moonfall Rengar
>> can bring the Rengar in
>> response to Moonfall. Reveal Za.
>> Mhm. Resolves.
>> Has to do that for the timing. So Za is
actually is playable. Don't want to lose
the hidden card. Nope.
>> Moonfall. Yes.
>> Oh, the double moon
>> back to back. We talked about this
earlier. Moonfall into Moonfall is
backbreaking. It's like, hey, Thousand
Tail Watch is good. Now imagine
>> unacceptable losses. Insult to injury as
in a t in a turn that could have been
all about rebuilding comes about
demolishing
his friend.
>> Hey uh so when we said that he might not
need to go too quick.
>> Yeah.
>> Clearly he's not going too quick.
>> Turns out double moonfalling to kill
your zas is exactly how you play out of
this situation.
In one fell swoop,
>> Allan is in full control of the game
once more.
>> And [laughter] it is the Y that has to
claw his way back onto the battlefield.
>> Lonely Porsk
for free.
>> First mate.
>> Mhm.
And for two
I will play challenge. First mate on the
other.
>> Should I?
>> Yeah. Nice. Nice. [laughter]
>> Alan's like, "H, I wasn't expecting full
trade."
>> Score.
>> Yeah. Anything else?
>> Pass the turn.
>> So, we're basically back to a situation
where no one has anything at this point.
>> I mistakenly took the rune, but I knew
what's the rune on the board.
>> I'm still scared to talk about
rebuilding because it went so poorly for
me last time.
>> [laughter]
>> You know what? Sometimes you just have
to trust that Allan's got the best line
>> four.
>> And when we predict it's just like, oh
no, actually Allan's line. Sure.
Totally. Totally. That's a better
>> five.
>> Yes. Uh draw
>> 42 play to the base.
>> Mhm.
And for two lonely part of the base
only of them.
>> No, they are not so lonely. They look
together the
>> nice.
>> Now it [snorts] seems friendly.
>> It reeks hidden here.
>> It reeks of Rengar. [laughter]
There's uh something hidden a little bit
behind that. Although that is uh Oh,
because of course um I think five energy
uh that is
>> ready to go on the side of Silven.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think it is interesting to bring
up the new battlefield selection
>> for Diana Rockfell path.
I I wonder how heavily influenced that
is by his uh his meeting in the
Vancouver finals with a certain cap.
>> How much that uh change things so that
you you you're saying, "Okay, well, you
can't Rengar here."
>> Exactly. And you you saw how much effort
it took for Silven to play around that
charming to the other battlefield in
which he could Rengar.
>> Am I am I blind? Cuz I am, but am I
blind? Can I not count? Isn't that four
runes?
One.
So, there should be no Rengar thread
there. If I'm blind, it's my fault. I
will I will hold my hands up and say
that, but I'm counting four. Uh
>> four is the one that comes uh after
five. [laughter]
>> I I think you're right. I think you're
right. I think I I
>> That's okay. Uh it's, you know, we've
had We're stuck in Jin mode still, so
everything's a four uh at this point. Um
after some fun games dice trigger death.
>> Yeah.
>> Draw a card.
>> Go to six.
>> And now we're getting in a scary state
where you can move all the way up to
seven as Allan and [laughter]
>> I'll take that hero of presenting the
problem. I'm going to hold either one of
them. What do you still have left in the
tank?
>> Push back on me.
>> Awaken. And the difficulty now is with
Vex at one battlefield and the other
battlefield being Rockfall Path, you're
like, well, any Rengars are kind of
turned off for this turn because they
would get stunned. So, you have to fight
this Vex with just the two lonely parros
that you have available plus then pump
spells plus anything that can augment
and help.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, of all the cards to draw though,
>> that will definitely
>> if you're going to get one,
>> that will definitely be fueling the
fires of war.
>> Now,
>> taking care of the Vex first will open
up more options later on.
>> How much is it going to cost? There's a
hard bargain in hand. Does Allan care?
>> I feel like you have to make it as tough
as possible. It will let it resolve.
clips.
>> So, minus four.
>> So, plus one.
>> Will not commit the hard bargain just
yet, but will definitely be driving up
the price of this little adventure that
Silven has set out upon.
>> Of course, Eclipse is giving minus four.
>> Yeah. And paying a single energy and two
power for a single extra might. I'm not
a economist or anything.
>> Nice.
>> Has inflation gotten that bad? Uh it
seems like it as the lonely power will
end up dropping and draw a card. And
yeah, that is game one going over to
Alan ZQ. That Moonfall turn, double
Moonfall was backbreaking and it came
out of nowhere, right? This is the the
eb and flow that you can witness him
riftbound and which Allen's EQ uses to
his advantage optimally by all right, I
took a major blow myself, but has it
left my opponent overextended? Yes, it
has. I can punish that.
Commit to it. Break the back. Even if
that results in sadly right now some
friendly fire. Yeah. At this point. But
it it you know there's there's friends
but not real friends in a in a
tournament setting. You know the uh not
going to be taking it easy when you
still got your tournament life on the
line. Um, I think you know that
situation around Ruin Runner and Rengar
being pulled in with the the double
Moonfall speaks to just again how good
Diana's options are. It's like Ruin
Runner is normally a tricky card for
most decks to play around. Normally it's
it's a sticky unit that that you cannot
deal with unless you're not targeting it
but have like kind of collateral damage
effects. And Moonfall's just a great
example of that of like, hey, actually I
target the battlefield. So if Ruin
Runner is on that battlefield, it's
vulnerable anywhere else and it's it's
okay. But you know,
>> you you you're not pulling it back and
forth. That is simply not happening. But
what good is a ruin runner that's not
sitting on a battlefield?
>> Yeah, exactly. You you want it to be in
that situation.
>> Other side of the coin, like I'm not
sure how philosophical you want to get,
but there have been people who say that
a ball is most useful when it is empty.
>> Huh. and a a a ruin runner in base. Is
is that an empty ball ready to strike at
a moment's notice?
>> That's an interesting concept. That is
uh certainly not as useful as a ruin
runner that's like stacked up with
Trinity Force and sitting on a
battlefield that you know old Lucian
days where we were like, "Hey, this
camel can really slap."
>> The ruin runner in base could be
anything. Even a Trinity Force equip
Ruin Runner sitting on [laughter] the
battlefield.
>> If you can imagine hard enough, that
would be it. Um although both of these
players are having a great time in round
seven, both have made it to day two here
at RQ Utrift. This is the beauty of
original qualifier. You get to meet so
many new people and occasionally
celebrate freshest moments like this.
Even though this tournament brings out
the fiercest competition out there, you
mentioned regional national qualifiers.
I'm going to take this opportunity to
welcome you all to the Pol Polish
National Championship broadcast this
[laughter] next next game and a half. Uh
there's actually there are so many good
Polish players like we had Sebie uh at
um Bolognia in the finals against
against Allen so putting up good results
and many many more. Um, I mean there's
they've traveled with like 200 players,
so it would be really difficult to name
all of the the the best players to come
from that group, but um, it's so lovely
to see the support that they have from
their community. And I am sure I'm sure
there are many of you at home with
sizable national communities bring them
to the events. I want to see them.
>> I want to see all of you at events
>> as we go.
>> Oh my word,
>> a turn one unit.
>> Yes, [laughter] that's a good point.
Silven didn't get a turn one unit. Um,
you know, I'm I'm expecting a lot from
people uh Barcelona. I I want to see the
the Spanish community out uh in in
Barcelona. That's that's for another
time. That's that's August. We'll we'll
get there eventually. I will say they do
tend to to show up on mass. They do.
>> But back to the here and now, this
Lonely Porro is venturing out. And if
we're talking about battlefields that
are very very familiar, abandoned Hall
in Diana, a mainstay. Yeah. Yeah. And
now you've got the uh
>> okay
>> trigger of Diana going into the
battlefield
>> gets charmed of course that was where
that came from from Silven side of
things utilizing that
it's a fundamental of Ye but the the
defender passive that you you're going
to get from the the legend of course
triggers for new players when you charm
your opponent they are the attacker
>> so here's the deal
>> okay
>> what I
>> you can say all right charming the Diana
in there is Is that really what you want
to be doing or you want to save that for
something more valuable? There is a real
argument to be made to keep Diana on the
back foot, not allow her to get those
showdown triggers to start filtering
through her deck. Those really add up
over time. The longer the Yei gets to
stay on the battlefields,
>> the better it gets.
>> Go with tool.
>> Mhm. got to free.
>> So because of the star spring trigger,
the lonely parro was awoken at the
beginning of the turn and is able to
move back from that trigger from
Starring with a master being played
there. Allows it to say to conquer the
second battle.
>> If you will let me win even once this
Bree, I won't ever
>> Oh, no, no, no, no. I mean, if I will
win even once in this B, I won't ever
let you forget it. [laughter]
Silvin just wanting to to to have a win
or earn a win for himself.
>> Something I I would like to bring
attention to. Okay, cool.
>> The double-edged sword in this matchup
that is Starring.
>> Okay. Yeah, sure.
>> For obviously the the flexibility allows
for Yi
>> to filter out.
>> All right. I don't want I don't want to
play with Lonely Porro anymore. I want Y
on my
>> Yeah. You want to make bigger units all
the time. Yeah. But will take that to
his advantage as well. And every extra
move for Quay.
>> Oh, Moonfall again.
>> To Moonfall by one and recycle to play
defy.
>> Wow.
>> I thought it was kind of bad. Yeah,
[laughter]
>> I am easily impressed. I'm aware of
that. I still enjoyed that.
>> I'm absolutely the player that like
reveals the Rengar or something there
thinking it's there. That's okay.
charisma even while uh one zero down in
this
[laughter]
>> as we see some mind games being played
with children uh
which I call him as like like a Polish
haka or something [laughter]
>> that's that's I'm still the the flip
over
you're just living Ram free and anybody
else is head other than Allen.
Okay, happens.
>> Even though
I really enjoy the the the
>> the banter we are witnessing the fact
that that Moonfall did get the fight
>> really
>> messes with the the tempo that Alan is
setting out. It's not disaster in any
means, but the longer you can keep this
Diana on the back foot, the better your
chances are going to be as Y. Yeah, the
uh smoke screen followup because if you
force to keep investing power into these
early plays, if they want to commit to
the quake, they're going to have to tap
out again. That is where you can punish
once more. So, forcing Allen into these
tight alleyways where his he doesn't
have access to a plethora of options in
which he flourishes get him out of his
comfort zone. and his comfort no zone
should be known to one of the players he
plays most with.
>> Now, do you just fizz Moonfall?
>> Oldie but goody.
>> Do you just say uh it's in the bin, but
we're going to do it again.
>> And that will end up
>> dealing with the board anyway. The Defy
was good once but not available the
second time. Tapped out at that point.
And Allan once again exerts control over
the board. [laughter]
And this is the last position you want
to be in as yeah having to claw yourself
back onto the battlefield. However,
>> currently I do believe Allan is stepped
out. Oh, there you go.
>> No vex available. So that Rengar
though not pouncing will be making its
way onto the battlefield.
Hold.
>> Yeah.
>> Two, three, right?
>> Mhm. Mhm.
>> It's scrappy though when you're down to
just Rengar from hand on your turn pass,
but he's not completely vulnerable with
a single energy. You can at least fain a
lot of options to to stay on there. if
that is a a punch first, which would be
incredibly costly currently when you're
sitting on only five runes still.
>> But you always have to respect it. You
also have to respect five again like
you've seen one. You have to play around
it.
>> And it is something that you know Allan
will be uh calculating running all in
the lines the numbers at this point.
That's something that we saw in Bolognia
and we've seen historically from Alan
being able to process a lot of options
in the types of deck that Alan plays
like the Ezreal and Diana is like, "Hey,
I have a million ways I could do this,
but I have to pick the one that that
accounts for the most risk and how can I
play around that?" And and that's when
players pick up the decks like Diana,
like Ezreal that Alan has been playing
and they go to Nexus Knight or their
skirmish and they're like, "I'm going to
get it done." and you go one and one
every single round because you can't
close out in time and you're like, "How
does Allan do it?"
>> Well, uh, by grinding a million games is
the actual answer to that.
>> Trigger.
>> Okay,
>> it's 11.
>> Getting his trigger off,
>> which we saw at the beginning of
Unleashed a little bit of Ka'ix's play,
then kind of fell off for a couple weeks
in the middle. It feels like it's not
even that long
>> with the
>> Yeah, this one.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, just to make
things clear. May one,
>> cycle two.
>> Let's go next.
>> Yo.
>> Oh, and the white flag is being wed as
it is confirmed that we do have a punch
ready to go. Allan knowing that there is
no answer from his side and he knows if
if the units get wiped out at that
point, it would be a long route back to
um to you know establishing a board
presence and and getting through and
Alan's like ah let's go next. I'll I'll
start on the front foot in game three.
>> It it's exactly that because knowing
your options also means knowing when
when you are out of it even though you
your opponent might still be quite a
ways away from victory.
>> Yeah. I mean that that's half of the
exactly kind of what the type of thing I
was talking about. We don't often get to
see it in action, but it's something
that I've just assumed about the way
that Allan plays when he's out in the in
the hall where it must be like to get
through all these games. If you ever are
dropping a game, you're like, uh, okay,
I'm done. We got to get to game three.
Like, let's let's move on. Like, I need
like 20 30 minutes in my game three to
make sure that I'm I have enough time to
make sure I close it out.
>> And not only that, but also your mental
energy. Like, am I really going to burn
through all of my time and my mental
capacity to see if I can find the one in
a in a million out or am I confident
enough in my own capabilities to get it
done in the old deciding game three?
>> Yeah, which uh is where we're heading
between Silven and Allan. You you heard
Silvin say, "If I even win one game of
this series, I'm never going to let you
forget it." and Allan the one to to
throw in the towel on that one and say,
"Nah, okay, let's get into it."
>> I feel for Silven's future grandchildren
who will have to hear this. [laughter]
>> Hey, did I ever tell you about that time
that I
>> Yes, Grandpa.
>> Yes, Grandpa Silvin. We've we've heard
this time. [laughter]
>> Pure love of the game by Mlayer. Now
I am of the opinion that that is
no longer preferable. You want you want
to hear why?
>> I would love to hear why.
>> So Vamos layer just saying oh you can't
move to base from here.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I feel like even with Aurelia kind of
staying I don't want to say stagnant but
stable in in the I think she went like
maybe 1%.
A lot of these matchups have access to
ganking.
>> Sure. including yourself, but with so
many E out there, Ireelius out there, so
many access to other ganking, even the
Hill, which provides ganking from the
other side,
>> it's uh it's a tricky one and it's very
hard to get maximum value out of
>> and uh a bunch of the decks do have um
maybe not in in this moment um the the
bounce side. Diana certainly does, but
uh you know there are others where you
look hand Yeah, exactly. Like ride the
wind. So as we go into game three, that
that's an important point as uh it has
been a while since we've seen Valor's
used.
>> It definitely has its uses, but has
gotten a lot harder.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that that is very true.
Is this two drop into sabotage
>> and take the moonfall? N okay, two drop
into pass. Don't want to dill Seymour.
the I have been enjoying every
language's uh pet name for for scuttle
crab. Uh I've I've heard that in Italy
he's called Giorgio.
>> Okay, [laughter] cool.
>> And so every country and language has a
pet name for scuttle crab.
>> Let I think that's a beautiful thing.
>> Let us know the name of your scuttle
crab in in your region either in chat or
on social media. You can use a hashtag
rq utract to give us that all important
information.
The
target peak though um
>> you're still fine with it though, right?
Cuz you're like, "Hey, I get discipline
like every single time."
>> The stats however do not lie.
>> I believe the the the win percentage of
Diana
>> on the play going first with Targon
speak I believe it's close to 70%. which
is a
dazzling number to be hit across the
board.
>> Finds a stupify. So Allan's like, you're
going to have to commit a lot to this.
There's the discipline. So it goes up to
four. Stupify is going to try take it
down.
>> Throw. Yes.
>> That's a draw. Anything else from Allan?
Does he have a second stupify in hand?
>> Yeah. Yes. Pass.
>> Okay. Hand
trigger.
Lonely
and pass.
>> Interesting. Alan did have a second copy
of Stupify. I believe the
Diana ability was available, although I
would have to to go back and check the
bot.
>> Mhm.
A career as a scribe is uh not too far
away from Silven as he notes down the
entirety [laughter] of that. Like
honestly, sometimes I'm scared to play
sabotage in the same sense of like you
shouldn't ask questions you don't want
the answers for. Like could I see your
hand? I'd like to forget now. Please got
another stupifier. All three.
That is another skill. By the way, I I I
like to give these little tidbits for
players who are either starting out at
Nexus Knight or, you know, skirmish
level because that's your road here. Uh
writing down information very quickly.
Do not write every single word. Find a
system that works for you. If you can do
shorthand, great. If not, abbreviate in
any way that you can to make sure that
if you do get information that you write
down very quickly so that you're not
slowing yourself and the game down.
>> Does that confirm that the ancient
Egyptians played TCG?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, we got hieroglyph.
Um,
that's not a conversation to continue
[laughter]
as uh Allan's EQ is uh has the way we
didn't really touch on that uh coming
into
>> out of the last turn as we had the the
hand reveal
>> and once again in in this regard it's so
important that this time around Allan
didn't tap out committing to the
>> and even a single energy goes such a
long way backed up by A readied Diana
legend.
>> You really I want a a long Yeah. A long
way.
Two in one day is too many.
>> This is a conversation that we should
[laughter]
>> ah using my own words against me. I see.
>> I learned from the best.
>> Okay. Way is going to go in. Um now you
get to draw this card. This the more I
see this the the more broken it feels.
Um
>> yes I want to
>> this is an interesting adaptation that
we have to keep in mind though because
uh we can compare the lists from
Vancouver to what Allan has brought to
Utre.
>> So you have to take in mind in Vancouver
he was not main decking three Moonfalls
with the rise of Ye he has put in his
third moonfall from uh the sideboard is
now main board in Utre. also ditching
one of the uh vexes. Not not apathetic,
but the other one.
>> Cheers.
>> Cheerless. Thank you very much.
>> Um so you can see how minor adaptations
will make a significant difference when
you get to see so many cards in your
deck.
>> Well, there is one of the uh the best
shist. You can always sideboard them
back in, right? Exactly.
>> Just for the main deck difference.
>> And that's a card that was just like
synonymous with Allen's first win in
Bologna. Like nobody really saw it
coming. I kind of memed and put it on my
like cards I like.
>> Don't say that.
>> Nah, it's fine. It's long. It's long
enough now. No one remembers. I'm the
only one that talks about me putting it
on that graphic. But
>> the priority
>> as lonely progress is it
>> for three points.
>> Mhm.
>> For four. Mhm. And this is such a
daunting proposition to be diving into
as the master
>> having to face off against both
>> the quay
>> and the vex tierless which
>> makes com committing those combat tricks
in the showdown rather costly. You're
going to have to commit them early on
already.
>> Do you really want to fight it that way
or do are we fine just developing our
board? It is Alan who needs to answer
our point advantage which I'm sure won't
take too long.
>> And that's kind of the reason why it's
it's difficult to
>> we're reacting to the uh Titan. Um
>> so the ability and exactly turn itself
has already resolved and you can't
react.
>> Yes, exactly. The ability can definitely
react to
>> as uh
>> that will be the discipline. Uh the
reason for that is you do not want to be
penalized when the Vex then goes into a
showdown with the lonely pro.
>> Very hard to respond to that.
>> Yeah. Uh you actually as soon as this
move happens is not possible to uh to
make that adjustment.
>> Mostly just accepting that you're
getting a card draw there and just
forcing Allen to do something.
>> Hey, if he has to invest yet another
Moonfell just to get rid of my lonely
porro.
There are worse things that can happen
if if you're talking about charging the
highest price to your opponent to get
minor things done as well though, right?
Like cuz you pull in with another unit
and then you minus to them both and Vex
goes over the top.
>> This is for
>> So you're right. It's not just the
Lonely Power. And now it turns off the
Lonely Parro's death nail trigger and
turns off the E.
>> Oh, that's miserable if you're on the E
side of things.
Yeah,
getting the double whammy like we said.
>> First mate.
>> Mhm.
>> Oh, he wants the first mate as well.
Just saying they're cheap. These are
almost buy one get one free at this
point.
>> Yes.
>> Defy into a hard bargain. Just Allan has
every answer.
And this is uh looking to be have you
ever had a single Vex beat up a a Porro,
>> a would you bladesman from Ionia and a
first mate from Buildwater? Vex doesn't
mess around.
>> Sounds like the beginning of a very
clunky joke. [laughter]
>> Well, they're they're they're all
walking into a bar after this.
>> Exactly. Not the arena bar, though.
That's not in this matchup. As
Double moonfall again for Allan Carson
Hunt for
>> Mhm.
Alan wants to dig a little bit more.
Want to make sure that Hay is safe for
now. So
keep your eyes on how many runes Allan
will leave ready. Yeah. giving the
turnover by moving Hay back into your
base. You are safekeeping him a little
bit from the Rengar if it is going to
come out and just take it a step
further.
>> Yeah. Three to three.
>> Three to three.
>> Okay.
>> Taking it a step further. In response,
you can now write the winded back in
>> and eight might.
>> Yeah, that's fair. Also, Allan of course
was in control of Targon's Peak the
entirety of that turn. Did not conquer,
therefore does not ready two runes at
the end of his turn.
Some reluctance from Alan sight to let
that resolve without any push back.
>> Stupid fighter.
>> Okay.
>> Stupid fight to get one
>> and uh whoops all units. [laughter]
>> It paid off.
It paid off. Alan was like, if I'm get
if I'm losing this,
>> having that information, you know,
there's no right to win
>> for free.
>> So committing to a fight,
>> it's a lot easier.
>> Go here.
>> Ah, punished by the own stupify.
>> Score to four.
>> That just means you're opening up target
speak for Allen's conqueror next turn.
>> But you get to untap two at the end if
you're a Silven. So it's not it's not a
play without instinct. I I guess that
there there's there's two ways of
looking for that.
>> I guess I am more of uh getting my own
targets speak half full kind of.
>> Yeah, that's fair. [laughter]
>> I will say um at this point you know
that Hay is like a potential what there
were five units in hand. A potential
like plus [snorts]
15. [laughter] If you can move enough
times your fruitful enough
>> result. We haven't seen Latte but
Moonfall. Uh I I think it's it's been
flying pretty under the radar, but
>> never seen it in the
>> I kind of like this card.
>> It seems pretty good.
>> Pass
>> pass on priority through the showdown.
>> We knew that that was going to go to
eight. There was like almost nothing
different that was going to happen.
>> It was inevitable.
Now Allan inching Everford closer and
closer to not only day two
>> but continuing the streak.
>> Yeah, very truly he has just a history
consistently of making day two.
>> I mean he is the owner of Riftbound's
longest winning streak at 24 best of
threes.
>> Yeah, which is one in a row.
>> Incredible. Uh,
>> I can't even count that
>> at like a at a competitive level is is
is insane. Um, and I probably don't
think we'll get matched again.
>> Players here.
>> Yeah.
>> Go here.
>> Mhm.
>> And this is what we talked about
committing your combat tricks outside of
the showdown.
>> And S was like, you didn't have spells a
turn ago.
>> Do you have them [snorts] now? Oh, you
got one. But we can draw the spells.
[sighs and gasps]
Silven's gearing up.
[snorts]
You can see the smile on his face.
>> Mhm.
>> I think he knows where this is going.
channel.
>> I mean sometimes you just have to enjoy
the moment, enjoy the experience that is
laid in front of you and wait
>> uh pay one and uh one floating.
>> Yes.
>> Give plus five to the [laughter]
student.
And now paying one.
>> Yes.
>> And recycling one again.
Char to the battlefield. [laughter]
>> Silvin gives the the charm check
>> and a GG to Allen's EQ. Allan's EQ will
advance through round seven with another
win. Undefeated so far in the
tournament. Um, as we said, these two
know each other very well. Uh, I'm sure
both happy they've already made day two,
but a great sports mode performance from
both of them. You have to respect
[music] Silvin going out on his own
terms.
>> Yeah, that is I mean you have to to
respect it. And if you it's [music] both
a blessing and a curse to be facing a
friend, someone that you know, right?
Traveling all that way to still play
your your [laughter]
like I tried to get rid of you. There's
how many thousand players in this room
and and you you again really. [music]
>> So you kind of have to take charge
whatever you can. It can't be doubted
that Allen's run up to day [music] two
seems once again quite unstoppable at
least in the first seven rounds that we
have witnessed so far.
>> Yeah, exactly. As uh that was a a fun
fun game between the two of them. Um and
you know what that you could see Allan
kind of tap out of game two and say,
"Hey, actually I'd rather conserve what
left I've got in this matchup and make
sure I can, you know, get through the
round, take a You've been at it for 8
hours already.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's a long day. Uh,
anytime you can save an extra 10 or so
minutes and just be like, "Hey, I I'm
going to freshen up for the last round,
be ready to play uh and make sure you
are in top form." You can see how much
it meant to Silvin to actually get the
concession from Allen, though.
>> Generations will [laughter] talk of this
moment.
>> Carved into the grotto and caves in
Poland.
>> Yeah. You just have to say this is what
love for the game looks like. Yeah.
Yeah. This is to and to to appreciate
seeing a a master craftsman at work.
>> Yeah. And and honestly in two different
ways both around the competitive scene
because uh we we looked at in the the
video that you you uh helped make
earlier of just how big the Polish
community is, how much it means to the
Polish community to be here traveling as
a community. And you look at what
Silven's done in the community there and
performing on a high level. clearly has
both of those facets. Whereas Allan on
the other side, a great player as well.
But talking about that regimented
practice, grilling, like constant
improvement is always there. So, the two
different sides of what it means to do a
competitive event like these RQs.
>> Even when you're playing Diana, you got
you have to be respectful of the
importance of discipline
>> on the Masi side of the board
>> and to stay committed to your deck game.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> All the training, all the repetition.
[laughter]
We uh are are ready for what I'm sure
will be a very interesting interview
with our winner.
>> James, how could I just give you the
winner? We have a very special treat, of
course, uh an immaculate game of not
only one of our most prolific players in
the game, but a prolific part of the
world sharing together Allen ZQ and
Silvin joining me here for a joint
interview because at the end of the day,
congratulations you both. you've already
locked in day two.
>> But the fact that we got to witness what
card games is all about and the
camaraderie and the respect for each
other going against each other at the
table and having fun is is
>> Did you guys have fun?
>> I
No, I hate the guy, you know. I He's
like every day he's just busting me and
trusting me. I need I need to win
against him, but unfortunately not. Ah
yeah. [laughter]
>> I absolutely loved playing when he's
missing his two drop while going second.
>> What are the odds? What are the odds?
>> 97% of getting of getting dropped on
first on turn one going second in the
first game. Like what are the odds? Like
but it was it was for me it was my first
game on stream actually. So playing
against him, uh, I needed a fresh air
before the game, by the way, to try to
cool off because this whole day for me
is I don't know what's happening. Like
how can I be 61 at this point? I don't
know. I don't know. Okay, Tom Foolery
aside, we know each other for a long
time. We actually got to practice before
we met for like a whole day of practice.
So we had good reps into each other deck
and Silva knew what he needs to draw
into me. I knew what I needed to get to
win against him and I end up just
drawing better. Well, you say you can't
believe it, Silvin, but I believe it. I
just watched it happen. You Your only
loss is to the twotime regional
qualifier champion winner.
>> Look insane if you say say that. Say
that again. Say that again.
>> Your only loss today is to a twotime
regional qualifier champion.
>> Insane. Insane. I I can I I don't
believe it. But this guy, me having this
score, it's mostly this guy. Also, I
want to shout out Barek. Of course, BK
helped me a lot with mastery
preparation, but like for me someday it
it's going to be hard. There is a lot of
great players, him, Prismat, uh some
Sherman, uh who else Dwali, I I still
don't know how his nickname is
pronounced, but one day I really would
like to go with him to the for example
regionals. Maybe play against him in the
finals because he Okay, he doesn't know.
I didn't tell him this ever because I
don't want him to feel weird, but he's
literally my my idol, you know. He's my
friend, but he's my idol as well. So,
getting beaten by him on stream, I I
have won one game. I have won one game.
I I said I won't ever let him forget
that. So, it's it's a blast. It's a
blast.
>> And we got to watch it happen. And you
guys really got to show us that energy
and again what card games are all about
and why all of us in this room are here
to play. not just representatives of
Poland, but as Riftbound and the
community as a whole. So, first of all,
thank you. And you still have a lot of
tournament to play and I could sit here
and I think talk with both of you
forever. Allan, of course, you know, so
much insight, but even just watching you
both know and react and play. The
testing shows and you're both in day
two. So, Silvin, don't sell yourself
short. There's some more rift bound.
>> Thank you. Thank you, man. Thank you,
man. Thank you, man. And just and by the
way, thank you.
But I just want to say guys, everyone
that that plays this game
can maybe it's not a lot but can achieve
it. Reebound is so fun to play. It
actually gives so much of fulfillment
when you sit down in the t in front of
the table and play the game. So guys,
even if you yesterday I went one free in
PRQ, I had literally a breakdown after
that. And today I'm sitting here with
him and him he's his he's his goat as
well. So guys, just play the game and
believe in yourself.
>> Well, I don't really know what else to
say, but congratulations Alan on your
win as you will move on to your round
eight here. Still got day two to play
and one more round today, but that's
going to be it for this interview. We're
going to go ahead and send it back.
>> That is that's everything that we need
from an interview. Thank you Barrett for
for speaking to both.
>> Everyone needs Silvin in their life. I
think it's safe to say the hype man.
Everything we need. Uh yeah, I somebody
I'm going to take a moment and say
somebody's got to do that for the UK,
please. I'll I'll follow you. I'll
follow you into whatever we're doing if
if you can do it for the UK scene. Um
okay, let's wrap up that that uh match
up. So Allan, of course, as you said, 7
and0 um going into day two in an
undefeated spot. So in a very good
position. We're always keeping our eye
on who has the the zero in the losses
column as we close into the top eight.
That'll obviously be way later tomorrow,
but that puts you in the absolute best
standing cuz even two losses makes it
very unlikely. So, Silven's uh at 6 and
one right now. Still could potentially
win out and make it all the way there.
>> If you want to keep it within your own
control, just don't lose. That is that
is my tip for the stop loss.
>> Don't lose. Uh and and don't go
anywhere. Let's go into to our second
feature match for round seven. Um, we
are going to see I think many people's
best of best offset uh in Colin from uh
Challenger TCG. I mean when you look at
players that basically said, "Yeah, I'm
going to play this champion. I'm going
to play this legend from the beginning
of the game and then just like I'm not
going to do anything else."
>> And then also stare through the room and
making eye contact with so don't even
bother. who wants to challenge me in
these abs on set the boss as uh as Colin
will have advanced to this point. I
actually saw um those of you Jin main
fans earlier, Colin actually matched up
against Jibs who we saw earlier um and
Colin took that win uh in a match up a
little trickier for the Jin than the one
that we saw. So Colin has made his way
here to that 6 and0 position on set. So,
a lot of familiarity with kind of like
the the orange cards that come out of
Master Yi and a lot of the Fiora yellow
cards, if that makes sense. Like when
you're looking at that mid-range, you
got hidden blades, you got buys, you got
um I mean, Call to Glory is in here as
well, just because it's you have that
versatility with set um throughout. So,
um, nothing
overly surprising about that list,
although I would have to review it again
just to make sure that I'm
>> Here's here's the thing about set the
way you are leveraging through your
units. It is so important that you
always have like a front runner
>> for yourself to to rally behind someone
who can carry the banner, some something
to attach those challenges to, something
that can wield a buff and then
translated to more card draw. and and
Annie is going to make that really
really difficult for any of those major
uppercuts and knockout [clears throat]
blows to land. Especially now with
Unleashed introducing the Grim
Apothecary who makes it so hard to get
any sort of interaction to stick as the
moment you target them, the Apothecary
swoops in and puts him back in hand.
>> And then I'd be remiss not to talk about
the fact that it is Gonkra on the other
side of the table. But we focus so much
on Colin, of course, another
recognizable player on Hexon is um
running the Annie. So when we talk about
like running a legend, Annie is another
one where I'm like, well, you're
fighting Prisma for for best of Annie,
so you got to be confident in in how you
play this out, you can see the package
that we've seen a couple of times today
and throughout. Um the fairest
forrunners in the main definitely
something that we were seeing in Spirit
Forged. Um, we've seen Prismat changing
the list a couple of times. I know we've
seen them sometimes in sideboard or at
least the numbers start shifting around.
So, I'm interested to see exactly how
>> for Runners.
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. It is. Here's the deal
with Forrunners. The value is still
there.
>> Sure. Now that that star cross is just
the most efficient answer into
addressing the forunner, you have to be
really cautious and you shouldn't be
afraid of sideboarding it out if you are
facing a list that has plenty of access
to fizzes as well.
>> Uhhuh. That is very true as we actually
get to see the high roll for once on
this situation. So, we are going into
game one of our second feature match,
which is somewhat of a rarity for us.
Normally, we jump in throughout the
series. Uh, and and to give uh Gonker
their flowers, uh, top 16 in RQ
Vancouver. So, coming off uh a good
result as closing in perhaps on
the winning formula.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Very. That's some some great
recent result, recent history. So, um,
excited to see how this one goes. And I
mean just for for full disclosure, I do
feel this would be a bit of an uphill
uphill battle for Colin here.
>> He's going to be very meticulous and
precise in how he chooses to commit to
the place because
>> Seth doesn't commit
>> a little bit. If he is throwing a jab
that will go through a wall, requiring a
lot of force behind it, requiring a lot
of investment, if that doesn't pay off,
you're left exhausted.
>> I I feel like this might be a tricky
matchup. um in general the Annie into
the the set's so resilient as you were
kind of talking about in the buildup to
this resilient to any deck that's going
to throw out
>> spells and try and kind of like deal
damage take out like kill units because
the trade on oh okay I just use a set
legend and set abilities no I'm actually
fine like I just spend a buff and
suddenly I'm I'm in the same position
>> how I like to frame the analyst is kind
of like a surgeon
>> sure where you are wielding a scalpel
which can cut through a whole lot of if
you wield it the wrong way, it will
shatter.
>> It will chip and it will go blunt and
then just be scrap metal.
>> What you're saying is sets abs are made
of steel so that scalpel can't can't go
through.
Or maybe that's exactly what they need,
like the thinnest, sharpest blade out
there to pierce even metal.
What I'm fearful of for the Annie is if
they do commit to the taking down units
that are buffed up. If you have to
invest all the same to take down threats
on the enemy board that will just come
back for relatively free for the price
of a buff.
>> Mhm.
>> How long can you keep up with a set that
is
>> I don't want to say playing for free but
gets redos on his place?
>> Yeah. I'm I'm just having one of these
moments where it's like I'm watching a
set against somebody that plays a
Kaiser. I'm like, "What year is it?"
>> Oh, still this year. Okay, fine. Uh but
still very very Origins coded at this
point in in the game's life cycle. But
uh
>> I I was captivated by by Gonker's
headwear.
>> So that is
>> I love it.
>> Going for best of porro
at the same time. Um, excuse you, James.
They're all the best porros.
>> Yeah, how how can you pick? How can you
pick?
>> They are all the best porros.
Now, when we are getting onto our
battlefields,
arena bar coming out, making sure that
if we're going to class, we will be
buffing throughout. Keep your eye on the
monks in this list as well. Ringu monk
also present in the list, buffing left
and right. So, you're going to
>> have to work extra hard because there's
not a lot of down time between units
walking around without those buffs.
>> Yeah. And and that is another thing that
makes this match up kind of tricky is
well now you got to find spells that are
one more powerful. If you were just
threading the needle of, as you said,
that scalpel potentially of like, hey,
I've got exactly the right amount of
damage for exactly the right amount of
might. The buff on top of it is like,
oh, how do I do that without void gate?
[laughter]
>> And maybe you maybe you can get away
with it one time. Yeah. All right. I'll
I'll invest a falling star. But
investing a falling star for a unit that
will not go away.
>> Yeah.
>> And the moment they move it again and
Yeah. You can give him another buff
coming out. It it can really be this
endless torrent of units just throwing
themselves at you time and time again.
>> Yeah, that'll be cleave in order to take
that. Iso will uh
conquer. And there we do have the use of
the the set legend ability.
But what they bring in power on the set
side, they kind of lack in flexibility
>> because when they are moving to the one
battlefield, right, there's not an easy,
oh, I'll back right out. Oh, no, I'll
write the window over somewhere else.
So, you have to be you have to be very
conscious of how immobile you are at
certain times.
>> Yeah, I think that's a really good way
of of of approaching that. I will say
that at this point in the game set
having this many units stick is a bad
sign for Annie generally normally Annie
you're like I really need to keep you on
the back foot having four units develop
sorry three units developed and having
had to use to to try and take out the
Fiora. I always get arena bar like
bunched up with the the units counting
down. Um, having three units already
there makes it tricky to say, "Okay, I I
have to keep outputting some damage,
keep putting pressure on, keep
>> keep keep you on the back foot." It's so
hard, though. You're you're trading
inefficiently every single time. There
there there are no cards similar to
like, let's say, an unchecked power,
>> right? That can
>> like, oh, I play one card and it deals
with three of my problems.
>> Yeah,
>> that is just simply not really there on
the side of Annie. And when his sabotage
goes overhead,
the news might be slowly tightening in
game one.
>> I target her.
>> Did um
>> I looked away for a moment to sabotage.
I was going to say it's on the chain,
right? I saw Colin move to the uh
>> to the trash
>> on the sabotage. I just wanted to double
check that that indeed did happen. We'll
be able to starcross
through
to get rid of the uh the the Fura
without a deflect cost since it's not
mighty.
And with Unleash coming through, we see
not only the Rengar decks making use,
but even the set decks are benefiting
from from the FA folk here,
>> making sure you can minimize the
resources out there that can keep up
with you.
>> Despite all that muscle laying around on
the board, the victory points are
lagging behind
>> a bit significantly, I will say.
>> Uh, five.
>> Yeah, I think that's one of the things
where you're turning the corner quite
quickly.
and
>> is uh like like the deficit is not very
large, but it feels like Colin should be
further ahead than he actually.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I appreciate that. Uh now,
long sword played with quick draw in
order to get it out of hand. Clearly
clearly the the card that Colin would
would be taking there from the sabotage
if it was left in conqueror's hand. So
having to say, "Yeah, you're going to
force me to do it and I will have to
right now."
And Colin gets the read that I'm not
really scared of the next turn cuz
you're going to ready two runes.
And I'm I can see your hand. It's just
top decking for what you get.
>> Sure.
>> We are committing getting
>> our smaller units high and mighty
>> ready to be expended and build that hand
back up once more.
Monastery of Harana comes to fruition
spending the buff.
>> And we were talking about the
significance of tapping out against
Trixie decks. That's the moment you have
to strike. I spy with my little eye.
Zero energy available for Annie.
>> Yeah, exactly. Is uh
>> activate arena bar
offsets.
Uh.
>> Oh, now bringing over everything with
the Grim Apothecary.
>> And I pass.
>> Yeah, there is the Kingpin himself. And
with any uh well faltering and maybe
stumbling to the floor, this is the
moment that a set can start whailing.
Yeah. Landing punches, blow after blow,
keeping their opponent down. not
allowing them a way back in.
>> Yeah. And uh just for again newer
players perhaps not familiar with all
the keywords Kingping has the tank
keyword which means that damage has to
be assigned to him first. Therefore the
AOK stays alive.
>> Not enough to get through it. Therefore
all the units behind him get protected.
>> It was a pricey play though.
>> Look at what is left of the runes for
Colin going down to three.
>> Yeah. Yeah. that it is fair if there's
>> got plenty for it, right? Don't don't I
can see that. But
you need to have this stick around if
you are not getting a significant lead
from this.
>> Oh, hold the three.
>> Yep.
>> Unlike some of the other body decks that
we've looked at, set doesn't mind so
much leaving multiple things in one
place, though. Set obviously is going
to, you know, the other side of Kingpin
is like getting extra might for every
buffed unit that's at the same location.
So, you know, it it's not the master
where it's like, ah, I only really want
one thing here. If I just stack a
battlefield, I'm I'm actually not too
bad. Sometimes with set, obviously, you
want to be able to conquer on schedule
and uh utilize as much
of your your unit's ability to move
around as possible. And that's going to
be the first mate
>> readying set.
>> It's the pseudo ganking
>> uh draw one for
>> this is another aspect when you're
playing into set. Even if you're like,
"All right, I'm going to get rid of a
few units and their buffs."
>> Uhhuh.
>> You're sending them back to base. So
they'll be be ready in base, ready to
attack next turn.
>> So you're gaining you're giving more
flexibility to a deck that critically
lacks flexibility.
>> Yeah. But it's it's kind of a a damned
if you do, damned if you don't, cuz you
have to deal with them. You can't just
leave them there. The Starcross is the
only other like acceptable way of saying
get out of here for now. It's kind it's
really similar to taking down a scuttle
crab when when you have to take down
Seymour. It's like, well, I'm glad I can
get rid of the body and deny you the
hold, but I don't like you seeing my
hat.
>> My pet Ricky.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, that's a lot of buffs.
>> It is your turn.
>> Someone out there has like a full set of
like riot buffs for their set deck and
that is like the most blinged out.
>> I just can't wait. We We had the Bramble
back, right? and the the golem, the red
buff, blue buff being introduced.
>> And I just can't wait for the next set
where we can finally
>> Oh, are you leaking? Are you
>> No, no, no. I can't wait for for for the
moment where maybe there are cards that
allow more buffs. I mean, Master Le
already does for No.
>> Oh, I see.
>> Come on. How much fun would it be to
regard a card that has buffed twice as,
oh, they have double buffs? [laughter]
Uh, now we're getting into the League of
Legends of it all,
aren't we all? Isn't Isn't that our
uniting factor?
>> True.
>> Yeah.
>> Now it's Riftbound.
>> Though I I do appreciate that there
there is this this subgroup of players
that's being drawn in that do not play
League but love Riftbound
>> and they just don't understand any of
the reference.
>> They got to smile and wave through
there.
>> They're like you had to be there.
>> You had to live through it.
>> Something that we should be calling out
in in this regard.
>> Call it out. Though
Grunk has been taking major hits, they
are keeping up in victory points quite
diligently.
>> Yeah. Grinding out point for point as
well as possible.
Now plays
the Rengar.
Not so much pouncing, but
>> play Star Cross any set.
>> Talked about in the previous turn how
how influential Starcross can be just
with uh saying okay here
>> discard flash.
>> Wait, I'm sorry. What did Starcross
target
>> uh set uh Annie? Oh, sorry.
>> Sorry.
>> No worries.
>> Yeah. So, discard flash.
>> Yeah. And that is some of the synergies
why starcross in Annie feels I mean it's
a costly play as uh we're going to ring
some glory up see if they're home see if
they will pick up [laughter]
will allow the pit rookie to survive a
little more and these are these assaults
that we mentioned where if they bust
>> you are hurting.
>> Yeah, exactly. And facet spending one
buff there is totally fine. You would
spend it anyway to keep the unit alive.
So, keeping it alive.
>> That's pocket money for [laughter]
>> Exactly. So, you know, now you're just
putting another wall in front of the
Hannie
>> when the when the bellhop carry sets
bags to the to to the box in his in his
arena, right? He he tips in buffs. Yeah,
you get you have a buff. Don't spend it
all in one place.
>> Sec can carry his own bags like this.
>> Of course, he can.
>> The epitome of liftbound.
>> But would you want to?
>> Yeah.
I guess
>> I can cook my own food, James. But
[laughter]
>> that's fair.
>> You have someone shuffle for you. Do you
hand your deck to your opponent and be
like, I can shuffle if I you do that. If
I if I had enough buffs to be spent to
be around like set does I probably
would.
>> Top three.
>> Play first mate. Ready, set.
>> Okay, we're crowding the board, but I'm
going to keep highlighting it every
single time it happens. Focus. fully
tapped out.
>> Okay, got it.
Conquer going to say, "Yeah, that's too
much for me to overcome with the hand."
You kind of have an idea of what was in
there earlier from that that sabotage.
And Colin will advance to game through
[music] game one of this series. We are
of course in a best of three, which puts
us in a situation [music] where Colin
will be looking to pick up one more win
to be stay undefeated.
don't have exactly the sideboard plan,
but I have to imagine there's an
unyielding spirit in the sideboard. Uh,
which typically is is what has always
been included in in body sideboards to
deal with direct damage spells cuz it
says, "Hey, take no damage from spells."
And and also um what you sometimes see
is right all right if I'm heading into a
matchup where star cross will be played
more than once cuz either Annie is
balancing it or Fizz is recasting it
from your trash being able to at least
all right maybe give some sort of
immunity and cover up the the most
important people in your deck. Yeah.
Yeah. Get some of that security on the
other side. I'm wondering where Annie
goes. This feels like a particularly
difficult matchup um to play out. So,
don't know that there are too too many
sideboard uh options here, but I'm not
overly familiar with the list that Gonra
is uh is running. But
>> it's to me just in um in atmosphere that
the Annie deck brings
>> it really it strikes me as similar to
the not necessarily in cards wielded
>> but having lots of two ups having a one
up here and there because you know I'll
be seeing plenty of cards
>> and I need the flexibility to adapt on
the fly.
There's a bunch of cards that
when they were revealed,
well, when I say a bunch, I'm just going
to talk about the card smite. It's not
particularly helpful here because set
prevents death, right? Like the way that
it works is it's if it were die this
turn, you know, it doesn't. So, it
doesn't really beat that. But with the
Rise of Deathnell decks, I've always
wondered whether like there's a a a room
for the banish effect coming from Smite,
I don't think it's really good cuz
action speed is is too slow to to
>> cost for power, right?
>> Yeah. So, it's not well placed, but I've
always wondered is that something that
can make it work. Uh irresistible fa
folk has for body decks been just one of
the absolute top performing cards in my
mind. I have no stats for that, but I'm
going to just assume. No, it it is it is
out there together with with punch first
there there there can't be any doubt.
Now
>> what does it feel like?
>> You are just holding any hostage right
now. Like all right, you want to play
anything on the board? Well, you better
be playing two units cuz any one unit
you will commit. Even if it has four
might,
you're vulnerable. Yeah, I'm looking at
what's in hand. There's a Fiora punch
first, another fay folk. That's the
thing as well, depending on what trade
you're taking. You're also fine to
expend the fa folk sometimes. Annie is
probably one of the decks I would do
would
>> like not do it against so much.
>> Flash bought it
>> from the sh of Annie.
>> So they can at least keep their Kais
safe.
>> Ah, I see. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I I the
>> I decline the trigger.
No, because of Arena's greatest.
>> I'm okay with giving him.
>> I'm okay with giving him. You didn't
save us. I don't care. You get
>> Yeah, I just Sorry. He get No.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He gets it. He gets
it. He gets it. No, no, no. He gets
Yeah. Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> No, that's good. That's good. I get your
point.
full marks to Gonra for sportsmanship
as uh we will be giving the point out
for uh arena's greatest at the very end
and that this is what I like even though
we are in the highest echelon of
competition
>> these players if they want to win
they'll be like I'll I'll do that on my
own strength.
>> Yeah.
uh points for sportsmanship uh in that
exchange. Um I I think it's worth noting
where we are in the tournament for both
of these players. Both 6 and0 both have
made uh day two already. So again, we've
talked about how important it is to to
maintain undefeated for as long as
possible and and get through towards
that top eight, but still six was the
number of wins they were aiming for to
make day two. So, a little a tiny tiny
tiny bit of the pressure is is off
compared to how coming into this round
would have been, but still an important
round for both. You have to take it step
by step. Yeah.
>> You can't make top eight if you don't
make
>> day two. Yeah.
>> So, even though for plenty of these
players making day two is the bare
minimum.
You It's not a given that you will make
it.
>> Yeah. And many many players um I' I've
seen posting their results today are
already at X and two and that's like
well as soon as you get to that point
that's a dangerous thing with rounds
left still to play on the day
>> and it ripples as well because when
you're every game you're fighting for
your quote unquote life
>> that does something to you mentally as
well leaving you more exhausted more
prone to mistakes it's a
>> it's a negative sprigger right
>> uh yeah
>> okay I just want to see if I want erect
that's why
>> oh I see okay yeah Um,
>> which one?
>> This.
>> Yeah, it does change it does change my
life to react cuz I was thinking
>> so. Sorry.
>> You have how many cards?
>> Uh, five.
>> Five.
Little bit of
>> just clarification.
>> Yeah, clarification. And just make sure
we're in in the right step here. and you
know he gave him the point earlier. So
>> I mean even though
>> Colin set is not a unfamiliar face out
there
>> you're not getting a whole lot of reps
into a set. It's good to clarify certain
triggers
>> of course because Fiora is mighty has
all keywords on it including ganking. So
we'll be able to go battlefield to
battlefield. Uh again, just such a a
versatile unit that has has historically
throughout the entirety of uh of Ripan
so far been played in a lot of yellow
decks that Fior victorious. And this is
what it means to play against a good
set. He is not allowing openings for
efficient trades. And how do you open a
door if you if you can't stop it from
closing?
If you if you put your foot in between
that door, you're losing the foot.
[laughter]
>> Is a revolving door ever open or closed?
>> I was not ready to
>> I know. I I hit you back with a
philosophy. And that's a big hit though
with a punch first. Is going to turn
this fight back in Colin's favor.
>> Is that good?
>> Is on the chain.
>> We'll see what Gonkra has as a response.
There was a star cross in hand and that
is what it's going to be. It's going to
be the set and the
>> Renga
repulse.
>> This is what we were talking about. This
is what you need. And you if you know
the matchup is there and that is the
emergency break being pulled by Gonkra.
Needing to get out of there as quickly
as possible.
>> A lot used to escape as well.
>> Getting out alive, but
Barely the damage that's been done to
the economy of Gonkro will be felt for
generations.
>> From here, Colin is just like posted up
on both battlefields.
Holds to six
>> and he is threatening the game from
Ayura now.
>> Yeah,
>> Gonkra has to to mount a comeback and
it's going to be made even more
difficult.
>> Sabotage is going to reveal. Do you have
anything in hand? Can't afford that star
cross. It's hiding back there. Can't
afford it. Just an inferno where at this
point would
>> Yeah, there there's there's no nothing
that does this turn. And the Vex in
hand. I think it's a Is it a Vex or is
it a a Kaiser in hand?
We'll find out. As
>> that would be as we go. The third
Kaiser.
We'll move
in.
>> Just bringing it over and whittling
away.
>> Eight tank. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> With tank goes up to eight and makes it
really difficult.
>> Okay.
>> Two for faith. Oh, another FA folk just
says conquer if you play a unit
>> it's going to get pulled. Oh, and even
is able to bring it to the battlefield
with the showstopper.
>> And I think that is the round stopper at
this point. It's going to be another
unit pulled into a combat that cannot
get through the set.
>> You know what they say that that had to
be the suplex that broke the Annie's
back. That's the superlex at this point
with this much strength on the board.
The inferno comes in just to go a little
bit over the top. Put some down, force
out one buff being used. Unfortunately,
that puts Set back
>> into the base. So, when I say
unfortunately, it just means that Set
will get readied up and be able to move
to the other battlefield quite easily.
Gonkra
>> likely out of options and will extend
the fist bump over to Colin who stays
undefeated in day one. 7 and0 as Colin
looking to once again
prove to be the best set and still in
the running for the tournament. I am so
glad we got to watch the entirety of
that match because it's easy to see
Colin on set and be like, "Oh yeah, of
course he's doing well." But to see it
happen, how the sausage is made, this
Annie, which you know some people will
label as one of the strongest decks out
there when wielded by those who are
experienced with it, felt absolutely
powerless, like taking candy from well
from a child quite literally in in that
exchange. Um so Colin advances as we
say. Conquer is still in the tournament.
That is just the first loss. Uh so six
and one still through to tomorrow. Still
in contention for top eight, still in in
a a good position. Just has to win out
now for the rest of the rounds. And
shout out to the crowd that have joined
us at the viewing area here in the
venue. It is uh quite late in the day.
Uh the players do still have one more
round to go as we close in on 900 p.m.
local time. So
>> one one more for good measure.
>> Yeah, one more for good measure. I think
I think Do you want to pay more today?
We do you want to add like five more
rounds? I mean you you don't even have
to ask what we are doing right after
this like between the rounds.
>> I'm being told we can't add any more
rounds. What we can do, [laughter]
what we can do is head to a quick break
and hear from Dvali.
>> Bear Bryant here joined with an absolute
pleasure for Dwali, one of our reigning
regional qualifier champion and I still
got to say it to this day. It's always a
pleasure talking to you because you're
the first one like and that will never
be taken away. And so, but not only just
that, but you are the epitome of, you
know, other players like Allen and
Prismat, and we'll get to that in a
second, but of this game is hard,
>> and the skillful ones continue to do
well. You just came off of a semi-finals
in Vancouver.
>> Yeah.
>> How are you doing? That was a rough
match. I mean, it's that's a that's one
of the strongest players of this game,
if not the strongest player.
>> How's your mental going is really where
I'm at.
>> Uh mental is good. I mean like uh we
both you know not to take anything away
from Sam but we thought you know whoever
won our match is most likely to be the
first two time just because we think we
have a good match up in Dengar. Um and
you know that's a lot of pressure I
think for one match because I'm thinking
you know what if I win this I'm likely
to win the whole thing. uh obviously it
was a really tough loss and I wish I'd
won but at the same time you know
Allan's super good and uh you know I've
been talking to him and he told me you
know in in our match after he beat me
he's like if we played 100 more games
we'd be 50/50 so
>> that's [laughter] such an awesome thing
to say.
>> Yeah. So I I got to play a few more
games against him and then you know what
maybe I'll get to 50/50 and beat him
next time. You say 50/50, but
>> Dewali, I was there in Houston when you
beat him.
>> And that was also an incredible match
>> going into your eventual win in Houston
because let's be real, like I mean the
finals I thought was pretty fast. Your
semi-finals was a grinder and then you
had to play against Allen as well. So
you won there
>> and now there's this, you know, you're
playing you're both playing Diana. You
were playing different versions
obviously. So I I kind of went, how
about that? you know, like do you think
that version is better specifically when
it gets to that top cut situation? Cuz I
I think the frigid touch or the frigid
jewel version is much better for the
field.
>> Yeah, it is.
>> So my question though is that I mean to
win these events, Dwali, you have to
beat those
>> players that are playing the more
specialized versions. What's the game
plan right now? Do we kind of still
tailor to that or have we made some
changes maybe?
>> So it's it's kind of like a give and
take like you're mentioning, right? you
have a better shot at doing well on day
one and like maybe the early rounds of
day two if you have a more general
version with Juul. Um, but my goal when
I come to these things is to win, right?
So I think like for example this
tournament I brought one that I think is
better for the top tables and I hope to
get a little bit, you know, fortunate I
guess during the Swiss in terms of not
running into anything that's like a
really bad matchup. Um, and then when I
get to the top tables, if I can get
there, then I should in theory have a
better shot. So that way, you know, if I
play against Allen again, I'm not
slightly on the back foot. At least I
can make it closer. And I think we're on
the same list this time. So So okay. So
I I do want to pivot with that cuz to me
that's like one of these it's I I say
the word rivalry, but at the end of the
day, respect for each other, incredible
players.
>> What about the rest of the people in the
room? you know, there are obviously, you
know, we talked about Sam a little bit,
prismaticism, you know, like I there's
this there's this
>> pillar of players right now and you you
are one of the players on that pillar,
but there's other people as well and
it's like I don't know how much, you
know, you obviously you haven't really
ran into him in the tournament setting
necessarily a ton, but
>> what do you think it takes when I fast
forwarding a little bit when we get to
things like a championship?
What's going to happen when you put all
of you in the same room and you can
actually start getting paired against
each other in rounds one, two, maybe
like three.
>> That would be wild. So, you know, of
course, it's not just me versus Allen. I
think it's a bit of that dynamic because
we played in top eight now a bunch of
times and we're playing the same deck,
but I mean, we have Prismat, right? Uh
we have the challenger guys. They have
multiple top eights. You have Colin, you
have Daniel. They're all great players,
honestly. Um you have Sam, right? Sam's
a repeat top eight. He's one. Um so, you
have these great players. you have, you
know, there's Chinese players like Rico,
for example, that's incredibly good. So,
there's a ton of amazing players. And
when you get to that championship level
where each round is a grind, you know,
round one you're against Prisma, round
two you're against Allen, I think I need
to maybe up my endurance because it's it
it really is a grind on the mental when
you every round you're getting put
through the ringer. Um, but honestly,
hearing that makes me super excited.
Every round is going to be a banger
>> and I can't wait to see that happen. But
for now, we still have some regional
qualifiers to go through and I expect to
see you at basically all of them.
>> That's my goal. Yeah, that's my goal.
>> Making a name for yourself here in
Riftbound. And it's just the first year.
So much more to come. Dwi, an absolute
pleasure, and I wish you luck in your
Riftbound career in the future to come.
>> Thanks so much. We're going to send it
away.
>> A key component of playing League of
Legends is gathering XP and leveling up.
Now you can do that in Riftbound 2 with
the newest additions in Unleashed. Every
XP you get will add to your level as a
player and will benefit you in different
forms. So far three [music] legends have
been released that directly benefit from
XP gain. Ka'ix Void Reva Poppy Keeper of
the Hammer [music] and Master Yi Wu
Master. Notice that all of these have
the body domain in common. Master Yi
uses XP passively. With higher level, he
finds stronger passive effects. At level
six, your units are permanently boosted,
and at level 11, your units always enter
ready. Of course, in the main [music]
deck, most masteries will rely on the
champion unit, Master Yi, unstoppable as
a win condition. [music] This one gets
cheaper the more XP you have, and at
level 16, it even becomes unargetable.
Combined with Master Yi, Wu Master's
ability to enter ready, he can really
swing games. Kha'Zix and Poppy have the
unique ability to gain XP through their
own legend abilities and otherwise use
it like a resource. While Poppy
generates card advantage by spending XP,
Kha'Zix gains utility by either buffing
his units or moving exhausted units away
from their battlefields back to base.
Since all of these three legends have
the body domain in common, there's a
huge variety [music] of body cards that
can get you the XP you need through the
hunt keyword. For example, hunt cards
grant you an XP whenever you conquer or
hold. So winning combats for those decks
is of utmost importance. Cards like
Gemand Hunter, Boracious Gromp, and
Master Heat Tempered [music] can be
found in all three decks, but XP can
also be splashed into other decks. Grim
Resolve, for example, is a strong combat
trick that gives a unit three might on
action speed. If the unit wins a combat,
it grants [music] you two XP. This card
might find its way into other decks as
well. Fiora players have already played
around with the Shepherd's Heirloom,
which works like a Dorance Blade, but
does not equip for power cost, but for
XP. There are plenty of ways to
integrate some XP gain into your decks.
So, get those level in and scale into
the late game, Riftbounders.
All right, thank you so much, Leo, for
that little walk and talk there about
the XP mechanic. We love to see it. But
we are getting to the business end of
the events now. We are hunting for best
of especially since this is our last
time for players to get their hands on
those origin ones. So that's most likely
what we're going to be seeing moving
forward. But I am Sha Burton joined by
Leo. Leo, what you think now going into
our last round of Swiss here at Utre?
>> I want to see something spicy. I want to
see something that has not been seen
that much before. And of course that
still has a chance or is locked
alternatively into the top cut already.
I've been strolling around the top
tables between the rounds and there's
some pretty cool decks there. Some uh
faces I'm familiar with. I'm very proud.
Some of my locals are actually
performing quite well. A good friend of
mine Brent is right now undefeated on
Victor with the Victor Innovator. So and
also the Vanguard Armory. So that is a
really really cool deck that we're
seeing right now. And of course also we
had them in the backup featured match
earlier. Couldn't see them. Dynamic with
Draven and a really really cool list at
that
>> 61. Okay. See which ones we're going to
be getting a hold of. I've been on the
receiving end of that Victor style deck
and quite honestly my P had like 20
recruits in play. I'm just thinking how
is this happen then? What am I going to
do? Turns out wasn't going to be a
wasn't going to do a great deal. But
let's go into our minds of our players.
So let's say you are targeting an
Origins. Yeah. Let's all do it together.
Let's get in there, guys. Let's think.
So, we've been targeting Origin's bests,
right, Leo?
>> Yeah.
>> We're currently now, we need to win this
next round to make sure we can secure
our origins legend of choice. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> What's going through your head right
now?
>> Better not miss a two job. That
[laughter] must you know, you take you
take one game at a time. Of course, if
you are just right in front of those
very important matches, the pressure is
on, right? It is going to change. Even
if you don't want it to change, even if
you're saying, "I'm going to treat every
game equally
when you're in front of those big
matches, it's really really hard to keep
that up. If you can't completely zone
out or lock in rather, that's that's
great. But on the other hand, in those
big matches,
sometimes this pressure can also get
something out of you, right? So
sometimes it also uplifts you. Some
people though, they fold under pressure
and uh I mean, all of that is fine, but
hey, there we go. Fantastic. Well, let's
make some noise for our crowd. We're all
the way here at 9:00 here in the venue.
We haven't even got enough seats for
everyone. That's what we like. That's
what Riftbound's all about, isn't it,
folks? Last time to get our hands on
some Origins Legend. That's what we love
to see. Looks like we have players.
Haven't got headsets, though, so we
can't give too much away, but we do have
players now sitting at our table. Do you
recognize any of those, Leah? No,
>> I have no idea. We're very excited to
see what these players are going to
bring. So very very much curious. We
probably got a message somewhere where
it says what these players are playing.
But I think that we're going to see a
legend that without saying too much
because you know the players don't have
the headphones on yet.
>> You can kind of already see it while
shuffling here is choosing a deck that I
predicted to be the deck. So I'm quite
curious to see that.
>> Phenomenal performances in the last
Chinese regional in Tanzhin.
I hope I pronounced that right by the
way. If not, my apologies.
>> I think you did to be fair.
>> Let's hope so.
But yeah, going into our last Swiss
round feature match here at the Utre
regional qualifiers. If you are joining
us here, thank you for taking spending
your evening with us. We're going to
have a very fun round of Riftbound. I'm
sure we will. I'm very glad to be your
tour guide here through this day one
action. Don't go anywhere cuz obviously
tomorrow we will be crowning a champion.
>> Absolutely. Today it is a little more
chill of course you know many players
will reach that day too if they just go
X2. That is the threshold that you
definitely need. There might be some
minor other modifications but I think
with 18 points you should be good to go
to reach that day two. And I am already
curious you know I'm I'm a big stat guy.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. lot of might, but I'm
curious to see the conversion rates of
the legends that we're seeing because
yes, we're talking about it quite often
that so many pay players are playing
different decks because of the best off
system. Everyone wants to be the
prestigious best player of their
respective legend. However, I want to
see how well they do. Like if you're
looking at the the bottom floor of meta
relevance of legends, if you're looking
at an ARI, a Jinx or whatnot, I want to
see how many sign up and how many
actually make day two because some of
those actually can have quite the high
conversion rate and that might then be a
secret meta contender. We have just seen
that
>> in Vancouver with Sherman getting second
place with Renga and all of a sudden,
you know, Renga was nowhere. People
laughed at Regga, which they shouldn't.
All of a sudden, in the pre-rq
yesterday, Renga was the fifth most
played deck from over 40 different
legends.
>> Yeah, it's interesting that Rengar
because I actually managed to get my
hands on most of the cards before the
Vancouver is off. But this this, you
know, this deck seems cool. You can
ambush a lot. And then Vancouver
happened and I went to locals. There was
like five Rengar in the room. I was
like, where were all used last week? You
know, you're only jumping on it now.
It's cool. But I was there from the
beginning. But yeah, it's something to
be It's an interesting one, right? cuz
let's say you are targeting a best of
and then you have a a bit of a wonder
run, a princess run as it were, and you
find yourself catapulted up into day two
and beyond. All of a sudden, you might
have a sneakily good meta pick that
targets the top, you know, x decks
rather well.
>> Yeah, that can of course always happen,
but I most of the time I don't think
it's
>> by accident. I think most of these these
players
>> have really put their hearts and souls
into their deck list into a meta read
realizing okay what has performed well
in the most recent regionals. What decks
are on the rise? What do I expect to
have more usage? For example, the Master
Yi that all of a sudden picked up so
much in usage since people have realized
>> this is not a late game deck. We want to
play the aggro mid-range version of
Mastery Yi because Yi flat out gives you
stats.
>> Yeah.
>> And traditionally in card games, just
flat out stats, they don't scale into
the late game. This is this is early to
mid game.
>> And that's how you should play Y
apparently. You run arena's greatest.
You run the Renga. Renga offensive six
drop for five energy is already good and
then you bump it up to eight and then
you try to finish the game as early as
you can instead of just waiting around.
You have defensive capabilities because
of that might bonus to ramp up to get
more runes in. But then what?
>> Yeah, that's the thing. I always think
Master Yim has it's been doing
fantastically well, right? Hasn't been
having a lot of good results and really
represented here. I call it it's almost
like a good honest riftbound, isn't it?
You know, there isn't that many tips and
tricks apart from the Rengar ambush of
course. You know, you put your unit
down, you say, "This is my mic. Can you
topple me?" No, I win. If not, turns out
you might win. So, yeah, good honest
master. But it looks like Leo, we do
have headsets on, so we can start to
have a little gander about what our
players here are playing. Oh, there we
go. A little bit of a Leblanc deceiver.
An interesting one. A card that has had
a lot of hype coming into this format.
You know, I feel hasn't had the greatest
of results, I'd say. But on paper, the
the deck is terrifying. You can just
blink viewers and all of a sudden the
reflections are here. Big might here.
Mixologist is just spawning units out of
nowhere. They can get out of hand. That
is what Leblanc is all about.
>> I mean, Leblanc is one of those decks
that are so incredibly powerful that
even with a low meta share, people built
their decks around it, right? There's
Gus in every single chaos deck basically
just because that card really stops the
Blanc. And there's some utility in other
matchups. I'm not saying that Gust is
bad into other decks, but it has such a
great application versus Leblanc, which
is why I think Leblanc's
usage kind of gets hit by collateral
damage somewhat. But the deck is scary
when it actually gets to scale. And
Challenger TCG's Desiden has brought out
this hook variant basically
>> that is it feels like so far ahead of
all the other Leblanc decks. And there
we have the Rexi Void Burrower Legend
deck actually running an honest broker.
We're not seeing seals. That's really
really cool how these Rexai decks
developed because there is so many
different lists. We are playing 10 two
drops this time. Are we Is there no void
rush?
There is no void rush. Oh,
that's interesting. And how often you
not see the signature spell the deck
like the signature spell in this deck is
rather strong by the way. I mean it's an
interesting one but obviously they've
gotten so far through the event. So it's
been clearly been working for it. Maybe
at the very least a side option. I mean
I the sidec I would usually reserve for
some certain matchup to fix some some
issues but I can see it happening but we
are going to see where it's going. The
players have started. We are proceeding
the mulligan. Nice tech on the Rexa deck
is the shells.
>> That is a rather rather strong card.
Gives extra might bonus and I think it
can predict. So you are perhaps having
some of your reveal triggers 10 two
drops. Not finding one. How many times
has this happened on stream already
today?
>> Wow. That's not what you want going into
your last Swiss round here. Looks like
we're immediately going to see our
champion Leblanc hitting the field. Back
over to Vocarta now. What can they
muster up? It's just going to be the
big, the bad, the scary Kaiser.
The signature sort of character or card
I should say from the Fury archetype or
domain I should say is back over to
Hector now. And the thing is about
Leblanc, it can be traditionally slow
out of the gates. However, I feel the
longer the game goes on, Leblanc can
quite honestly just get a little bit
silly if I'm putting it lightly. There's
going to be reflections flying
everywhere. There's going to be tokens
here. There's going to be baited hooks
there. Quite honestly, it's hard to keep
up with it if I'm being perfectly
honest. So, if there's any deck you
don't want to have a slow start against,
I think LeBlanc is high up on there. But
traditionally, that rackside deck can be
quick out the gates. Do you think it's
possible Leo for for Carter to you know
leap frog game sort of push tempo back
their way?
>> Missing the two drop is really really
hard especially against a deck like the
blanc. You're absolutely right because
already this baited hook scaling deck is
running away in points. Of course,
abusing Starring such a funny
battlefield to use in Leblanc because
you can just make these ready tokens or
reflection units now and then you can
play your low draws the watchful sentry
next to it and just push it back conquer
the other battlefield. It has a very
wind swept hillockish
effect in that regard.
And now, of course, you're not going to
hold on that other battlefield, but if
your opponent doesn't take care of it,
you're going to draw two cards in the
beginning step does make it harder for
your opponent to conquer sometimes. So,
these temporary tokens, even though they
have temporary written on them,
>> which can become super hard to deal
with.
>> It really can. You can obviously use the
other uh Leblanc to turn them. We remove
that temporary tag if you so desire. but
not one we see all the time in a Leblanc
deck. We have to respect it if it comes
out. We are going to see Cleave coming
down on the Kais. That's going to be
seven.
Okay, this is looking good. What is
that? A seven into a four. Kaiser will
win that. We are going to see a draw now
as well from the Kaiser.
>> Kaiser and D.
>> Yeah, everyone draws cards now. We have
the Leblanc that draws us a card. We
have the Watchful Sentry that gives us a
card. We have Kaisa that draws us a card
in the beginning step. if you don't get
rid of well that's a lot of options you
have here
>> in the beginning step that's going to
draw two cards for Hector TCG however
takes off
>> the pressure he has on board a little
bit if if you want to call it pressure
now well Karta is finding a decent two
drop-ish in the Noxus hopeful pushes
back the Kaiser way more useful in base
than on a hold because then you can
freely conquer to draw some more cards
get some more value in there but now I
actually haven't seen the three drop
Leblanc too many times die in the
beginning step. This actually
feel like it happens way less than it's
supposed to be.
>> Well, that's the thing about Leblanc. It
needs to keep units in play for you to
use that legend ability and start
getting those reflections down. If you
can sort of stop the units as they keep
coming in, the Leblanc deck can really
struggle cuz you need units in play even
for like your baited hook plays for
example. So, if you can keep removing
that, Varta could be in a good spot. But
one thing I want to draw attention to is
that Rexai breacher when units get
played from anywhere other than in your
hand. They now have accelerate which
obviously the Rexai legend can do. So
keep an eye on that one. But it is just
going to be the Rexful Rex coming down.
>> Yeah,
>> ruined Rex I should say. That's a scary
one. That definitely will doing four
damage to any enemy unit.
>> Yeah, sometimes times two with a Carus
for sure.
>> Keep an eye on that one. That car will
make death nails trigger twice and that
honestly glass mixologist ruin rex. It
gets rather I said this a few times but
honestly if I need you to draw it home
it can get silly. Kaiser is going to
charge in though
>> and I think the under titan is a premium
target to discard. I actually really
like zones warrants in Rex because some
of those cards that you really want to
reveal off the top not too great to draw
them necessarily. Oh,
>> falling star. Falling star put out is
going to get played.
>> Wow.
>> Ruin Rex that is going to get sent to
the discard. The trash I should say.
Defin should trigger though.
>> Yep. And that is perhaps going to either
take away the Rex eye breacher.
>> Well, I'm not I was just going to list
all the options, but yeah, it's
definitely going to take away one card,
>> but it is really important to remove
this card if there is a potential baited
hook. don't want to give a big
conquer perhaps get into combat and then
baited hook. So that is where the deck
really starts running away.
>> Now this is interesting. This is how you
really have to temper LeBlanc. Remove
the units and threaten the board and
start taking points quickly. I think
Borcart is doing a fantastic job of that
right now. Reestablishing the Kaiser
with a Noxus hopeful as well. As you say
without units in play, baited hook not
an option. Reflections not an option.
Hector needs a unit to stick at some
point.
>> Will this be the turn?
>> Big problem for Hector is that all of
this all of these units that he can
play, they are costly. They are costing
power
>> and it is getting significantly harder
to get to a good beta turn. White Ray
can also have some value out of this.
So, let's see if he's actually going to
keep that ruined Rex around. If not,
that is going to be phenomenal for
Volkata. Can you imagine Volcata having
a two drop in this game? That would have
been such a huge advantage.
>> Yeah, it really would have been. Okay,
is over to Varta now. Can we remove that
ruined Rex?
>> Can you imagine Star Frost here?
>> Yeah.
>> Here we go.
>> Vision.
>> Yes. Vining shells.
>> Okay. Y
>> sorry I always forget to
>> So he saw the vision and now is going to
conquer with Kaisa. That's going to give
a draw. That's going to give a discard
and a draw for the zones. Varants that
is out.
>> We discard under Titan. And now we are
triggering the void borrow. That dredger
is just perfect together with a draw we
found off of the Kaiser or the Z warren
because we talked about units that need
to stick on the side of Hector TCG and C
the week would do the trick.
>> I imagine we're most likely going to see
that call the week now. Right, remove
that ruined Rex. Here we are going to
see two. Do we see the recycle one? I
think that means call the week is
getting played. Leo Hector cannot get a
unit to stick on board. Volcata is
playing this perfectly. going to remove
the Karon dredger which then can
obviously replace itself with a bird
token as well.
>> And now we're actually taking units from
the backline. And I love that play from
Hector. Yeah, I mean it's a little bit
of damage control right now, right? But
just saying, hey, I know that you're
getting even more cards if you if you
keep conquering. So I'm not going to get
that Kaiser away from you even though
that unit screams deal four damage to
me. But you're just basically saying,
hey, I'm going to remove the units from
your backline. You can hold. I don't
love that you're holding this, but you
can hold and then you won't get your
conquer triggers. Even though the
question stands in the room, is it too
late? I mean, we're currently looking at
a five two point discrepancy.
Hexa, what do we Okay, here's the glass
mixologist. This is an interesting one,
right? because this cannot well it can
get removed of course but it has that
death ability where you can play a unit
from your trash for free or less and put
it straight into play replacing itself.
Oh, mirror image. Okay, now now we're
talking. This is where LeBlanc starts to
get rolling. We're going to copy and
make a reflection of that glass
mixologist.
>> And that reflection is going to be able
to conquer one of the two battlefields.
question is do we want to go into the
zones warren or do we want to go into
the star spring
>> is going to go zones wars and says we're
going next immediately because not
getting out of that pickle
>> I'm stunned what a quick game that was
LeBlanc faltering hectar currently one
game down here
takes game one that Rexai quite honestly
was off to the races [music] at the
first hurdle and now has to respond.
>> That is the age-old rivalry between
aggro and control. Even if aggro is not
off to the races, not having the best
start, missing a two drop, which usually
is crucial, that takes you out straight
up.
Could manage to find the tempo again.
And Leblanc, honestly, sometimes your
hands are just so so filled with sticky
units, you don't even
>> get the baited hook rolling. Did not get
to play the deck at all. This feels like
the deck that we've seen in the
beginning of the tournament in round two
where the Dazzling Aurora versus
Squirtle was just not found at all. This
is basically what happens here as well.
Baited Hook feels a little bit like
Dazzling Aurora, just not quite as much,
but it needs a lot more setup. Yeah, I
think if you was to sort of ask a
Leblanc player there, you know, do you
want to be dropping two ruin Rex instead
of like a glassologist? Be like, no, I'd
rather a glassologist to be perfectly
honest. That has a little bit more
sticking power [music]
and a little bit more ways to replace
itself. But have to play the cards that
you're drawn unfortunately. So now he
currently finds himself in a 01 game
deficit. So we'll have to plot a reverse
sweep. Now this is interesting really.
We do get to consult our side decks here
and we'll place some cards and obviously
go first as well. That could be the
advantage he needs in his game, too.
>> He had almost everything set up. It was
a Z warren game, which is not the the
strongest battlefield. This is usually
not your absolute power battlefield
index.
>> Y
>> two drop was missed by Rexi. Still
couldn't manage to overcome the deck.
Also, keep in mind everyone at home, we
do not have a second feature match for
this round because there is no round
following this. So this is the last
round of the day. So after this first
match up, we are done for the day. Going
to have a quick interview, I reckon. But
that's going to be it then. So we're
going into game two. Both of these rift
bounders at 70. Prime position to go to
day two. But you of course
>> want to end on a win. You want to end on
the highest of notes possible being
undefeated after day one.
>> Exactly. So they both have done a
fantastic job. But the thing is, as we
did say in previous rounds, if you want
to try and get yourself to a top eight
and beyond,
>> you need all the match points you can
get. So even though you are in this 70
record, but that's great. But I'm sure
you ask both players now, do you mind
losing this one? They're both like, no,
I'd rather win. So it looks like our
battle for choice here. Windswept
Hillock against the forbidden waste.
That windswept Hill is an interesting
one. Units here have ganking
that can let those reflections start to
get a little bit silly. But here we go.
Swiss round eight game two feature match
getting started well on our mulligan
phase
>> and not seeing
>> oh
>> that is
>> that doesn't look good Leo
>> I mean he gets three draws
>> this is true this is true
they need to be good though that's not
what you want when you're in a 01
deficit
>> especially not game
>> yes
>> that is that is very very important that
you are not missing your two drop here
because this is what the windswept look
this builds for, right? You want to set
up some points that you either yourself
agreeing down your opponent.
>> Is it going to happen again? How many
times do people miss their darn two
drops in this tournament?
>> Too many. Too many. And Volcata
immediately gets the champion unit into
play. Does Hector I unless he drew a
unit. I'm not sure he did, by the way.
We might be seeing no units here.
>> No, that would be crazy. I guess you
have the champion at the very least, but
okay.
>> Also, it's I find it very interesting
that Volcata decided to Oh,
>> it is going to be the bailout champion.
Leo,
>> I don't think things are going well for
Hector, but Volcarta, can he close the
door of opportunity on Hector here and
advance to that perfect 8 and0 record?
We're going to go charging in the wind
stret have ganking for next turn.
Very interesting that we decided to
start with the Rexai breacher
>> because that one can be useful in the
end game as well. Kan Dger is now being
played. The question is do we see a call
the week immediately. Oh, that is huge.
I think that would actually really
really
>> like to see one of those call the week
plays because you get the inferno
basically for free and then you can call
the week sack your own carry on dredger.
That would be rude if there was
[laughter] a call the week this turn.
>> Oh, accelerates.
>> Oh, of course. Could you get played
anywhere?
>> Yeah, I think we do not care about power
at all anymore. And afterwards,
>> oh, there's a call of the weak. Leo
Varta, someone check the fire alarms in
here cuz he's drawing that heat right
now. Immediately closing the door on
Hector again.
>> Trying to immediately run away,
identifying, hey, I'm going second
versus Hook Leblanc. have the chance of
a double conquer in my second turn. I
will take those. Go up to four
afterwards. You can then push out all of
your units. But that is still where
Leblanc is going to become dangerous.
You have temporarily taken care of the
issues. But what are we seeing in Wait,
wait, wait, wait. Was that a Oh, I
thought that was a pass already because
Wata was flipping those runes. No, we
develop a Carus for the first time now.
Carus with watchful sentry. That is not
the most might I have ever seen on a
single board. However, that is already
kind of two draws as well. But next
turn,
>> Hector is only going to be at six ruins.
So, the biggest Unity could play is a
ruin tricks.
>> Yeah, that would need to actually, you
know, die before it has its maximum use.
But with Carus, we get to use twice.
Carus, you know, triggering death nails
twice. It's like Var is going to move
both those units back. Is that hand a
little?
Okay, now we have the Kaiser that is
already a really really strong unit, but
not being able to conquer in a turn like
a double conquer in the first turn kind
of whiffs one of your legend abilities
and you are missing out on the one on
the next turn. However,
I think going second versus Leblanc, you
take any point you get over one card
that you can flip off the top.
>> I would take that wholeheartedly as
well.
So it looks like are we still on Varta's
turn here or
>> that was like it that was like it was
meant to be really just showing the the
under titan getting the inferna being
three runes that are still ready so you
can accelerate it and then kill the weak
on curve everything perfectly fine
there's a lot of things that had to come
together
>> for sure that's the thing about you say
these aggro decks right you say that
that those sort of turns they can happen
I'm sure if you ask for cut. Yeah. How
many times have those sort of things
panned out?
>> You say hopefully you
>> and I forgot to radiate.
>> You used it this turn. You hit the under
Titan.
>> I
>> I hold it like I used it last turn and I
forgot to untap it.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Sorry.
>> All right. Just got this uh sorted real
quick. I'm also one of the big uh legend
untapper forgetters
>> for sure.
>> They stay exhausted every single time.
>> I'm exactly the same. He was at home.
I'm a volie bear player. So I'm not like
playing anything too crazy myself. But
yeah, that volar does stay exhausted.
Is over to Hector now though. Has got
units to stick. Hasn't actually managed
to do that too much in this best of
three. But here we go. We're going in
with a conquer.
>> I think we're going to start boarding
the value train now.
>> There we go.
>> This is where things get silly. Death
nil obviously would be applauded times
two. Reflection. and we can make that
reflection token.
>> I think you're spot on about that. But
Silly doesn't score too many points most
of the time. So, I think we're going to
get two and we're going to draw so many
cards for these watchful sentries. But
yeah, how much are we going to profit
off of that? Still only six runes
available and your opponent is going to
threaten to go to six.
>> Mhm.
>> The magic number in Riftbound.
>> Yeah, that's where things start to get a
little bit scary.
are currently at two for our Leblanc
player here. Remember, if he wants to go
to that perfect 8 and0 record, winning
this game is a non-negotiable.
>> Oh, develops a VI in base.
>> That's a very sensible play.
However, it's not one that feels so
great.
>> Now, you'd love to be playing those
ambush units. Crash, bang, wall up.
Unfortunately, that's not going to be
the case here. Is over to Volca. Was
that cold or
>> so? You are on Hector's side forfeiting
>> sorry
>> fifth and sixth point. There is no way
you're holding that. There is no way
you're holding that. You're going to
give away one Rexai activated ability
plus Kai'Sa draw. That is already huge.
And then Kata has another K the week in
hand and then you will have to decide do
I give up my Vi or do you give up my
Kus. If you give up Vi you will never be
able to push into those battlefields and
then you're probably going to lose on
the spot. If you give up Carus, you are
giving up so much value for the rest of
the game. But
>> if you give up the V, the rest of the
game might be incredibly short.
>> It's a tough decision. Let's see what
Hector pans out. If that is what Vodka
is eyeing up here, if he hits a falling
star off the top, I'm going to scream my
lungs out.
>> I'm going to hold you to that. I'm going
to hold you to that. We are gonna see
the bird go crashing in the
>> the
in case viewers didn't know how bird
sounds good. We got Leo here. [laughter]
We are gonna see the death nil trigger
of course times two. That is going to
put Varta on five.
You can have 20 cards in hand. If you
don't get the points, if you don't stop
the points, that does not matter. And
also there are so many decks like Diana.
If you have 20 cards in hand and seven
runes up, you can have so many different
plays. In hookblanc it is so limited.
You need these
starts where you ramp up a lot. Now we
we haven't used legend.
>> No. Here we go. Remember falling star.
You have to scream.
>> I didn't forget that.
>> Only if he uses it.
>> So we draw first. And that is a falling
star.
That one looks [laughter] incredible.
>> There's no way that happens. That might
immediately snipe away the VI. You have
the call the week in hand. That is Rexi
Gaming.
>> That is riftbound everybody. Absolutely
ridiculous. There's the call the week.
There's the board wipe. Volca said, "How
dare you have units in play, Hector, not
on my watch. They are all gone." Vulcata
is firmly in control of this board.
Firmly in control of this game, marching
towards the 8 and0 record. Hector my
friend, what can you do?
>> Volca even hiding another card there for
extra card draw is developed in base.
Two battlefields. One is his, the other
one is open. He's at six points. Two
points. He has all the time in the
world. Hector instead he is racing
towards nothing. He really needs to out
everything. What can you do with your
Leblanc deck? The units, they are clunky
or weak. The spells, they do not remove
anything. What can you do? You don't
have enough runes for an accelerated
watcher. Hector is shaking his head
slowly but surely.
>> I think that a thousand tailed watcher
would be ideal, but as you say, one rune
off be able to get that in play
accelerated. I believe this is going to
be scary. I mean, if you just put it
down. Yeah, we have to just put it down.
>> That is eight.
>> Oh, yes. We have the sacrifice last
turn.
>> Okay. Okay. Here we go. Oh, it's just
going to be the hidden blade and Hector
will concede. Volcata advances to a
perfect 8 and0 record with the Rexai
masterclass. Congratulations to Volcata.
The stars are falling from the skies
onto Hector's Leblanc units and Volcata
dug himself an 8 into day two. Rexai
undefeated, baby. Wow. that I tell you
what if Rex does that every day game
which apparently it must have been if
he's eight and zero that looks rather
terrifying to sort of how often do you
get these aggro decks I can just oh you
know let me just get a falling star this
turn there we go [laughter]
absolutely insane
>> I conquer for free and it's six damage
to units in your base
>> yes oh you want to try and charge in
last turn hidden blade stop that
honestly absolutely insane
poetry emotion watching I tell if Rex
carries on like that. It's already 8
and0. I wouldn't be surprised to see it
in a top coat and beyond.
>> And Hector, he just honestly some games
you just need to forget, right? It
wasn't meant to be. Everything went
perfect for his opponent. Hector had no
say in this game whatsoever. There was
no agenda in any of the games. It looked
dicey in the first game with the missed
two drop.
>> Yeah. But after that, it was fullon
aggro. All of these all of these reveals
as well in game two. How insane is that?
That you first get the under titan off
top plus the inferna that you can
accelerate and then in the end game hit
the falling star when you need it. So
your c the week takes away the last unit
when your opponent is already decimated
on runes while you are accumulating
points and points and points. That was I
think that was the top end for Rexi.
That is you cannot have a better game as
Rexi.
>> Uh can't get any better than that.
What's that Leo
>> the star falling star? Oh my goodness.
Coming in at the perfect time. You
called it. He said, "If it comes here,
I'm going to have to start screaming the
hell's your T." Fair play you did. But
yeah, that was But this is one thing I
want to talk about a little bit though
is this LeBl we've seen when it gets to
that late game.
It's silly. You know, baited hook here,
reflection there, ganking hit get. But
what I have seen is that if you can stop
it getting there, if you can remove
those units, deny the carus, deny the
draw, deny the glass mixologist, it can
look like you're just hand back down,
can't do anything. back over to you.
>> Playing versus Leblanc is very
counterintuitive. When you see like
>> those units that have powerful death
nail effects, the last thing you think
about is just I need to remove them
immediately. You think, hey, maybe I
want to bounce them or something. Okay,
fury and order doesn't really have so
much bouncing in them. But you have to
take all of those units away from their
field because if they start to build up
anything, you have to be aware that all
of your units will get traded away. You
have to basically throw in everything,
get rid of their units so they can't
start getting value off of off the
baited hook.
>> Yeah, you're right. I'm sure he didn't
really want to have to swing into those
ruin wrecks. That's exactly what
happened. But now we can hear from the
winner himself. So, it's over to the
lounge of Barrett.
>> Welcome everybody. I'm John here with
Vulcata who just proved that Fury is
here to stay in the format. You are 8
and0 with Rexai here at the regional
qualifier in Utre. And I've got to ask
you, that was such a good performance on
a deck that I don't think anyone has
been playing basically since Spirit
Forged.
How many Chaos decks have you been
running into? Because I feel like Vex
Apathetic is really rough sometimes, but
we just saw there at least in that
matchup, the removal of the deck is
unmatched. So, how has your day been
overall?
Well, Vex is not a problem at all. You
have all if you have to you play all the
cleaves and every card that can deal
with it and you are mainly a board
centric deck. You you you flood the
board with units and vex is not a
problem anymore. Of course, you play the
ambush cards because they are good.
They're units etc. And
that's how I deal with the chaos. And
chaos is it's a pretty surprisingly
really good matchup. Uh because like Vex
is a four mana for Mite unit like it's
it's nothing.
>> No, you're right. I mean and you just
proved us too that the deck is so good
at finding extra tools. As long as you
can keep getting onto those
battlefields, you find the stuff on the
top, the falling star to help remove the
VI, the Cole the weak in the hand, a
master class like our casters described.
But you were telling me a little bit
right before we went live, but you were
saying that the Leblanc matchup is maybe
not the best for you in testing.
>> Yeah. Well, my my list is not super
aggressive. It's aggressive, but not
from like if you see other list that
play a lot of tokens, etc. I play more
mid-rangey. So, if Lebanon can start
rolling, it can get hard. But I was
lucky to get to find all my outs. And
yeah, I won that game.
>> And my last question or what I want to
point out is Volcat, you are 8 and0.
>> Yes.
>> Your day is over.
>> Yes. You are a few people joining them
tomorrow. So, you of course need to get
your sleep. How does that feel right
now?
>> I'm tired.
>> That's what it is.
>> That's how I feel.
>> Perfect. Well, with that in mind, I'm
going to make sure that you can get some
sleep. We all want to get out of here as
soon as we can because we've got another
long day tomorrow, including yourself.
So, we're going to send it back.
Yeah, we have got a long day coming
tomorrow and he's going to find himself
there at that perfect 8 and0 reckon. I
find it interesting to hear him say,
"Oh, you know what? I don't think I've
actually built my deck best for the
Leblanc matchup. Could have me." Yeah, I
mean there are cards like Falling Stars
which do help in the Leblanc matchup
actually, but they are not ideal. You
have this token spam. It was not the
most aggressive list. You have a lot of
value cards like Kai'Sa. Many players
have cut Kai'Sa from their Rexalis quite
a while ago because you know you get the
value of the top of your deck not by
drawing those. You don't want to always
have them. But with other cards like V
peacekeeper that you want to draw and
you want to utilize from hand, I feel
like this almost mid-rangey approach is
quite nice. Also, honorable mention
no arena's greatest. Oh yes, a good
point actually. Why do you reckon that
was?
It's a candlelet the other one that's I
mean sometimes if you're saying I don't
want to play too aggro it does just make
sense right you don't need it you want
to get some more value out of it
forbidden waste is a really really nice
setup as well if you're trying to push
into those battlefields and the zone
warrants I really liked it because
actually when you play
>> that deck sometimes you have the issue
of just drawing all of those under
titans and removal spells that you
sometimes don't need and then you can
just discard them and draw a new card
that's nice
>> yeah I think you're so right but now we
can actually ready to have a nice little
day wrap up. Let's kick it over to the
lounge and hear from them.
>> Thank you both. Great job today. Um some
real fun rounds, really fun games and
casts. Uh what a what a great first day.
Day one in the books for RQ.
>> Honestly, what more can you ask? We've
seen a healthy slice of the meta. We've
seen innovation in both Aurora decks and
see a Jin go 5 on. What more can you
demand from a day one? It had it all.
Yeah. What more could you ask for? Well,
you could ask for a second day and that
will end up coming. But uh what we had
today, did we predict what we would see?
I don't think anybody really predicted
the entire day, but there were a few
things that we uh we caught up on as uh
James and Banner here to take you
through just the last few minutes of
today's show. So, when we looked at what
we were expecting coming in, you know
what?
I picked Diana because of Alan. Did you
pick set because of Colin? Cuz both came
true today.
>> I feel like you kind of you you can't
say set and not mention Colin. I think
across the board we're we're pretty on
it except for well Pike. Maybe there's a
day two miracle. We saw some Pike,
>> but we have Rexi undefeated. We have
Allen on Diana. Colin doing an stellar
job on the set. I I think we have a
pretty healthy spread throughout. Yeah,
I'm I'm sure we'll see some Pike players
in in the last rounds as well as we tidy
up the final standings for the day. We
won't actually have those available to
close out the show today just because uh
over in the playing hall, everyone's
still deep into the last round of the
day. So, no no way that we're going to
end up having the full standings for
everybody that. But we can go through
some of those players to watch. I know
that Jibs, for instance, our Jin player
that was 5-0 after round five, ended up
dropping the game to Colin, picked up
the next game and is, you know, fighting
to go seven and one potentially, uh, you
know, on that 6 and2 71 tipping point,
but has made it to day two. A stellar
job. I mean, I I'm not sure if plenty of
people had a day two appearance from Jin
on their bingo card. I sure hadn't.
>> Yeah. Well, now now it certainly is.
Although the bingo card is just four,
right? So, so just when the when the
number comes out, you're like, four,
great. I get the whole thing. Uh, Full
House, Line, all of that with the bingo
references, the I'm not a big bingo fan.
It's not my favorite tabletop game,
which Riftbound would be instead. Is
>> that sounds like a skill issue to me.
>> Exactly. [laughter] Exactly. Too much
too much luck in that uh game. Um,
however, we are honing in now on our day
two performance. And what does day two
have in store for us? Well, day two is
five more rounds of Swiss and then a top
eight cut. So, everything still to play
for these five rounds of Swiss on day
two in an RQ are some of the sweatiest
rounds of ripound you'll find cuz
people, especially those four first four
rounds before IDs become a thing, are
like, "Hey, I I need to win every single
game here."
>> It gets serious cuz there's a lot on the
line still. What adds to this is temp
the energies are falling every every
game. You have spent many of these
players are spending it all on day one.
It's really hard to show up day two on
that same level. How many times have we
seen people go eight on and not make it
to a top cut?
>> Yeah, there are plenty of players in the
running, but not a lot of spots. Only
those top eight, of course, that we're
looking for. Obviously more prizing on
the line with the top 64 placements plus
the best of cards that as we get into
day two tomorrow we will track all of
the best offs that we have to give out.
But that's a day two thing for now.
We're going to wrap up here. That's the
end of our day. Join us tomorrow 10 a.m.
CST
for day two of RQ Utre. We're going to
look to crown our third European RQ
champion. We'll see you in the morning.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Come on.
Black.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey,
hey,
hey.